hi everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel
our topic for today is tableau full
course
in this full course we will be covering
a brief introduction to tableau then we
begin with the tableau tutorial
later we will understand the functions
in tableau advancing ahead we will learn
the parameters in tableau we will learn
how to get connected with data
next we will understand the lod
expressions in tableau
after lod expressions we will dive into
the data blending in tableau we'll be
covering once we are done with
fundamentals we will get started with
charts and tableau tutorials later we
will learn to design a dashboard in
tableau
once we are done with charts and
dashboards we will get started with some
projects and tab connected
finally we will go through some
important interview questions in tableau
hope we are good with the agenda for
today's discussion now let us begin with
the session
so what is w
so before we understand what exactly is
w let us imagine a simple situation
imagine that you are an office worker
and you get some loads of data
uh maybe like millions of rows or
billions of rows and you are supposed to
extract the insights of that particular
data
so what do you do you basically load
that data into a database and try to
write the sql commands and then try to
extract the
insights of that particular data
so this kind of approach is basically
time consuming and you get exhausted
now
what if you had a tool
which could write all the sql commands
for you in the background and all you
had to do is just to drag and drop the
data
sounds interesting right
so tableau is just the same all you have
to do is just drag and drop the data and
it will automatically write all the sql
commands you ever wanted to write on
that particular data and it will give
you
live data interactions and advices for
the future
now with this let us understand the
definition of w so basically tableau is
a business an analytical software tool
developed in america w helps people to
understand visualize and make data
driven decisions in real time with
extreme agility and accuracy
now with this let us continue with the
next topic which will be about the
various versions of w so at first we
have the table you desktop so tableau
desktop is a data visualization
application to facilitate you to examine
virtually any kind of structured data
and generate highly interactive
beautiful graphs dashboards and reports
within minutes once a quick installation
you can tie to virtually any data source
from spreadsheets to data warehouses and
display information in several graphic
perspectives designed to be easy to
utilize you'll be working more rapidly
than ever before
next we have the w server it is a
business intelligence application that
offers browser-based analytics anyone
can utilize it is a rapid fire
alternative to the slow pace of
traditional business intelligence
software it is an online solution meant
for sharing distributing and
collaborating on content created in w
what makes w different it is proposed to
everyone there is no scripting required
so everyone can grow to be an analytics
expert you can grow your deployment as
you require it
train online for free find answers in
minutes and not in months that's the
specialty of w
now followed by the w server we have w
online
so w online is a business intelligence
application that offers browser-based
analytics anyone can utilize as
discussed before it is a rapid fire
alternative to slow paced additional
business intelligence software so
tableau online is a secure cloud-based
solution for sharing and collaborating
on tableau views and dashboards next up
we have the tableau public
so now i want to give you guys a serious
heads up if you're a beginner in w w
public is like an open source whatever
the data you choose to work on using
tableau public it goes to public so kind
of like w public is not preferable if
you want to work on your company's
sensitive and confidential data w public
is a free software to facilitate anyone
to get connected to a spreadsheet or a
file and create interactive data
visualizations for the web it is
delivered as a service that permits the
user to be up to and running overnight
with tableau public users can construct
amazing interactive visuals and publish
them quickly without the help of
programmers or id
it is designed for organizations to
facilitate their websites with
interactive data visualizations
there are higher limits on the size of
data you can work with and among other
features you can keep your underlying
data hidden and lastly we have w reader
w reader is a free desktop application
that you can use to open and interact
with data visualizations built in
tableau desktop with tableau reader you
can filter drill down and discover
humongous loads of data now moving ahead
we have the features of w
so these are the few important features
that you might want to consider
those are the first one robust security
tableau takes special care of data and
user security it has a foolproof
security-based authentication and
permission systems for data connections
and users access
w also gives you the freedom to
integrate with other security protocols
such as active directory kerberos etc an
important point to note here is that the
w practices
low level filtering which helps in
keeping the data secure followed by that
we have the collaboration and sharing
feature
tableau provides convenient options to
collaborate with other users and
instantly share data in the form of
visualizations sheets dashboards etc in
real time it allows you to securely
share data from various data sources
such as on-premise on cloud hybrid etc
instant and easy collaboration and data
sharing helps in
getting quick reviews or feedback on
data leading to a better overall
analysis of it
another extremely useful feature of
tableau is the use of time series and
forecasting
easy creation of trend lines and
forecasting is possible due to tableau's
powerful backend and dynamic frontend
you can easily get data predictions such
as a forecast or a trendline by simply
selecting some options and drag and drop
operations using your concern fields
next up we have live and in memory data
tableau ensures connectivity with both
live data sources and data extraction
from external sources as in memory data
this gives the user the flexibility to
use the data from more than one type of
data source without any restrictions
you can use data directly from data
source by establishing live data
connections or keep that data in memory
by extracting data from a data source as
per their requirement
tableau provides additional features to
support data connectivity such as an
automatic extract refreshes notifying
the user upon live connection fail etc
next we have informative view and even
the mobile view one of the key features
of w and the one that got its popularity
is its wide range of visualizations
in w you can make visualizations such as
bar chart pie chart gantt chart billet
chart motion chart tree map box plot and
many more
like you name it w got it you can select
and create any kind of visualizations
easily by selecting the visualization
type from the xiaomi tab apart from that
it is capable to represent data in
mobile view as well tableau acknowledges
the importance of mobile phones in
today's world and provides the mobile
versions of tableau app
the next and the last feature is that
being capable of accessing data from
various kinds of data sources
tableau offers a wide range of data
source options where you can get
connected and fetch data from data
sources ranging from on-premise files
spreadsheets relational databases
non-relational databases online cloud
data for data warehouses and many more
so followed by the features now we'll
discuss about the advantages of w
so following are the advantages of using
w first one it has remarkable
visualization capabilities
of course the unparalleled capabilities
of visualizing information is on top of
the list of tableau's software benefits
followed by that we have the ease of use
the tools intuitive manner of creating
graphics and a user-friendly interface
allows non-developers to utilize the
basic apps functionalities to the
fullest users arrange raw data into
catchy diagrams in a drag-and-drop way
which facilitates information analyzing
and eliminates the need for the help of
iit department and patent building
next high performance apart from its
high visualization functionality uses
rates its overall performance as robust
and reliable
the tool also operates fast on big data
which makes it powerful performance on
an important point on the list of the
advantages of w
and next is the mobile friendliness
one of our best advantages out of the
tableau benefits is its efficient mobile
application which is available for both
ios and android it adds mobility to
tableau users and allows them to keep
statistics at their fingertips as well
as supports their functionality that
desktop and online versions have
and finally we have the thriving
community and forum
w has a rich community the number of w
fans who invest their expertise and
skills in the community is increasing
rapidly
business users can beef up their
knowledge on data parsing and reporting
and get many useful insights in this
community
also forum visitors are ready to help
settle any user issues and also share
their experience
next up we have the disadvantages of w
the first major disadvantage is the high
cost
the tableau is not the most expensive
visualization software especially
compared to such business intelligent
giant such as oracles and ibm solutions
all the same the license is quite costly
for small and medium companies which
makes it one of the considerable tables
disadvantages
next is the inflexible pricing tableau
sales team is not flexible enough to
provide case-by-case approach for their
customers ignoring the fact that each
company has its own unique requirements
for visualization tool package the
tableau sales model requires clients to
purchase and extend license from the
start
as a result a lot of companies that use
w arrive at the conclusion that they
don't need all their license features
they would prefer to buying a set of
requirements and scale them if necessary
followed by that the next disadvantage
is poor after sales support on multiple
message boards users complain that w
software lacks proper after sales
maintenance if customer has software
performance problem the support team
does not settle the matter by
investigating the problems root and
eliminating it
next we have the power bi capability or
the poor business intelligence
capability as previously mentioned the
tool provides best-in-class information
visual interpretation however it lacks
the functionality required for a fully
fledged business intelligence tool such
as large-scale reporting the building of
data tables and statistics layouts
and lastly the poor versioning only the
recent tableau version support revision
history while for the older ones
software rolling back is impossible now
with the advantages and disadvantages
discussed let's move into the top
companies hiring the companies which are
desperately looking for tableau experts
are accenture ey pepsico deloitte
wells fargo cab gemini and many more
now let's discuss the
humongous and handsome salaries offered
by this tech giants
so according to glassdoor the average
salary of a tableau expert in america is
82 000 grands and for a beginner it is
somewhere around 60 000 dollars per
annum and at the highest rate it is 1
lakh 10 000 dollars per annum similarly
the average salary of a tableau expert
in india is 5 lakh 6 000 per annum and
for a beginner it is somewhere around 3
lakh 60 000 and
and for a highly skilled experienced
tableau expert the salaries range from 8
lakhs 75 000 per annum here's a story
about these two gentlemen talking about
tableau the first gentleman comments on
how the ipl cricket league was very
entertaining this year and how he
believes that de villiers scored the
maximum runs but the second gentleman
says he has stats which shows that khali
outperformed this time how did you come
up with these stats there's a tool that
helps visualize data by creating
interactive charts and graphs it's
basically a business intelligence tool
used by many organizations for visual
data analysis tableau helps us gain
insights by visualizing the data that
you already have so tableau is important
when it comes to visualization it has
many advantages first it has speed of
analysis so you can get into your data
and start analyzing it very quickly
second it helps users be self-reliant
and not rely on very difficult analytics
tools to start digging into their data
third it allows you to do visual
discovery so as you're building you can
learn information and insights about
your data four you can use it to blend
diverse data sets and five you can use
the data sets that are centralized so
after you've put together a data set you
can publish it out and more people can
use it than just you that sounds
interesting how about we visually show
the stats of ipl so first we'll look at
connecting to data this will be the
first step in tableau
so if you have opened up your workbook
and you see this page you can click here
connect data
and we're going to choose a text file
and we're going to join our deliveries
data
to
our matches data so we click deliveries
at broaden deliveries and we can click
add
and bring in another text file called
matches
next we'll talk about joins we will make
use of joins when we have multiple data
sets to work with suppose we want to
join these two data sets one of which
has a team id and what city that team is
in the other one has a team id and tells
you the name of the team there are four
ways to join data sets an inner join the
resulting table contains values that
have matches in both tables so we can
see here that we have delhi and the deli
daredevils we also have chennai and the
nice super kings we have bangalore and
then we have this team that doesn't
exist in bangalore and so since these
two don't match since we have two two
three three but then we have four and
six these two don't exist in our
resulting table because they don't have
matches in both tables in a left join
resulting table contains all values from
the left table and the corresponding
matches from the right table so we have
delhi chennai and bangalore and then we
have their matches however bangalore
does not have a match so it is let null
in a right join we have the opposite the
resulting table contains all matches
from the right table and the
corresponding matches from the left
table so we have the daredevils the
super king and then we have king punjab
and they all exist however number six
does not have a corresponding city and
so that's left null and in a full outer
join the resulting table contains all
values from both tables so we still have
delhi and chennai and we have bangalore
and we have the kings but their nulls
their corresponding nulls exist as well
so since this one doesn't have a match
it still shows up but you get a null and
then this one doesn't have a match it
also still shows up and you get a null
now it's going to
allow us to join our two
different data files and together
so we have to decide which field to join
on in this case it is match id
and then on the matches it's just called
id
and that is id
we'll do an inner join that will select
only the records that match between the
two fields
so it's given us some
sample data underneath from our two
things and we look at match id here and
where it's one
here
scroll over and see that it's one here
for id
if we scroll down and find a different
number so here we have two
for id and we scroll over and match id
is now two
and we have our join in place dimensions
and measures dimensions are qualitative
fields that cannot be aggregated for
example batsman and batting team etc
however measures are numerical values
that mathematical functions can work on
like batsman runs and extras so for the
case of batsman runs you can sum up all
of the runs for an entire game or that
took place in a city or for an
individual batsman and that's how you
can tell that it works with a
mathematical function now we'll move on
to the last part of dashboard designing
so we can move on to
sheet1
and we'll take a second and load our
query
and now we have
the
worksheet space and this is where we can
build our visualization
this is called a worksheet you can also
build a dashboard
which is where you can put multiple
worksheets together
and you can build what's called a story
which is where you can take worksheets
and dashboards and put them in
an order to tell a story
so on our worksheet
we'll have this space here in the middle
which is where you can build the
visualization
you have
columns and rows
where you can drag on your data which is
here on the left here's our data
dimensions on top measures on bottom
we'll talk a little bit more about that
in a second
we have columns and rows
where you can drag your information and
it defines where the columns
go or where the data goes to define the
columns where the data goes to define
the rows
we have places here these are our cards
and when you drag things onto these
different cards it will do different
things to your visualization
and
let's talk about our dimensions and
measures so tableau will take its best
guess
at what your data is so it's guessed
that all of these blue fields on the top
are dimensions
and dimensions are
qualitative data so
data that defines
and like describes
the rest of your data and so
usually it can be things like city so
you can say here's a city and then we
can look at our
different
measures by the city that it took place
in for example with financial data you
could pull on city and you could look at
sales by city and city is the dimension
which is a quality and then sales would
be a measure which is something that is
quantitative
and it is able to be aggregated
whereas dimensions are not things you
would like to aggregate so some things
can be
a number
but they're still not a measure such as
a phone number
nobody is going to
want to sum up different people's phone
numbers and see what the sum of the
phone number is however you might want
to look at a customer and see their
phone number
and puts it up in the dimension area
another thing that tableau does in this
case
by default it will make little folders
for your different data sources so we
have our deliveries data source
and our matches data source
we go back to our data source section
that corresponds
to our two different files
you can also look at these sample fields
here and the part where it's blue at the
top represents the blue table
and if we keep dragging we'll see
the orange coming in which represents
the orange table
so here we are back at sheet1
and let's start building our first
visualization
i'm going to right click here click
rename and we're going to call it
matches in each
venue
so we're going to start off by making a
map
tableau has recognized the word city
here and put this little globe next to
it meaning that it has recognized it as
having the geographic role of city
so if i double click on it
it maps out
some cities now it's having a hard time
mapping the cities so we're going to
click edit location
and it
doesn't recognize these places or it
could exist in multiple places because
it's defaulted the country to the united
states
so if we change that defaulted country
to india
then
we have much fewer unknown
fields
so we're going to focus on india
and
not
look at these other
locations because some of these are not
in india and but we're going to make
this visualization for india
specifically if you wanted to show
what countries they were in you can
define
from what field you can find the country
information so if we had two
fields in here one was city and one was
country that told you what country it
was then you would choose this from
field and you'd choose that country
dimension
and that would fix our problem assuming
things were spelled right and put in the
right countries in this case we don't
have country so we have defined india
and that's what we're going to focus
next
we're going to bring city
onto color as well
and now they each have their own colors
and here's our legend
and we want these to have a different
size based on how many matches they've
had
so we're going to bring on id
onto size
and
we
wanted to actually count
those ids so we changed it to account
distinct and now you can see the
littlest ones have around two and as
they get bigger this
to this size is 20 and the size is 85
and when you hover you can see exactly
how many they have
you can adjust the size using this size
marks card
make our circles a little bit bigger
we can adjust our color
by adding a border
maybe like a black border
but then changing the opacity
so we can see through it a little bit
for those that go over borders
and start to overlap
and if we wanted to see the exact number
without having to hover
we could take
this id onto
label
and again
change it to account distinct
there we go
and now you can see exactly how many
there are in each location
you can change where the labels show up
by adjusting the alignment so we could
have it in the center and it kind of
shows up inside their circles but that's
kind of hard to read in these smaller
circles so we could define that we
always want it at the top
or something like that
we could also have it say the city name
so if i drag city on the label
now it shows 9 and then the city but if
i want to change the order of that
see how it does the count and then the
city
i could drag
so you saw right inside of here we have
two that are on labels so they have this
little t inside of a box and now city is
on top
of count
of id so city and then count
we could also allow
people to filter
so if we click show filter here
and if we just want to look it'll zoom
in on the countries you select so if we
just wanted to look at a couple of them
then we could select individual ones
or if we wanted to exclude certain ones
then we can make it easy to exclude
great so now we have our visualization
for matches in each venue next we're
going to make another
worksheet by clicking down here and
we're going to name this one
top
run scores
and this will allow us to be able to
find who scores the top runs and so
we're going to
make
a
visualization
called a tree map
using this show me button we haven't
explored show me yet show me will show
you what visualizations you can build
based on what you've selected
over here so when we selected city it
shows us that we can make maps using
city what we're going to do
is look at
city
and
i'm going to hold control
and click batsman and i'm going to hold
ctrl and click batsman run
and now you can see that tree map is
highlight as filled in not grayed out
anymore so we can select that
and it is showing us
what batsmen
have the most runs
we want the color to be based on city so
let's drag city onto color
and now we can see that it's separated
out by city
and you can see that the person
at the very top right with the biggest
square
has the most runs
but then you also get a second benefit
of being able to know which city seems
to have the most runs associated with it
so it looks like mumbai
has the most runs
let's also filter this information so
let's bring on
batsman runs and we can choose sum
and let's filter out batsmen who didn't
get
a total of
400 runs
there we go so now we only see batsmen
and cities that have a sum bigger than
400 runs
okay so we have city on label but maybe
we just want to be able to see that on
hover so we'll take city off of label
and now we just see
the batsmen who have the highest runs
for each city
and
we'll also bring on
the number of runs
onto the label
so now we can see the batsman in their
runs and exactly how many
runs they have
you can always get to how many they have
based on hover
we'll go on to our next visualization
and that's going to be
win percent
based on
toss
decision
so we're going to see
which
decision you make based on the toss
leads to a win more often so you can
choose to bat or you can choose to field
and if you choose to bad do you win more
than if you choose to field so let's
take a look
we have our toss decision
and we also have
if they won the match or not match
winner
and i'm going to control click toss
decision
and we're going to select pie
so here we have a pie chart that colors
it based on toss decision which is bat
and field
and makes the angle and the size of the
circle based on the match winners now
we're only going to have the
angle be based on match winner or not
and then we can define the size ourself
so we can make it bigger
i'm going to change this visualization
to fit the entire view so that we can
see the pi better
great but we don't see a percentage so
let's change this sum
of match winners to a table calculation
so we're going to click add table
calculation
and we're going to change it to percent
of total
we'll close that so now when we hover it
says sixty percent of the time matches
were won
by the people who chose filled
and 39 were won by the people who chose
bat
let's make this into a label as well so
i'm going to control drag toss decision
onto label
and what that does is make a copy
and add it to label instead of pulling
it off of color so let's see what
happens if i don't hold ctrl so if i
just drag toss decision on the label it
got rid of it off of color and just put
it on the label and that's confusing
there's two pieces but they don't look
any different
so control drag fixes that will do the
same thing
for
that
match
percent of total that we made match win
percent of total
one of the benefits of having these
labels here
is that it allows you to be able to use
this visualization
even if you take a screenshot and send
it to somebody
and they can't hover over the top and
see what everything means another thing
you can do
is annotate it
and so
we can click annotate the point or the
mark
and it will give you this box and then
it will put in some information that's
showing up in your your tool tip and you
can modify this and
we can change this so it's not bold
anymore or leave it both and when you
hit ok
it is
makes this box that you can move
tells you information about that point
or that mark
when you do the same thing here
and draws a line
and this allows you to
put notes about it you can see that
these parts
are dynamic so it just fills in toss
decision based on your field from over
here
and it will change if it changes so will
the percent match winner
so for example this is for
everybody over all time
but if we show a filter
for city it adds it to our filters card
up here and then we could filter it to
just
the city
and you can see that they have updated
and
in this city
they have more people who have chosen
to bat win the game
and so you don't end up with
old static information
in either place
but if you did want to make a note
manually about what you think is
happening here
then you can do that as well
we could also do the same thing with
date
and now you could choose just what year
you want to see so just 2017
and in 2017 the field advantage was a
lot higher
and here's 2016
and that's all time our next
visualization is going to
explore the idea of
if you win the toss how likely you are
to win the game
so we're going to look at historical
data and see what's happened in the past
so we're going to call this
advantage
of toss winning
so we're going to bring on
all of the toss winning
teams and we're going to
also bring on all of the
teams that actually want so
how it works
is we can see
all the teams and then you can see if
they won or not so we're going to
quickly make a couple of changes to this
the first one is
this team
changed its name
to this team name so we're going to
group those two teams into the same
group so that they are treated
like just one
and we're going to create a group based
off of
winner
and we're going to grab the two team
names by control clicking
and click group
and it puts them together
let's replace winner with our winner
group
there you go so now you can see
those two teams are together
do the same thing with toss winner
create
group
one disadvantage to creating a group
is that it's very manual
and so
you have to manually create the group
and you have to manually update it so if
they change their name again you have to
change it again and
[Music]
it's nice to have the functionality and
tableau to make those changes in case
you don't have the functionality to make
the changes to the data source itself
but do keep in mind if you have to
manually group things together you have
to manually keep it updated as well
next we're going to exclude some data
so
we have this null here that we'll just
click exclude on
because that would be perhaps when a
winner was not declared
and we're going to remove some of these
teams that have holes in their analysis
and that could happen because they
didn't play all of the teams or
so there was never a match with that
team
and so
here for example
they
played and they could have won
or this team could have won this team
could have won or this team could have
won
but these other teams don't seem to have
any matches against them so we can
come across here for the winners and
i'll control
the teams
that we're excluding and then we'll just
come over here to exclude and you can
exclude a bunch at a time it just adds
it to the filters right here so if i
right click on edit filter you can see
all the teams we've excluded
and then we'll do the same thing on the
toss winners
and we'll control click
and exclude and now we are left with all
the teams that seem to have available
data
between them
and now we want to see
of these toss winners
who won the game so we're going to count
all of the matches
and that will
give us the information we need so i'm
going to grab id and put it onto text
now what it's doing is giving me all the
ids so i've got to right click on it and
change it to a measure
and change it to count distinct
and now it will show you
how many matches fit these categories so
for this team
if they won when this team wins the toss
then this team usually wins
which is the same team so i'm gonna
widen this out so we can see
the names
better
so when the super kings win the toss the
super kings
won the game 42 times let's right click
here and we're going to
change it to
a table calculation again
four percent of total
and what that is saying
is that of all the games
where the super kings won the toss
they also won the game 64 of the time
now you can read this with the numbers
fairly easily but it'll be a lot easier
if we can also show in color
so i'm going to change the marks to
square
and i'm going to control drag this onto
color
and now we have
what's called a heat map
and the color is stronger where the
percentage is higher you can see our
range over here
so you can see there's a pretty clear
advantage to the person who wins the
toss
they tend to be the one that wins the
game
when the daredevils win the toss the
person who wins the game the most
is the daredevils
let's take this visualization and use it
to analyze a different feature of the
game so i'm going to right click on the
worksheet and i'm going to click
duplicate so now we have the same
visualization twice
and i will rename it to be called
batting
first advantage
so here instead of toss winner we're
going to bring on batting team
but let's first create a group again
so we're going to don't be confused by
group by that's not the same thing we'll
go to create and click group
we're going to put together
control click the team names that have
merged okay
and
let's drag
you see how it's not up here right next
to batting team that's because
they put the calculated fields that
we've been making outside
of the folders
so
if you're looking for a calculated field
you can scroll down to the very bottom
and let's drag batting group right over
top of toss winner and it will replace
it right out of there
and we have our gaps again
because the toss winners that we
excluded only applied to that toss
winner so i can pull off this toss
winner filter we don't need it anymore
and then we will
control click
on the ones
with the gaps
that we wanted to remove
click exclude okay
and now we have an analysis
showing how the batting team does
in our next visualization we're going to
explore who the leading
batsman is
and this could allow you to find out
who's the best if you were in charge of
putting together your team
so
we can
take all of the batsmen and put it on
row so now we have a list of every
batsman and we can bring batsman runs
onto columns and it will sum up all of
their runs
now what we can do is sort it
from biggest to smallest and we can see
who are our top batsmen
we can bring batsmen on to color so i'm
control dragging again
and then they each get their own color
one nice thing that you could do here is
show it filter it by the team
so here we have like team one and team
two but what we would be doing it is
filtering it on batting team
so we're going to click show filter
and so if you wanted to see
well like this is the best overall but
let's see who was the best to ever work
for this team
and then it will sort it from best
down
and you can switch the team and if we
choose this one we should choose this
one as well
and then we can see who's the best
another thing that could be really
useful is seeing who's the best by year
so we can come here to date and click
show filter and now we can see this is
the best overall of these years but if
we just want to see most recently who's
the best that's a very different story
so filters can be very handy
for looking at a bar chart here
and getting the exact information you
want
we could also maybe just look at the top
five batsman so what we'll do is we'll
drag batsman onto filters and we'll
create a conditional
filter based on top here
by field so we'll say top ten
we wanted to look at the top five so
we'll change that to five
and we're looking at the top five
batsmen based on the sum of their runs
so you could choose something else to
filter it by but we wanted to be based
on their runs and we hit apply
and there we go we just see the top five
and again if you just want to see the
top five for 2017 here's the top five
for 2017.
maybe 2016 and 2017 together
those are your top five
now if we wanted to be able to change
how many we see
and as the developer we could go in
and change it here
but if we wanted our end user to be able
to change it then they can't because
when this is published
you can't change your filters
that you can't change the filters that
are
the top conditional filters we can
change these filters that we show on the
report called quick filters
but not this guy
you can see we can see now that it's
choosing top five
but we we
can't select it
how many so let's get rid of that card
and let's make a parameter that will
allow them to select it so create a
parameter
and we're going to call this top
n
we're going to make it an integer
and it's going to be a range
we'll let them choose
between 5 and
30
and they can go up and down by 5.
we'll click ok so now we have here at
the very bottom parameters
and we can right click on it and click
show parameter control and now we have
this parameter over here called top n
it's set to 5 and then if i change it to
10 nothing's happening
that's because we made the parameter but
we haven't put it anywhere in this sheet
so we're going to put it right inside of
this filter
so you come here and we want to choose
top how many
you can do it based on a parameter and
we'll do it based on our top end
parameter okay
so now when we change it from 5
to 10
the parameter updates the filter
so
in presentation mode the user can come
in and choose how many they want to see
now we've only let them go up 30
but
that's to your discretion you could
have this parameter
do whatever you need
so we could say they can go up to a
hundred
and that changes our parameter now we
have all these little marks in between
and here i chose eighty
or you could even make it
so that they don't have a step size
they just have a range and then they
have just this little slider and it
could be any number in between
but not lower than five and not bigger
than a hundred
let's remove this filter
and we will also
hide this card because
we won't give them the option to choose
how many they want to see in this case
we'll just show them all
so
for this next visualization we're going
to look at our top five
and we're going to see how they do over
time so again we're going to start on by
bringing on our batsmen
but we only want to see our top five so
let's bring batsman on the filters and
we'll do what i just showed with top
five
now since we don't have anything else on
this visualization it's not sure how to
define the top five
so we're going to do it with batsman
runs and we're gonna have the sum of the
batsman runs so top five players over
all time that have
the highest sum of best been runs
highest sum of runs so here we have them
and we're going to bring on their runs
and we'll sort them biggest to smallest
and next we're going to bring on a time
element so we can see it over time so
i'm going to drag date over here
and now it's doing a line chart for
every
with a dot for every year
and i'm going to change year from the
discrete year to the continuous year
so that it's an axis down here and now
we can see that i'm over time we can
bring batsman on onto color so we can
see the different color for each batsman
and here's how they're trending
and then we'll also bring
the batsman runs onto label
and now you can see how many runs they
had
next we're going to take a look at
finding out who our leading bowlers are
so let's bring all of our bowlers onto a
visualization
one way to look at this would maybe be
to see which bowlers have the least runs
associated with them so we can bring the
runs up here and then sort it smallest
to biggest
however they could have very few runs
associated with them because they don't
bowl very often so let's bring on match
id
and change it to be
a measure that is a count
of match ids
and we can see
that the ones a lot of these with the
least amount of runs also have the least
amount of matches
so it's not a very good indicator
we have here what's called a dismissal
kind
and you can see
the reasons that
the batsman was dismissed
and one of them
is hit wicket so you can see any of the
bowlers that hit the wicket
so let's bring dismissal kind on to
filters and we'll just look at those
that hit the wicket
so we have these ones
that have hit the wicket and let's see
how many times they did that so we'll
actually bring on
down here number of records
and we'll sort it biggest the smallest
so now we can see that this bowler
has hit it twice in our limited set of
data
if we include all of the dismissal kinds
except for null so this means that they
were
dismissed for any of these reasons
we can see
which bowlers had the most dismissals
and let's bring bowler
onto color
great then we'll rename it
deleting
bowler we're going to do a similar thing
as we did with top five batsmen with
bowlers so
we could start with this visualization
and replace
by clicking right clicking and click
duplicate
let's bring it to the end
and now
instead of
top five
batsmen
we can change it to bowlers
but first let's bring in our dismissal
kind
and only choose the ones
so here we can click exclude and we're
going to exclude null
and hit apply so we don't have the nulls
anymore we just have the ones that were
dismissed and we're going to bring in
the bowler on top of the filters and
we're gonna have it be based on
the top
count of dismissal kind
top five
okay and
we'll put bowler over top of batsman
and we'll take out the sum of batsman
runs
and put on
our number of records
and batsman didn't get removed when i
pulled bowler on top of it so i must
have accidentally pulled it in front of
it there we go batsman's gone
now here's a disadvantage to making a
copy and then changing it because it's
like what's happening here but it's
because batsman is still on color and
some of batsman is still on runs
so let's take number of records and put
it on to runs
onto the text
and then let's take bowler and put it
onto color
that clears things up quite a bit
so now we can see the bowlers over time
if we take year of date off
we can see which ones are the best
overall and we'll sort it
there we go and then we'll put year back
on
by dragging date up here
right-clicking and changing it to a
continuous there we go so now we have
our top five
and we need to rename this
to top five bowlers
okay
so now we have all these visualizations
and we can start putting them together
into dashboards
so let's make our first dashboard
we're going to have the size
be automatic so it fills the screen here
you have some options with the different
sizes you can have it be a fixed size or
you can define the width and the height
you could also define the width and the
height based on some of these presets
like a desktop browser or a laptop
browser
you could have that be automatic so it
fills the space
now this will have it fill the space on
any screen so they're looking at a much
smaller resolution then it'll try to
squish all of your visualizations into
one size so i don't recommend automatic
for
a lot of visualizations because you need
to have extra space
and or if you define this should be here
and this should be over here then it'll
all squish it all together
there's also a range where it's sort of
like it's automatic and it will adjust
based on what screen you're looking at
it however there is a minimum size
and will never be smaller than that and
a maximum size and will never be bigger
than that
so it won't stretch or shrink your stuff
too far
before adding scroll bars
so here we have automatic
and
our first dashboard so
we're going to rename our dashboard
we're going to call it
overall performance
oh the first one we're going to make is
going to be
looking at venue
and
run
scored
great
so this is our dashboard space so it
says drop sheets here and then these are
our dashboards
and we have other objects down here
that you can also bring on
and then over here we have layout
which after you have brought things on
you can change their layout here
and it will show your item hierarchy
based on how they're nested down here so
on our dashboard
we will first bring in
our matches
and we will bring in our top scorers
and we have
all these different places for matches
and we have
our different cities for our top scorers
and so
if we go back to the sheet top run
scorer we can do that in three ways we
can come down and find the right sheet
and click on it to go to that sheet we
can look at our visualization and click
this go to sheet and it will take us to
that sheet
we'll go back
or we can come over here to our sheets
and click go to sheet and we'll take it
to that sheet so let's take our filters
off of the sum of runs so that we're
showing all runs for all cities
you know what instead
let's just edit it
so it's filtering out
only those
that never scored more than
say 100.
okay so we have a lot more in here but
it will filter out some of the lowest
ones
and we'll go back to our dashboard
and now there's one thing you can do
which is called
an action and so we can click use as
filter
and now when we click on a city over
here it will filter the remaining sheets
on this dashboard to
what you've selected so
we can see
how many matches have been done in
different cities and if we want to see
well who are our best players in mumbai
it will filter down to the top run
scorer
so that's called an action
so let's get rid of that and we'll look
at doing it manually as well so here
under dashboard we have our actions and
you can see there are no actions in here
but then when i come and click uses
filter
then we go to dashboard and actions and
now we have an action called filter1
generated
and what that has done is made an action
based off of the matches in each menu
sheet
and it affects the other sheet on select
and when you unselect see it says
clearing the selection will show all
values and it's doing it based on all
fields
okay
so if we wanted to make a different
action
which is a url action on these two
sheets when you
select
it'll take you to
this website
so this is the wikipedia beginning page
but let's say we wanted to take you to a
specific wikipedia page in wikipedia if
you append on
the name of the wikipedia page to the
end of this url it will take you
straight to that page
and we're going to assume that there's a
wikipedia page for all these different
cities
so we have city put in there
and
if we hit
okay
okay
and now when we click on
city
then it will bring up the wikipedia page
for that city so if we come back and we
unselect that and then we come over here
and we pick
a different city
it'll do the same thing and bring up
that wikipedia page
so right now it's if you click on either
chart it will bring up the wikipedia
page
we can edit that
by maybe changing it
so that it's only when you pick it in
the top scorer
chart
so when you select something over here
it filters the top score chart but when
you select on something in the top
scorer chart it brings up that city
that's just an example and now it's
bringing up that
page on a separate screen so let's
there we go
now we're back okay
and some more things that we can do
is
we'll get rid of this visualization that
is a legend for how big the circles are
and how what that means because we have
the labels right over top of the circle
so we don't need a legend for that we'll
close that
we have the capability of filtering on
city right now
but when we do filter on city
is only affecting this visualization and
not this visualization
so we can change that
by hovering over apply to worksheets and
then changing it to selected worksheets
and clicking all on the dashboard
and when i click show all worksheets in
the workbook you can see the rest of the
worksheets that are not on the dashboard
are not affected
on select okay
and now when i
filter these
it does it in both places
another thing we can do to make this
look a little nicer is make this a
multiple values drop down
so now it's in a drop down form
we can also
a horizontal
object
up here
and put city up inside of there
as kind of like a header
but we can have some more filters
so if we wanted to be able to filter by
the date
we can put the date on filter there
we'll click use all for now
let's go back to our visualization
we'll click on the visualization we
added it to and hover over filters
and look you can add year of date
here it is
let's put it up next to city
and we'll also change it to a multiple
value drop down list and we'll also have
it apply to selected workbooks all on
dashboard
okay
so now we can see
the different years
we only wanted to see maybe 2017 they
both apply
or they apply to both visualizations
there
and we can have those
and we can add a blank object
over here on the other side of city
so that it doesn't take up quite as much
space
we could put a text object up here too
with the
name maybe the whole workbook or
the sheet
there it is but if we want to edit it
and we can make it bold and we can make
it big
and those are some of the things we can
do to
update all of our
different dashboard things
our next dashboard the one that's going
to be about
overall performance
we're going to change it to automatic
again
and we're going to bring in
information about performance so we'll
bring in the leading batsman
and our leading bowler
our top five boulders will go underneath
the bowler information
and our top five batsmen will go
underneath the batsman information you
can see that
any filters we had or any
different legends we had are showing up
here we don't need these legends because
we have the names right next to them so
let's get rid of those
when i clicked on
the bowler in that last visualization or
in the last legend it highlighted that
particular bowler so i had to unselect
it before i closed it out okay and then
we had batting teams filter here
which we will not use
but we will use this year filter and now
if i change it it will only affect this
visualization but i want it to affect
all so again
this is just a good habit to have to
make sure all of your filters affect
everything on the dashboard that you
want it to affect
and that it's very clear which ones it's
affecting
let's give it some space
we can move this whole
piece so along the top here
it doesn't need that much space
and we'll change this
to be a drop down
filter
and it doesn't need all the space
so we can add
some blank to either side
and have it a little bit more
in the middle here
so now
we just want to look at 2017
we can see our leading batsman and our
leading bowlers but then you can't see
it over time anymore so let's
change our minds
and maybe we only wanted to apply to
worksheets these two worksheets
because we want these worksheets to
still show it over time
so if we click
selected worksheets and we remove our
top five top five
now we can see
that these worksheets update and these
ones do not
but one thing to keep in mind is that
these are the top five over all time
whereas these one two three four five
are the top five for this year
and so
these top five are not the same people
you can see
as these top five well this one is
and this one is but it's going to change
and so that's the point
is that
it's important to recognize that these
top five could update
to just the top five for the year we
selected if we still had it applying to
these worksheets
so it's just your call
information over time when filtered to
just one period is
can be not very useful
so
our next dashboard
is going to be
about advantage
and we're just going to make it so that
we can see
the advantage
of the toss
and the advantage of batting just side
by side so let's add a blank up here
blank down here
and it just gives you a visualization
where you can see the advantage
of winning the toss at the advantage of
batting first one thing that we're
seeing here is that we're getting a
scroll bar
because it's too wide to fit in the
selected area
so we could change
the visualization
to fit width
and then it will make this shrink to fit
inside
the area instead of giving us a scroll
bar
we'll do the same thing here fit width
if we change it to entire view
then it will also change the height to
fill this area
view
there we go
so as a recap we have looked at
different ways to look at data so that
you can use it to be
help you in your decisions you can use
it to find out who are your top scorers
in which cities you can use it to figure
out who is the advantage you can use it
to help you figure out if you should
choose to go to the field or to bat you
can find your leading batsman and who
should be worth more to try to get them
on your team same with bowler
and you can put them together into
dashboards that are interactive even out
to websites
today we're going to talk about building
dashboards in tableau based on
cricket data from the indian premier
league please comment below for access
to this data set and somebody from the
simply learn team will get back to you
and then you can follow along if you
have any questions about creating a data
source off of
a text data set then go ahead and
comment below or check out tutorial part
1 in which we go over that information
so we're going to get started and in
this visualization we're going to look
at
batsman information so let me rename the
sheet and i'm going to call it all
innings
score
and so the
by the end of this we're going to have
two visualizations two dashboards one of
them focuses on batsman and one of them
focuses on bowlers some of the use cases
behind this is if you are trying to
figure out who did the best the batsman
and who did the best of the bowlers for
if you were trying to put together a
team so let's get started we're going to
look at batsman
and here we have listed out all the
batsmen we're going to make this
visualization so that you can look at
just one batsman at a time so i'm going
to right click on batsman and click show
filter and now we have a filter over
here with all of our batsmen and we can
choose just one or all of them let's
just look at one for now and then we're
also going to look at their information
across all of their matches
so we're going to bring on match id
and now we have all of the matches for
this batsman now we have quite a few
matches so we're going to allow them to
filter to just one season one year so if
i right click on date and click show
filter it gives me this automatic year
filter so we'll just filter to maybe
2014 and now we have all those matches
for
one year for one batsman
and we want to look at the runs for this
batsman so we'll pull runs out here onto
rows and it now gives us bars for all of
those rows
if we were looking at multiple batsmen
so i select all here
it'll section them out by their names
but it's a little bit difficult to tell
where one batsman ends and one begins
sometimes just it's not that visually
easy even though there are lines so we
could make those lines darker or another
thing we could do is take batsman and
pull it onto color
and now each batsman gets their own
color and it's a lot easier to tell the
difference let's go back to just looking
at one batsman
and let's sort the matches from smallest
to biggest
and as in number of runs so here we have
all the runs for this batsman per match
if we look at multiple batman you can
see how he did as opposed to other
batsmen
there we go
let's
move on to our next visualization
it's going to be about
i'm going to click on the sheet click
rename and click type
type of dismissal
so now we're going to make a chart that
shows you
for one batsman for one
year
what kinds of dismissals they had so
we want the filters we made on all
inning scores over here to also apply to
this worksheet so let's talk about
filters a little bit when we right click
on filters we can click hover over apply
to worksheets and we have these options
we have all using related data sources
all using this data source or only this
worksheet and that's because we haven't
built a second worksheet yet we have
another worksheet but it doesn't have
the batsman information on it
cover right click on here same thing so
when i bring
or any information on this worksheet we
just need to have some information on
this worksheet for it to start being
taken seriously so i drag dismissal on
to color i go back to the sheet right
click and now we should have another
option only this worksheet selected
worksheets all using this data source
are all using related data source we're
going to use the option selected
worksheets now why would we use the
option selected worksheet instead of all
using this data source this is because
we're going to
apply these filters to all of the
batsmen worksheets but as i mentioned
before we're also going to make
visualizations based on the bowlers then
we're not going to use this same filter
on the bowlers worksheets so i'm going
to click selected worksheets
choose my worksheet and hit ok
i'll do the same thing here on year
apply to worksheet selected worksheet
and do the same thing
okay so
because of
filters and because how they can you can
have different filters per worksheet or
one filter that affects two worksheets
but not the other worksheets it's best
in my mind to do all of your filters at
the end when you're actually building
the dashboard so that you can keep track
of what the filter affects and what it
doesn't
in this case for our purposes we've done
it already
so now we're looking at just one batsman
just one year
but my preference is to do it at the end
now we brought on dismissal kind and put
it onto color and i want to make a pie
chart so i'm going to click on marks and
change it to pi
and right now there's nothing telling
this visualization
how big each slice of the pie should be
so you need to drag something onto angle
let's first
make the pie bigger just so that we can
see it better and then let's also
remove the dismissal kind of null
so
we have
null dismissal kind and that's when the
batter batsman did not
get out however
we're trying to keep track of
how many times they did get out so this
isn't relevant so i right clicked on
null over here and clicked exclude what
that did was made a filter right here on
dismissal kind
and we click edit and you can see it's
excluding null so that's what right
clicking and clicking exclude did so
right now it's doing 15 50. it doesn't
know how big to make each angle and we
wanted to count the dismissal kind
and that's how it'll determine how big
to make each angle so i'm going to drag
dismissal kind on an angle and i get an
error why would i get an error i would
get an error because it's treating it
like a dimension and the dimension
is
by definition
not
something you use to
measure things with and so you can't say
this angle should be this big based on a
dimension
so we're going to change it to a measure
which is when we're going to count the
dimensions so
we're going to do a count of dismissal
kind so if they got out because they
were bowled out then we'll count how
many times that happened and that will
determine the red angle or the orange
angle
and if it was caught that will determine
the red angle so count
great so now we can see
five and six so
for
this batsman for this year
he was out 11 times
five times because it was caught five
times because it was bold
let's control
and drag dismissal kind on the label so
now we can quickly see the five and the
six and we're going to control drag
dismissal kind on the label and we can
see
which kind
of dismissal it was that keeps us from
having to need
this legend
so we can click hide card and we don't
need that anymore
now we're going to make another pie
chart based on runs so since i'm making
a second pie chart i'm going to
duplicate this
there are some pros and cons to
duplicating it one of the pros is when
we come up here to filters
and we come to selected sheets we can
see that the filters that applied to
type of dismissal are automatically
applied here onto type of dismissal too
and so that's great news because we do
want
it to be filtered to just one batsman in
just one year however we don't want it
to filter out dismissal kind of null
anymore because now we're looking at
runs and runs
need to have the times when they didn't
get out so we're going to pull dismissal
kind off
and if you weren't paying very close
attention or you copied it then you
might be confused as to why things were
getting filtered out but it was because
it copied your filters as well so that's
one of the disadvantages of copying
let's rename it
runs distribution
and i'm going to pull off all of this
information here so that we're starting
from scratch so here we have
basically blank pie chart
and we're going to
look at batsman runs so there are a
couple different kinds of runs that you
can get so i want batsman runs to
determine color but when i drag batsman
runs onto color it's doing a sum of
batsman runs
and it's just trying to make it darker
or lighter depending on how many runs
there were but that's not what i want i
want to use it as a dimension
and now we can see we have zero through
six
and that means that a batsman either has
zero runs or
one two four or six runs
now there is three runs as well however
because we're only selecting
one year
and one batsman this particular batsman
for this particular year only had
either zero runs one run two four or six
so when we changed it to a dimension
it's now instead of summing up all the
runs it is now just showing you their
options but it's still doing it like a
scale from light to dark i want six
distinct colors one for each so i'm
going to change it from a continuous
type of field to a discrete type of
field
and now i have zero one two four and six
now i want to exclude zero runs because
i'm not trying to keep track of how many
times they didn't get a run i'm trying
to keep track of what how many times
they got different kinds of runs so
again let's exclude it and now we have
our four different kinds and just to
show this i right clicked on year i
click show filter
and if i show all the years you can see
our fifth kind
of run where they got three runs
on one ball
shows up so it does exist
it just didn't happen for this
particular batter or batsman during that
year now we want the angle to be
determined by
batsman runs
however we don't want to sum up the
batsman runs we don't want to take every
time that he got a six and do six plus
six plus six plus six what we want to do
is count how many times he got a six
so we're going to change it from a sum
to a count
and you can see he got
a six 24 times
and so before
let's go back
it was taking 24 and timesing it by 6
which is 144
and summing up
each of those times but instead we want
to count each of those times and see how
many times he got a six and how many
times he got a four not how many points
were scored
went um by getting a six so
that's a little bit of a confusing thing
to think about another thing you could
do is instead of doing a count of
batsman runs
let's pull that off you could use this
number of records field
and that will show us how many
meaning the number of records how many
records did we have from this batsman in
this year
that showed
that he batted a six so drag number of
records onto angle
and you see we get the same thing that
we had before so those are two ways of
doing it either change the
batsman
runs
to account
or grab a number of records number of
records is a little bit simpler so let's
also bring number of records onto
the label
and we can see quickly that mostly he
got ones
and got more fours than he got twos
actually which might is might be
interesting to
people who are trying to see how well
this batsman does
our next visualization has to do with
the batsman's strike rate
so we'll make our new sheet
season
strike rate
and we'll need to make a calculated
field
to be able to determine the strike rate
for a batsman so
we'll come here to this arrow click on
it and click create calculated field
we'll call it strike rate
and we're going to
find out how many runs
that a batsman gets
basically for every 100 balls bold so
we're going to
get the total of the runs by doing a sum
of batsman runs
we're going to divide it by the number
of balls bold we know that this data set
is one row per ball bold
it's the ball by ball data so we're just
going to divide it by how many the
number of rows number of records
and we're going to put all of that
in parentheses and one thing i need to
do is instead of just number of records
i needed to be the sum of number of
records so that it adds them all up
before it divides it
okay so sum of the runs divided by the
sum of the bold balls and we will
multiply that by 100 and that is our
strike rate okay so now that we have our
strike rate we can start building our
visualization
we would like to have both of these
filters so i'm going to
quickly apply it
so first build the visualization and
then apply it we're going to
come here and bring date onto columns
and it's giving us one per year
we're going to change our marks card
no let's leave our marks card the way it
is and then we are going to bring on our
bowler
and we're going to bring on our strike
rate
next
okay
so
now that we have
kind of the beginnings of our
visualizations let's go here
and we can now apply it to our
new worksheet apply the existing filters
one of the reasons it's so important to
apply the existing filters
to our worksheet
there we go now we can see quickly see
his strike rate for 2014. i'm going to
control drag strike weight onto label
and we have it there as well
okay one of the reasons it's so
important to use the same filter
that is applied to all of the selected
worksheets
instead of just bringing batsmen back on
and making our new filter each time is
we want on the dashboard to just have
one filter that applies to all of them
so you can see here when i change this
to 2015
and remove 2014 and then we go to season
strike rate we can see this one's also
2015 now
and we'll go back to 2014
season strike rate and this one's also
2014. so we want whenever a filter is
changed for it to affect all of the
visualizations associated with our
dashboard and so all of our
visualizations that are about batsmen
and their information we want to be able
to use the same filters
so i'm going to click show filter
quickly
and we're going to see what happens to
this dot when i add more years
so this is going to allow them to see
the strike rate per 100 balls over time
if they select more periods
our next visualization
is going to be called
team versus
player
and we're going to see how many runs a
batsman scores against particular teams
so we're going to bring on bowling team
because that's the team the bassman is
against
we're going to bring on
batsman
and their
batsman run
so now we can see how many runs each
batsman scored against all these
different teams
and again
we're going to apply our filters
there we go
let's also bring batsman onto color
again
just for when we're looking at multiple
batsmen at once in our filters
and we're going to bring the batsman
runs onto label
there we go so now we can
have it in both places instead of just
pulling it off and putting it on the new
one
great team versus player
and our last visualization for
the batsman dashboard
is going to be called
balls per
boundary
so we're going to see how many
balls bold it takes for a batsman to get
a boundary
but
we have balls for per boundary
calculated here
and also a boundaries count calculated
here
however we're going to show you how to
make our own versions of these
calculations so
i'm going to create a calculated field
i'm going to call it
boundaries count
and it won't let me save it as
boundaries count because i can't have it
saved as the same name
at least in tableau desktop that's true
i'm not
it looks like tablet public isn't
getting mad at me for that so but i'm
going to change the name
to
boundaries count calculated
so we can tell the difference between
the one that existed in the one that we
calculated
and we are going to
do an if statement so if
the batsman
runs
the individual batsman's runs not the
sum over whatever we select if batsman's
run is greater than or equal to
four
then one else
zero
so
it's giving me an error because i always
need to have an end
whenever i do an if statement
and this shows that whenever a boundary
happens so if they scored four or six on
one ball
then we'll count it one
otherwise zero and if i sum this up then
we'll be able to count how many
boundaries they had so
apply
okay
and for example if i brought on a
batsman all the batsmen
and i brought on boundaries count
calculated this should be
counting up how many boundaries they had
overall time
so that's the numbers we're getting here
okay let's back it out now we're going
to make
our new calculated field
called
balls per boundary
calculated
just so that it's clear which one is
which
and we're going to count
all the balls so this is for every ball
bold so we're counting the balls we
could also use the number of records
here similar to what we talked about
earlier and we're going to
divide it by the sum
of
the boundaries count calculated
so this will show us how many balls it
takes to get
a boundary
apply okay
great now we can start building our
visualization
and we are going to bring on
batsman onto columns
and we're going to bring balls per
boundary calculated onto rows
and now it's showing us
how many balls it takes
for the boundaries let's also bring
batsman onto color
i've gotta hold ctrl when i do that
there we go
so we have batsman here and batsman here
and we're gonna do the same thing hold
ctrl drag this down to label
now we can see the exact number
and for the final time
we're going to apply our filters
now i could have waited and applied my
filters at the very end once i had all
these built again i do recommend
applying your filters at the end
now we're going to put together the
first of our two dashboards so i'm going
to click on dashboard here
i'm going to change it to automatic size
which will fill my screen i'm going to
change it back to fixed size so now we
have our width and our height based on
what automatic size was
let's just round rounded out a little
bit so instead of 1678 i'm going to
change it to be
just an even
1600 and same even 900
so now we have
our fixed size here
there's also you could change it to a
laptop browser or a full screen so if we
click full screen
there's that size
generic desktop
i'm gonna go back to my size the size
that works for you is going to be based
on the size that works the best for all
of your users so that will take some
research
on your side and before i get started
i'm going to
do some formatting of my dashboard so
i'm going to click format here and i'm
going to change the default shading for
the dashboard
to
this particular
shade
you can use this color selector or all
these different kinds of basic colors
and so it just gives it a different
color than just the basic white so
that's a quick way to change the whole
dashboard color and i'm also going to
bring on
some text for the title of the dashboard
let's name our dashboard
we're going to call it batsman
performance
so
actually spell it out there okay
and then down here it says show
dashboard title so i'm going to select
that and we have batsman performance
there at the top
if you don't want the title here to
match what's here you have a couple
options so you can click edit title and
put in whatever you want
you can also
come we'll click floating here and we're
gonna just drag text on here
and
that allows you to be able to make your
own
title like that as well or just whatever
text you need to put on your dashboard
so we'll just remove that from our
dashboard and we're going to bring on
our visualizations
but we're going to bring them on as
floating visualizations
so i've selected floating here versus
tiled floating allows you to bring
something on and drop it and wherever it
lands is where it lands and you can move
it around and it's not going to try to
automatically fill this area
if i change it to tile
and i bring this on
it'll fill the area or
i'll put it to the left or the right and
it will fill
those sides
so back to floating
floating has some benefits
where you can just drop things and they
will land there however
if you make it floating then you have to
adjust the size of each individual thing
instead of just say if we
brought it on
undo that as tiled and we brought on
this
and we brought on this if i wanted to
adjust the size of these things i can
just drag this little line in between
and it just tiles them and they fill the
space you give them
versus with floating
when i bring on this
and i bring on this
then i have to if i want to adjust the
sizes i can make this one smaller and
then i need to make this one bigger
independently of that
so there are some pros and cons of doing
it either way
but we are going to do it the floating
way
and we are going to bring on
team versus player first
and put it here
then we're going to bring on
underneath that
type of dismissal
so basically all of our dashboards one
at a time
here's where our balls per boundary goes
my runs distribution goes over here
and it brings in
whatever
filters you showed
at the time and all the legends that are
showing up on that visualization so if i
go back to runs distribution you can see
we had gear and that legend on there and
i brought them in as well
let's also bring on
season strike rate
which also had here
and all inning scores
okay so this is the one that had all
ending score if you recall was the first
one we made that originally had our two
filters so we're going to change our
filters from multiple value list to
multiple value drop down
and that causes it to take up way less
space
it still has an incredible height so
we're going to go to layout and we're
going to change the height
to
something more reasonable
100 just brings it onto the screen so
that i could drag it like that there we
go
and then
year of date
we're going to edit this one let's see
to be multiple value drop down as well
and again
a more reasonable height for a multiple
value drop down okay so we've got
started
we have this legend here for color for
batsman which we're going to remove
because it has the name on it generally
and we're going to figure out how wide
we want these to be
so we need all three of them to fit
in our
width
1600
so that would be
a width around 500 each so let's go to
layout here and we're going to change
the width from 533 to 500
on each of these visualizations
and that gives us some extra
space to go in between them all
it's a little bit more reasonable the
space in between
there we go
and run distribution
so
once i've kind of figured out my spacing
to go in between them i can line up
these bottom ones by matching
the y
or x x value so this x is 25
and this one i wanted to line up with it
up and down so i'll change my x to 25
and it shifts it over
this one is 555
so i'm gonna change this one
and this one
i'm just going to copy and paste this
one
into this one
now we kind of have the x figured out
and i want them all to line up along the
y as well so i'm going to take this
170.
and i'm going to apply the 170
to all three of these
so that they line up perfectly
this is another benefit of having it be
a floating object because on
a tile object you can't determine their
position exactly otherwise
it would mess up all the tiles around it
but you also don't need to put them
quite as precisely in order because when
you do tiled it kind of lines them up
along lines
as they are
tiled great so this is a lot more
straightforward
let's
get these
i'll get this guy about where i want it
and then i'll line this one up with it
up and down
there we go
um we can also
come here and edit the title and just
make the font a little bit bigger
on both of these
and now let's make the worksheets here
individually a little bit closer to the
color that we
picked for our background so i'm going
to click right click right on top of the
chart and click format then i'm going to
go to the shading section and on the
worksheet i'm going to choose more
colors you see the color that we
selected before for the background is in
this little palette of recently used
colors
and i want one slightly different than
that so i'm just going to enter in the
one that i
want
and i'll copy that so i can use it on
the others
however if i did want the same color as
i had there i could just select it right
of the recently used colors okay
and there we go we'll come here
right click on the chart click format
shading and
i'm gonna paste in
that color
and you see when i clicked from here to
here it kept me right on that same sheet
however you see that this went to white
instead of the darker color i had before
and so
i don't even have to click format again
i can just come here
and paste in
my color
so i have a color that matches more
closely to my background color but it's
still different enough that i still have
the
outline kind of the shape of having like
cards on this dashboard
we go full screen here we now have our
dashboard that allows us to see
[Music]
all of the batsman performance
information for whatever batsman we
choose and whatever year we choose so
when we change the year
all the charts update
we want to
change the batsman
to
one of these chris's
there we go some of them aren't in the
year 2014 which is the problem we were
having there we go so now we see
all the same information but for chris
instead
so now that we've made our batsmen
dashboard we're going to move on to
making our bowler dashboard
our first visualization for the bowler
is going to be called
buller performance
against team
it's very similar to the one that we
made for batsmen only it's showing how
the bowler has performed against batting
teams
and the wickets that they got against
those batting teams so
we're going to bring on
the batting team
so we can see all the batting teams
against them
we're going to bring on bowler
so that it separates it out by bowler
one more try we'll also put bowler onto
color
and we're going to bring on
player dismissed
no sorry
we're going to bring on dismissal kind
we brought on dismissal kind but i want
to change it to be a measure and a count
of the dismissal kinds
and let's put it here
so now we have a bar chart
for the dismissal kind you can see that
it's going 0 to 30 for each of these
and that's because we have some that go
all the way up to 30 against a team
and if we wanted we could edit the axis
and change it to be independent access
ranges for each row or column
so now we can see that it
is zero to two for this guy
but zero to thirty for this guy
and that can be nice
when
you want to be able to look at them
independently however when we're looking
at them side by side and you're trying
to compare
we would think that maybe this person
did just as good
as
somebody like
this person
so we're not going to do that
because it could be misleading
also in the end i'm going to have
filters so that we're looking at one
bowler at a time and one year at a time
so
we won't need
to see them all at once
okay
we have bowler on color let's also
control drag the count of dismissal kind
on the label so now it's labeled
some of them are going to have a lot
fewer against teams maybe they didn't
play as many seasons and that they might
have a lot more that's why we're going
to have the filter for a per season
number
but we're not going to do that right
away
okay
next workbook
and worksheet
and we're going to call it
bowler versus player
so when we're looking at this at one
bowler at a time we can see
how the bowler has done versus
particular players
so
we're gonna bring on the batsman
here
and then we're going to bring on
dismissal kind here and again we're
going to change it to
account measure
and we can count all the dismissals
against particular players when we
filter it down to one bowler we can see
how they did versus certain players and
then in just one year
let's sort
biggest to
smallest we're going to
bring batsman
onto color
and
that way when we switch from
bowler to bowler we could kind of see
which batsman fall in certain areas it
also just
makes it
quick to follow it along to the edge
and
we could put counter dismissal on the
label here
so that it's easy to quickly see however
when we filter it down to just one
bowler and one year then there's going
to be a lot fewer dismissals per batsman
so
it'll be pretty easy to see so let's not
do that let's go on to our next
worksheet
and this one is going to be called
bowling average
so we need to create
a bowling average calculation
it's going to be runs conceited per
wickets taken so we have to come up with
our runs conceded which is
all of the
batsman runs we'll sum those up and
divide it by
the number of wickets which is the count
of dismissal kind
and now we have our bowling average
there is a bowling average that already
existed so again we're going to call it
bowling average calculated
so that we know which one's ours
okay apply done
and we're going to bring on the bowler
and bowler onto color
and let's bring on our bowling average
calculated
where i sort it
biggest to smallest
it might be better to sort it smallest
to biggest
but some of these players might not have
played
or bold
so that's why we'll have nulls
so
biggest smallest it is
and let's also bring the bowling average
that we made
onto
the label
great
our next sheet we will also need to
make a calculated field for this one
and let me hurry and name it and then
i'm going to go back to bowling average
because i had
one more thing to do there
economy
rate
is our next sheet okay so for bowling
average we have a situation where maybe
somebody doesn't know what the bowling
average means
so
you can right click on your chart in the
outside area outside of the graph area
and click on caption and the caption
will pop up and it's automatically
making a caption which is bowling
average calculated for each bowler it's
just describing what's happening and
then it says color shows details about
the bowler which it does and the marks
are labeled by the bowling average
calculated
so when i double click on the caption i
can change it to be whatever i want
which i'm going to
put
runs
conceded per
wicket
taken
and now we have a caption that kind of
is describing what this visualization
means
so on economy rate the economy is
defined as the number of runs conceded
for each over bold so instead of the
runs conceited per wicket taken it's for
each over so we're going to create our
calculated field we're going to call it
economy
calculated
again we have to get a sum of our runs
there's our runs
we're going to divide it by
the count
of the balls so this will tell us how
many
balls were thrown um but we don't want
how many balls were thrown we want how
many
overs there were
so just to make this a little more clear
i'm going to put parentheses around this
and we're going to take
there are six balls thrown in and over
so we're going to take the number
of balls and divided by six
to get the number of overs so we'll take
batsman runs and then this is per over
hit okay
for this visualization it's going to be
pretty similar
to the last one
where we're going to bring on economy
and we're going to put economy onto i'm
gonna hold control
and put it onto the label
sum of economy
oh it's not even using my calculated
field so
economy calculated
there we go
now it's much more reasonable we'll drag
economy calculated onto label
and
since this dashboard is going to be
meant to be viewed one bowler at a time
we're going to not split it out by
bowler in this situation
but you could and if you do split it out
by bowler that means they could select
more than one bowler at a time and see
their economy side by side
also here we can see that it says
economy calculated for our label if we
hit edit axis we can change the title
so we're just going to call economy
probably need to do the same thing for
bowling average there we go
edit axis
bowling average okay it got mad because
i didn't close it and then there we have
it
again i'm going to
right click in some empty space and
click caption and then we have our
caption here
edit caption
and we're going to put
average
runs conceded
okay
there we go we have our caption we have
our chart
and we have one more visualization to
make
for our dashboard
remember if you have any questions or
comments please put them below and
somebody from the simply learn team will
help us answer those questions or if you
have an answer to somebody else's
question feel free to chime in we'll get
a good discussion going
the last one is called a dismissal
and we're going to look at kind of like
we did before type of dismissal but this
was the batter and how they got
dismissed
whereas this is the bowler and how they
took the wicket so
we are going to also make a pie chart
which means dismissal kind goes on to
color and we change the marks to pie so
we have a pie that shows a color for
each of the dismissal kinds again let's
remove null so again i came over here
right clicked and clicked exclude but
you can do it right on the visualization
dismissal kind and you see how it's
blank instead of bold or cotton bold
and click exclude there so there it
makes our filter next we need to
determine the angle size we're going to
bring on number of records
and the more records that fall under
that dismissal kind that means the more
often that kind happened
and let's bring number of rows number of
records onto label as well
and also
we're going to entire view
so that it's nice and big and easy to
read and we're going to
add a caption
and
we're just going to put
dismissal types
but we'll see how that comes up on the
visualization so now that we have made
all of
our
visualizations for our dashboard let's
add our filters so just on this last one
i'm going to bring bowler onto filter
and we're going to click use let's
actually select a bowler
you can use this box to search
there we go and it's popped up you see
how i didn't even have to start
searching it at the beginning of the
name
it's just smart enough so we have our
bowler
let's bring on date
we're going to choose years
and let's use 2016
and we have our year
and now let's apply it
to all the worksheets that it applies to
so dismissal economy rate bowling
average bullying versus player and
bowler performance against team
same for a year
okay and you can see how much quicker
that is to
apply
instead of doing it every time you make
a new dashboard
so much quicker saves you some time can
be confusing so make sure you do it
because if you forget to do it and then
you change a filter on a dashboard and
it only changes one of the
visualizations on that dashboard then it
can be really confusing and
like on the batsman performance if we
had forgotten to add these to all the
visualizations and we left it off of
this visualization then
people could be confused as to why
that's not changing or off of this
visualization
if it's not changing it's hard to know
if it's not changing because it didn't
change from year to year maybe his types
of dismissal were the same from year to
year
or
it's just hard to tell the difference
and see if it's not affecting it so
always be sure
to double check
that your filters are applied to
everything you need them to be applied
to
let's make a dashboard
okay
we're going to make it
what we made it before
sixteen hundred by nine hundred
and you can see all of our sheets are
showing up but let me show you a quick
trick here this dashboard uses all of
the batsman sheets and we don't use any
of the batsman sheets again inside of
the second dashboard so if i right click
on the batsman performance and i click
hide all sheets it doesn't hide all
sheets it just hides all sheets
associated with that dashboard
and now you no longer see those sheets
and when i come to dashboard 2 it's only
showing me the sheets that are not
hidden
for that dashboard
let's get started by first changing our
dashboard color so i came to dashboard
and i hit format
and i'm going to change the color to
this blue color
and there's our background
and then i'm going to click
show dashboard title which is dashboard2
right now so let's rectify that right
now and we're going to call it
fuller performance
and here we have bowler performance
let's do floating which is already
selected
and we're going to bring on bowler
performance against team
and we're going to go side by side with
bowler versus player
and it's brought on
both of these have brought on
legends that are actually not helpful
because we have labels that tell us
these things so we're going to get rid
of these legends
sometimes i wait till i brought i have
brought on all of my dashboards before i
remove legends or change filters so
all of our all of my worksheets
sometimes i wait till i've brought on
all my worksheets i'm gonna bring on
bowling average
and economy rate
and dismissal
here's an actually useful legend so
we'll keep that around
remove this legend
because right there just tells you right
next to it
and now let's start adjusting our charts
so i'm going to make
these two side by side up here so they
need to split the space
so let's try a width of
750
which gives you a little bit of space
side to side
but still uses the space a little bit
better
you can see that this visualization is
too tall to fit inside of the area we've
given it so it has a scroll bar here on
the side
if you change
how this fills in its space so right now
it's standard you can have fit width
which it's already fitting the width of
the area that is provided if you do fit
height it's going to force everything to
fit inside of that area so there's no
scroll bar and it does not look good for
this visualization
and an entire view it's the same thing
it's trying to make everything fit
inside that area so we're going to go
back to standard another one that's good
for things where you do want the scroll
bar up and down is fit width so either
of those look good
these two are going to share space
underneath this one
and so i'm going to make them
both
let's say
300
how does that look oh that's good
let's make this one the same size as
this above it
750.
bring it over
okay
you notice
one thing
that's happening here is
we cannot see at this point the filters
there are no filters popping in here
even though we added filters now why
would that be that's because we have no
filters being shown on our visualization
none of our worksheets showed the
filters they just existed here so
if we come and we click on one of our
visualizations click the drop down arrow
and we go to filters we can see all the
filters we can select from
we're going to bring on bowler
let's make it
the drop down
and again
it just made it a really unreasonable
height because i was trying to fit all
of those bowlers
but 20 is too small
there we go
and we'll go here
and also bring on
year of date
what's the height on this one
55 55 is a good height
now it's time to clean it up a bit so we
have all of our pieces
let's first make sure when i change this
that
everything changes so when i unselect
2016 they should all
go to null and i click fit 2015 they all
update
that's what we want to see
okay so we have all the pieces we just
need to get them lined up looking nice
and
just getting things a little bit more
clean
like here
we want to show our caption
that we added
and here
and here
so this kind of
is something that you can use on your
dashboard to
describe things that are happening
or different pieces of it it's just an
easy way
to add a caption and then let's line
them up up and down i think that we
could probably make both of these a
little taller
what do we think about 350
maybe even 400
and we'll bring
these ones down
that's really nice for this
visualization to have more space
just a little bit more space whatever
you can give it honestly
is really helpful
sometimes with these visualizations that
are up and down i like to give them the
whole side to themselves so maybe we
would move this over and make it smaller
and these all three would fit right here
and then i'd give this one all this up
and down space i'll undo that
we can move this legend over a little
bit more
there we go
and then let's start lining things up i
like where this one is positioned
on the y-axis so i'm going to copy that
and bring it over here
they were pretty close there we go
and then
i'm going to
do the same thing with the y-axis for
these ones
just to make sure they're perfectly
lined up
these it looks like i could make a
little bit wider
if you would like
one thing that's happening here is it
looks a little bit like this one has
more up and down space than this one
does
and that's because it's missing this
label and it also isn't colored the same
as these other ones as it represents the
bowler well we can fix that because if
you remember we did not put bowler onto
the columns and we put it on there
there's our label
we also didn't put it onto color and
there we go so that gives us a little
bit more consistency
between these two visualizations
however they're still labeled economy
rate and bowling average with their
captions at the bottom there
okay
and since these are the same width i
would like to line them up on the x-axis
so
i'm going to take this
there
and that lines those up i want to make
sure that these are lined up
up and down
pretty close but not quite there
there we go and also year of date
is not necessarily what i want
the update part is
just
not useful for what we need so i'm going
to change it to year i'm also going to
center it
we'll come here for bowler
and center that one as well
center and also let's make it a little
bigger
see how it did not make it bigger that
is because the formatting
in here
such as changing the font or bolding it
requires you to have whatever text you
want selected
so now it's bigger
there we go
i like the white on the blue so i won't
change these individual dashboards
or individual worksheets to be a
different color
let's take a look
here we have our second dashboard
if we come here and we click hide all
sheets now you can only see the two
dashboards
in these tabs at the bottom
and you can see that we can have
different years for the two different
dashboards you could tie the year
together
oh we have year of date on this one too
let's change that
so
that's not
what i meant to click there we go edit
title
we're gonna make it centered we're gonna
make it bigger
don't press enter
when you're not done
and we're going to erase of date so
that's just year
do the same thing over here
this just adds a little bit of
consistency
there are two separate dashboards
but if people are going to look at them
side by side maybe or one right after
the other it is nice to have some
consistency
there we go
so there you have it we have made two
dashboards
one of them about batsman performance
one of them about baller performance
during this time we learned about
formatting our dashboards we learned
about floating versus tiled
and about
positioning legends and filters some of
the options we have for changing filters
we learned about
different ways to make different
visualizations we made pie charts and
bar charts
and we also learned about applying
filters to
just the worksheets that you want for
those dashboards
finally we learned about adding captions
so at first we'll understand what
exactly a set function is then we'll
understand the sort function
next we have the join and union and why
do we use it after that we have the
highlight function in w then we have the
device designer and finally the forecast
now these are the functions in tableau
that we will be discussing today don't
worry i'll explain each one of them with
practical examples so that you have a
better learning experience
now let's dive into the first one which
is the set
so what exactly is a set
so sets and w are basically a set of
elements basically if you have some
variety of columns and rows then you
customize some selected data for example
if you have a set of
cars sales data and inside that you have
some details about the horsepower the
price values the resale values etc etc
and you wanted to make a set of the cars
with the highest horsepower then you can
do that just by adding some conditions
onto your data so that's what the set
functions in tablet basically do
so we have an example on our screen
right now so this is how the set
function will be implemented in w and
you'll be getting some similar kind of
output
now we'll go back to tableau and try to
do it practically
now we are back on w
and in w let's try to make a set
and for that let's create a new sheet
yeah now let's rename this sheet
as set function
okay
now let's try to drag the
[Music]
engine size onto columns
now we have the engine size on our
columns
now the next let's choose the horsepower
so we have our horse bar on the rose
now you can see that we have a resultant
dot which is the total number of
engine size values and total number of
horsepowers including of all the cars
now let's try to drag the manufacturer
into the details part
so that we have the um
you know kind of which manufacturer has
the horsepower values and
the engine size etc etc
so we have the ford and the overall
according to the uh data set we have the
overall engine size is 36.60
now it's not you know this is not the
kind of data you want to look at so now
let's remove the manufacturer from here
and let's select the model
yeah now we have a little more detailed
one
just hover on to yeah you can see this
so we have the model corvette and the
engine size is 5.7 liters and the
horsepower is 345.
now let's try to drag the manufacturer
again onto the details so that we can
have also the name of manufacturer
so we have the manufacturer chevrolet
model carbide engine size and horsepower
now we have the data what we needed now
let's try to create a set
now to create a set you might want to
have to select the
let's undo that
yeah
now to create a set you might want to
select
the
values on here
so these are the selected paths we have
with the highest horsepower
now let's right click
and then we have an option called create
set and the last
option
now let's just try to rename the set
name
now we have it as set to one now let's
try to name it as
horse bar
set
and before junior we select ok if you
want to eliminate some names or cars you
can do that as well
for example if you want to eliminate
cadillac develop you can just
select and remove it i can also do it in
this way
cadillac escalade you can just exclude
it and it's it'll be gone
yeah something like that
and if you want this set to be added
onto the filters tab or filter shelf you
can just select it over here and it will
be automatically done
for now i think we don't need it on to
the filter shelf so we'll just select
okay
and there you go we have the horsepower
set over here
now to watch the
set what we created over here in a
pictorial way or a graphical way you can
just drag that and you can just add it
over
the chart pane
now if you wanted to look at the data
which you have in your set then you can
just drag that set onto the color option
and you'll be having a different color
on your data which is present in your
set
now you can just right click on it and
you can
make some changes to it if you wanted to
make or if you want to keep this you can
just
click on the option key point and if you
wanted to exclude it you can just select
exclude and it'll be gone
so this is how you use sets in
w
now let's move on to the next function
which happens to be the sort function
so what exactly is sort
so when you open table u you can see
some options on tableau which are
the uh some bar kind of things on the
toolbar
so these are basically sort options so
sort and tableau is a function which is
readily available for the user
to sort the resultant data in the form
of ascending or descending order so we
have a sample picture which shows the
sort functions use in real time now
let's get back to the w and say it for
real
so now we have the highest pricing chart
over here
yeah you can see
yeah let's select this one
so we have multiple car manufacturers
and the car models available in that
particular section
now
these are kind of irregularly sorted now
one press of this button
which happens to be sorted descending by
some of horsepower within model
you see
within model all the models are sorted
according to the horsepower so the first
one in buick the regal model which has
the highest horsepower 240 and the next
highest is to note five second two note
5 and then 175 so this is how the
models are been sorted now you can make
this look a bit more colorful just by
dragging the model on to color and you
can see the different colors
so that's how it is
now followed by sort we'll move on to
the next one
which happens to be the join and union
now the join and union are completely
similar to the join and union functions
which you basically use in the sql and
database
so you can see on the left part we have
the four different types of joins which
are the inner left right and full outer
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so join and union and w are used to
combine data from different sources and
they're completely similar to the ones
and sql and database operations
now imagine that you have various kinds
of data sources
and you need to work on those
various types of data sources in tableau
for example consider that you have
some
shopping data some store data so you
have the customer data separately and
the product data separately
and
let's assume that in both the tables we
have one common column that is the order
id
so the customer will be requesting for a
product and we'll be creating an order
id
and
in the product table you'll be having
the product data along with the
requested
product with its order id when you have
such kind of common column then you can
basically join the two data sets
and no matter what if you have the
orders data in
notepad and the product data in excel
format you can do it you can join them
it doesn't matter if you have the data
source in different formats
so that's why we have join and union in
table u
so let's get back to tableau and try to
do it
manually
so now i have kind of
excel
now let's select the store data
repeat and you have the star data and
now let's try to add the new data set
now for that you just need to select the
add option
now we have the other options now we
have already included microsoft excel
now let's try to include the csv file
the text file so i've already created
one
so this happens to be the returns data
now there you go you have both the data
sets over here which is the microsoft
excel and the microsoft not microsoft's
text file so you can see the new union
option over here you can use new union
option and try to combine both of them
based on the order id which is present
in both the tables
so this is how the join and union
basically work in tableau now let's try
to continue
with the next one
the next one is highlight
the highlight function is pretty simple
you just have to you know select the
option which you want to showcase it's
as simple as the name is
so the highlight in tableau is a
function readily available to help the
user to highlight a specific data out of
the complete file
so basically you can see
my screen and on the screen we have the
data set and we have a resultant bar
chart and on that we have the highest
pricing of a particular car manufacturer
and when you hover on to that particular
bar and select it then you can see that
that particular bar has been highlighted
now this data is also the same one and
on the right side part i've just
selected the bmw car manufacturer and
you can see the cars highlighted are
based on that particular car maker now
we are back on tableau and now we have
the same data over here now let's just
kind of sort it again
and you see here and now if i select
the
mercedes-benz
you can see that particular car has been
highlighted over here
so that's how we use highlight function
and you can see if you want to disable
highlighting you can do it by just
clicking this button disable workbook
highlighting
so now with this let's move ahead into
the next kind of function
which happens to be the device designer
so device designer is really simple
there is no rocket science in that it's
basically the kind of device you're
working with so if you have the tableau
installed in your tablet then you can
just select the tablet option so that
your dashboard is clearly visible
according to the screen size of your
table or tablet
and if you're using a desktop then you
can select the desktop option and you
can directly do it now let's get back to
tableau and check the device designer
so basically the device designer is used
to check the layout of the dashboard you
have you can select the fit width fit
height and entire view
so you also have the options for
making your dashboard look in the phone
mode
and you can either select the default
where your device automatically selects
the kind of view it wants to show
so that's how the device designer is
used in real time
now let's get back to the next one which
is
the forecast so forecast is one
interesting function used in real time
so let's imagine that you wanted to have
an information based on the future sales
on the
product based on the current data
available now you can do that by using
the forecast function in your table u
so as you can see on my screen i have
some information available based on the
sample data now we have the sales charts
on 2014 15 16 17
and
if you wanted to predict the data of
sales in the next upcoming year
which is 2018
i'm saying 2018 as the future year here
because the data set what we have only
has information until 2017 so that's the
reason i'm saying the future year 2018
no worry a lot about it we can actually
change it in the data set if you wanted
to now let's see this practically
happening in w
now we are back on tableau and
we are about to create the forecast
thing so we have the measures and
dimensions on the left part now let's
try to uh drag the um
sales
now we are dragging sales onto rows and
uh we're going to drag the order date
onto the columns
so we have
the graph over here
now if you kind of uh
press that little plus button and then
you can see the sales happening
according to 14 15 16 and 17 here
now let's try to select the analytics to
create the forecast thing now you just
have to uh you can see the forecast
button over here right you can just have
to double click on that
and you can see that the
tableau is predicting the sales over
here
and this is the best
case and this is the worst case of sales
and this is kind of the average
so this is how the forecast works in
real time
so we will get started by understanding
the proper definition of the parameter
and w
so what exactly are parameters in w
so parameter will allow you to provide a
value to pass into tableau parameters
allow you to produce scenarios or
options that are not available in your
data or create these values to put it
into your visualization after creation
end users can control the input to see
the results of the parameters effect
so this is a little complex to
understand so let me just break it down
to a simpler version
so parameters are completely similar to
filters so when you apply a filter just
imagine that you wanted to find the
sales of top 10 sub category items so
which are is it phones is it furniture
is it something else so which are the
top 10 items which are finding me the
most profitable sales so you'll apply
that filter to that particular sheet so
what if you wanted to apply the same
filter to 10 sheets
yeah by brute force metal you can do
that and you can apply that to the 10
sheets but what if you had hundreds of
sheets
right so in that scenario you might
prefer using parameters because once you
set the parameter you can use that
particular parameter for all the sheets
in your visualization and even you can
use these parameters in your dashboards
as well
so i think this was a little simpler to
understand now what are the use cases
that we will be discussing today in
parameters
so there are multiple parameters that
you can use in your day-to-day w usage
so we'll learn the most frequently used
parameters we're going to use the top
end parameters date field parameter
dynamic measures dynamic dimensions
dynamic measures and dimensions
reference lines and some sets so i hope
so far so good now let's begin with our
practical session so let's get back to w
so we'll be using the superstore data
set we have dates and etc etc columns
which we need for the parameters to be
applied so we'll go with that
so you can see that i've already worked
on some sheets which include the
parameters such as state parameter
dynamic measures dynamic dimensions
dynamic measures and dimensions
etc etc
so don't worry i'll save this book for
your future reference will be creating
new sheets and we'll be applying new
parameters for a better understanding in
a practical way
so for now let's create a new sheet
so you can see the icon by clicking that
you can just enter into the new sheet
now for our reference that let's rename
it
so we'll rename it as
top
and
so we'll be beginning with the top end
parameter so we'll rename it as stopping
for now
enter
yeah
so for top 10
let's drag
sales into rows
and
subcategory from dimensions to columns
now we have a bar chart on our screen
let's kind of twist it or
change the orientation yeah
now we want to find the top 10 or top
five
items which are giving us a top sale so
let's kind of order it in descending
to do so or to know the top 10 items
which are given as the maximum sales
we'll apply filters onto it so to apply
a filter
let's drag the subcategory into filters
and you can see a drop down menu or a
dialog box where we can find the option
called top so here we can specify the
top ideas or top items or top categories
whatever it is which are giving us the
top sales
so we'll be selecting by field and
inside that we have a top ten
now okay we are not going to create a
parameter right away
yeah we have to create a parameter right
away
now just select
a new name for your parameter
now let's select
top
n parameter
hyphen or let's place the number in the
starting for our better identification
okay
now let's select list
now we have
if you remember we had the minimum and
maximum values is 1 200 in the previous
dialog box now let's select that to 10
and here
five
or seven
now let's select uh
oh let's do it fifteen
ten
and five now let's rename them
display as
top 15
now display the 10 as
top 10 and the 5 as
top five
now the parameter is created you can see
the
number second top end parameter on my
parameters section over here in the
bottom left corner
now the aggregation is sum by default
now let's select apply and ok
now let us right click the parameter and
select the show parameter icon
and here we have the top 15. now let's
try to select top 10. now you can see
that the sheet has changed the data now
we just have the top 10 sub category
items which are providing us the maximum
number of sales
now if we kind of select label and show
marked labels then we have the numbers
right you can see the numbers which are
providing us maximum sales over here
now let's kind of select top five
yeah so that's how the top end
parameters works in real time now let's
continue with the next type of parameter
in our list which happens to be the date
field parameter
for that let's create a new sheet now
let's rename it as date sheet
for our reference
now we have the date sheet over here
now to create a date parameter we need a
date so we have the order date over here
let's drag that to rows
now let's select
profit
and let's drop it down to here now we
have the profit on a particular dates
over here
now to create a date parameter let's
select the icon over here and we have a
create parameter option
now
let's create a parameter
now let's rename it as
second hyphen date parameter
i'm renaming it as second hyphen because
we have already worked on this
particular sheet and if you have seen
this particular parameter section we
have a date parameter already existing
in my sheet so for that i'm renaming it
as
second date parameter for the reference
now we might have a doubt about
selecting the data type for the dates
i'll go with string over here
now let's select the list and add the
values now for a date we have year
as well as quarter
next we'll have months
we'll have a week and we'll also have a
day
so that's our parameter which is number
two date parameter let's select okay so
once we have created the date parameter
the next step is to create a calculated
field
so this particular calculation field
will help us with the calculation of
days
quarters months weeks and years now
let's rename this as well
rename it as to
date
calculation
yep
now in this particular tray we'll be
writing the formula
you can see that we already have a date
calculation over here let's try to see
the formula over there
so here we are we have the date
parameter
and year quarter month weekend daily
and we have the order date parameter
over here or the date and this
particular hyphen queue is used for
dividing the ear into quarters
now we are going to use the same formula
now let's create a new calculated field
now let's select case
and remember the date parameter we
created in the parameter section you
need to drag that in
so that's dragged now let's paste the
formula
and
end
so there you go we have the
parameter dragged into the calculation
field and we have the calculation for
year quarter month weekend day and we
have the calculations valid notification
over here now let's just select okay
now they go in
in the measure segment
or yeah
yeah there you go in the dimension
segment we have the date calculation
field available
okay now we have the sales and year-wise
data over here let's change the type of
graph to bar graph
let's change the orientation
here
now let's select the label option to
provide us the details of sales
there you go you have the sales now
let's select the date parameter
show parameter option and we have the
year by sales number let's select that
to quarter
so the parameters is shown on the right
hand column so you can see the sales are
according to here now when you select
quarter you have the quarters when you
select month you have month wise sales
and when you have week week wise sales
and finally the day by sales
so you can see that on the 18th of march
2014 we have the maximum amount of sales
so that's how you do it now moving ahead
we have the dynamic measures and dynamic
dimensions once we are done with the
dynamic measures and dimensions we'll
also execute dynamic measures and
dimensions together then we'll continue
with reference lines and sets let's get
back to w so what exactly are dynamic
dimensions so you can see that on the
left hand column we have so many
dimensions over here so we'll be
creating a filter and we'll be passing
all the dimensions or the number of
dimensions what we want on our filter to
be so we'll pass those number of
dimensions into the filter and for the
same we'll be creating a parameter and
we'll be running all the values of
dimensions through that parameter now
let's go ahead and create a new
parameter let's select the icon
create a parameter
and now we are in the new workbook to
avoid confusion so we'll rename this as
dynamic
dimensions
parameter
we will select the data type as string
current value
and list and inside the list let's write
in the category shift mode and segment
let's select ok and you can see that we
have the new parameter over here which
says dynamic dimensions parameter
now once the parameter is created the
next step is to create a calculation
field let's select the calculated field
option
and inside this let's rename this
calculation as
dynamic
dimension
calculation field
and inside the tree let's write in the
formula
now let's write in case
and let's drag the newly created
parameter
and now
let's select one
category
then
category
from dimensions
followed by that one
ship mode
then
ship mode
from dimensions
followed by that
one
segment
then
segment from dimensions
now and
yeah the calculation is valid let's
apply
okay
so you can see that we have a newly
created dynamic dimension calculation in
the dimensions section
now we have the newly created dimension
calculation here we'll drag that to
columns
now let's drag sales
two rows
now let's drag the category to columns
so there you go we have the different
categories furniture office technology
now we have the parameter displayed on
the right hand side now let's select
according to the ship mode so according
to the ship mode we have the first class
second class
same day standard class etc etc and
these are the categories happening in
that particular fields and if you select
the category or parameter by segment we
have these results consumer corporate
and office
now this is how the dynamic dimension
parameter works now let's get into the
dynamic measure parameter
for that let's create a new sheet
we are in the new sheet now
now dynamic measures are completely same
to dynamic dimensions the only thing
changing here is instead of dimensions
we'll be dealing with measures
now we'll follow the same steps again
first create a
parameter
let's rename this as
dynamic
measures parameter
and in the list we'll be using
sales profit and quantity
let's select ok and our parameter is
done now let's create a calculated field
similar to dynamic dimensions
let's rename this
calculation as dynamic
measures calculation
and inside the tray let's type in case
let's drag the measures parameter
there you go
now
when
we have used sales profit and quantity
so sales
then
sales
when
profit
then
profit
when
quantity
then
[Music]
quantity
and
yeah the calculation field is valid
apply and okay
now let's make use of show parameter
options so that we can see the parameter
on the right hand corner
now let's select the
category from dimensions
and the newly created dynamic measures
calculation onto rows
so we have the
bar chart over here
now let's select profit
so you can see the profit
by
category wise and you can select the
label so that we can have a clear
picture of the numbers
now if we select the quantity we have
the details according to the quantity
now to just make things look a little
better we can drop the category off and
make use of
to have a better visualization on the
sub-categories which are bringing us
maximum seats you can rearrange them in
descending order and we can see
binders are giving us maximum profit
in the number of quantity in the profit
yeah copiers and in sales we have phones
so that's how we use dynamic measures in
real now the next part is both dynamic
measures and dynamic dimensions together
for that all you need to do is just
select the calculations from dynamic
measures and drop it down to rows and
dynamic measure dimension calculations
onto columns we're using both the
calculations together and now let's kind
of use the option of show parameter
where we can see the dynamic dimension
parameter and dynamic measure parameter
together
now when you select
category and sales
quantity
now we have both dimensions and measures
here
now let's select the label option so
that we can have a detailed
appearance on numbers now we have the
segments over here consumer corporate
and office when we select sales we have
the sales number when we select profit
we have the profit number when we have
the quantity we have the quantity number
so that's how the dynamic dimensions and
dynamic measures are used in real time
so the next parameter that we'll be
dealing with is the reference lines
now we are back on tableau let's create
a new sheet
now for reference line let's select
the order date
and drop it down to columns and now
let's select
sales
from
measures and drop it down to rows now
let's make a change to here we'll we'll
check that today
and we have a line over here
we need the sales and continuous day
format yeah so this is how it looks like
now let's create a new parameter
let's rename this as
date parameter
let's select the data type as date and
current value
and let's select the date as
so according to data set we have the
dates between 2013 to 2018 so select
anything between 2013 to 14.
let's select 2014 yeah
now let's select okay
so now we have the newly created date
parameter over here let's select the
show parameter icon now let's get back
to analytics and try to use a line so
we'll use the reference line let's
select table
let's select the type of line
and color
okay
so you can see our reference line over
here which is got created
now let's get back to data once and uh
date parameter let's edit it once i
think we forgot something important
it's fine here
yeah let's recreate the line again let's
use the reference line table
and here
we created a date parameter we need to
select this i think i forgot that
okay now let's select the type of line
let's select a medium thick line and
dotted line let's select the color as
pink
yeah that should be it let's select okay
now let's select the show parameter
option when we have the date parameter
option over here let's kind of change
the date and once we change the date you
can see there is a shift in the line
so that's how we use the
reference line in real time we have the
date parameter over here this is how we
use it now let's move on to the next
option or next parameter in the list
that is the set parameter for that let's
create a new sheet
now let's drag the sales to columns
and subcategories to rows
now select subcategory and
yeah let's select subcategory from
dimensions right click and let's use the
create option and from there we'll be
creating a set
let's rename this set uh the subcategory
set is perfect let's navigate to top and
inside that let's select by field and
let's select
the top and parameter
we are in the sub category we have
created a new parameter which we had in
the earlier sheet
so again let's navigate to top and
let's rename this
now
by field
by top end parameter
select okay
now you can see that we have a new set
over here
so now let's select the show parameter
option
and now let's drag the set
into color so that we have different
colors
so that's how you use set in real time
in parameter calculations in tableau so
now let's discuss the differences
between parameters and tableau filters
so these are the few differences between
w parameters and tableau filters so w
parameters are used for static data and
w filters are used for dynamic data so
parameters are implemented to entire
workbook whereas filters are implemented
to only specific sheets so this is what
we discussed in the earlier part so
using parameters cannot select multiple
values but using filters can select
multiple values at a time and parameters
use calculated fields while filters do
not use calculated fields and finally
parameters support multiple data types
whereas filters do not support multiple
data types
so let me now begin with connecting to
data now in this particular topic
we are at the end of this lesson you
will be able to
understand how you can connect to
tableau data server you will be able to
differentiate between a join and blend
how can you perform a join on a data how
can you blend our data we will discuss
the various connection options available
we will understand how tablet server
works in terms of the kerberos
authentication all right we will
understand various performance
optimization techniques as well shadow
extra extracts as well as different
methods that we can prepare in terms of
the data that we want to analyze all
right so
let me begin
now the very first topic which is uh
connecting to tableau servers i'm going
to first take you through a couple of
presentations like here and then quickly
move on to the environment where we will
actually then start exploring the topic
so
[Music]
now when you want to connect to a data
source in tableau server it's pretty
simple you can connect to a flag file in
your local machine so one is you will
click on to the server in the start
screen and or you can specify the server
name you can specify and uh show your uh
log in your credentials the username and
password and based on that you can
perform the you can have your connection
to the database all right so that's how
you can connect to the tablet server as
well all right so
that's the very first basic so the
tableau administrator is the one who
assigns the roles and creates these data
sources all right and you have tableau
has the facility in order to import
different forms of data for the analysis
for your ease
and once you're connected to the tableau
server then you need to select the table
server data source on the data menu you
will need to select a data source to
download a local file a local copy you
can select and create a local copy and
then you can also duplicate a duplicate
of that data source will be added up
into your data window so that's how you
can connect to tableau server as well
all right and uh it basically promotes
various features wherein uh you can then
connect to the tableau server for your
data so you are in this example you can
see that you're able to connect to the
tablet server as an admin and
connect to the sample superstore and it
downloads it creates a local copy and
duplicates all the data in that
particular data window
that's how we can see the sample triple
source and you can connect to the server
uh next we're going to also understand
what is joining and blending so before i
move on to the presentation slides here
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
move on to the environment directly let
us start exploring these blending and
joining features uh right there in all
right i'm going to simply just clear
these sheets that we have
and um
let's go back to the connect to data
source window all right now in terms of
uh
this is where you're able to connect you
can see the tablet server so it's
through the server that you can connect
wherein you can specify your server
credentials and you can click on connect
and uh based on that that's how then you
can provide the credentials and uh login
all right now i do not have a server or
connection wherein i can show that
example but this is how you can click on
any of these servers you would have to
uh type in the url click on connect and
then provide the usernames and login
provided and that's how you can connect
to your data source using a server
option all right i'm going to show you
the file option wherein you can connect
to an excel and let us discuss the join
and the blending path here all right so
let me click on
itself we have the sample super uh data
store here and in this
when i pulled in order all right i
pulled in the first sheet so there are
three sheets in that particular excel
file when we pull an order this is how
you can identify
that whatever are uh these are the
header names these are the dimensions
and measures that's how it's getting
identified you can notice all the
dimensions are first place you have all
your measures then you're able to
identify the data type and the role an
abc which is a contextual value or
numeric value that means it's a
dimension with a pound sign what kind of
a data role is it tablets automatically
identifying each of these roles as well
all right even in the metadata that's
how you can see the field names the
field or name that you're going to see
onto your tape onto your view and the
table from which it's going to be
getting pulled in from in this you can
rename in case you want to change the
particular name hide it or alias it or
describe it
all right so this is how you connect now
connections is where you have the option
to connect between knives and extract
now if you connect to live that means
you're connected to this particular
sheet live that means any update
happening onto your uh sheets any kind
of updates on the sheet there is a nice
connection it will automatically update
your views as well on to your shapes
that you're creating and in case if you
select on an extract all right this is
what it means that it allows uh what it
does it it imports that data into the
tableau data engine first in the data
engine where it's going to perform these
queries it'll create an extract and
based on these we can then start using
the connection all right so what it does
is it disconnects it's more like a small
extract more like a cube if you
understand it in that manner tableau
creates an extract of that file
providing you
a disconnected uh whether it allows you
to give you a better performance a
better query
uh that's how you can then uh work on
and start creating uh and working on
these extracts now you can refresh these
extracts at a timely manner as well so
that is what a tableau extracts are
where it extracts it as a copy of the
data uh and saves it in the engine and
that's how then the performance as well
gets better in terms of using where you
can connect to your particular data all
right so you can work with uh multiple
data sources data sources can be of any
type all right wherein you can edit from
the number of lists that you can see it
can be a flag file a server file as we
saw or the saved one
and we can also then join multiple
tables within the data or we can also
blend when it's coming in from different
data sources then we can also perform a
blending so let me first show you an
option for join now you can see we have
the order table here when i drag and
drop the people uh sheet as well here
you can see that tableau has
automatically created a join
all right it has automatically created a
join when we have pulled in two tables
coming in from the sheet and by default
all right we have the inner join that
tableau creates so it creates a inner
join here wherein again you can then
click on the join option here and you
can specify and modify the join based on
whether you want it as an inner join
which is a default you want a left join
now if you see the right join has been
disabled here okay i will show these
options here by default the right join
is uh disabled by uh tableau by default
by default and to enable that you will
have to uh connect to your uh excel
sheet in a different manner i will show
that your shortly so that's how you can
change and you can perform your join
this is where you can uh explore and
show the join clause and here again then
you can specify like you can see a joint
that's being created amongst the data
source which is region and region people
among these two data all right it's also
showing you the join and whether it is
uh equal to or not equal to all right so
you can connect to multiple tables and
uh based on that you can add in our
tables you can specify the different
joins and based on that then when you
click on sheet uh you will then be able
to see that there is a joint being
performed there are two tables now the
people's table also that has been added
in and it has now performed an inner
join on our data and you can start using
this particular option so let's say i'm
going to pull in
the region on my columns and i'm going
to have my sales on to my rows it's now
providing me
details of my sales at a regional basis
now let's say i also want to analyze
the
people belonging to these regions
depending on the color so it's going to
change the colors based on the central
east south and west
all right that's how these are uh the
people the number of people belonging to
each region that it has identified so
that's how it has taken up the region
people as you saw there was a joint that
was created and it's given us that
particular option and based on that you
can see here we just have uh this
particular data source here and uh
that's how you can see now i used it
earlier as well if you remember we had
pulled in one particular table hence the
blue tick mark sign here enables and
shows us that this is the primary data
that they use now this comes in picture
when we're using a particular join so
let me right now just um
uh use this particular uh detail here
and we're not going to require this all
right so let's just close this
we just need one right now because we're
discussing on blending i'm going to show
you the blending part later right now
we're discussing on joints so
uh that's how you can join in your data
sources and you can combine multiple
fields using these joints so when you
have when you have multiple tables you
can simply connect to the data let me go
back to the data source pane uh this is
the startup page the data source page
and you can see the joins that's been
performed now let's say you want to
create a join where you want to force
due to certain situations and scenarios
where you want to force
a right outer join all right or right
join or for that matter you want to
write a custom sequence now you're not
able to write a sql right here in the in
the drag area pane where you can drag
and drop your sheets from the excel file
or any kind of a file that you're
connected to for that
and to enable the right join you will
need to
connect to your data in a specific
manner so let me open up a new instance
of tableau here
and let me show that to you as to how we
can enable the right choice and how we
can have our custom sqls as well so in
case if we want to write in a custom sql
on our view then how can we perform that
initial custom sql all right
okay so let us connect to our data here
and i'm going to take you on to the
excel file
now when i click on the sample
superstore here okay uh what we had done
is we clicked on open and that's how we
opened up the uh file all right and
that's how we could see the sheets now
instead of using the open option
directly what i'm gonna do is in the
drop down
all right here instead of open we have
an option that says open with a legacy
connection all right this is what is
going to enable us to write a custom sql
where we can specify a query rather than
using the entire data source or pulling
in the entire table so we're clicking on
this second option in the drop down in
the open uh tab here you will be able to
see the open with legacy connection i'm
going to uh so ensure that you've
selected that and that's how you will
then connect to the data source
and with that you now have a new custom
sql option that's opened up for you all
this is where you can once you've
connected you can double click on the
new custom sql
and you can write in your query you can
write in the sql where you want to
perform the query and pull in your data
all right you can have your
select
from
and let's say
orders
all right so that's how you can perform
and you can write in a custom sql and
you can pull in the required data you
can or have your required table that you
can pull in in terms of or creating a
sequel that you want to pull it or and
have your data all right so you can have
your select from
the
orders
and
preview the results
so here you can see the orders table has
940 we have a preview of the data
available in that particular
sheet that we pulled in all right and we
can now parameters is what i'm going to
cover when we come on to that particular
topic so i'm going to leave this for now
so that's how you can write your custom
sql and you can click on ok and that's
going to pull in your entire data and as
you can see now instead in the earlier
view i'm going to just switch to the
earlier instance of tableau you could
see that you could see the name of the
table that i dragged and pulled in you
could see the name order but in case
when we write a custom sql then it gives
us the name which is written as custom
sql query all right and this is where
you can get the information you can edit
the query in case you want to change the
results and requirements so that's how
instead of clicking on open you click on
open legacy connection and you can have
your own custom sql defined
now along with this
all right when you open and when you
click on a legacy connection when i drag
in the people's table here you can see
that even the options for right joints
have now been enabled so by default
tableau disables the option for right
join and in case in certain situations
and circumstances you want the right
join to be enabled you will in the same
manner have to import and connect to
your data using a legacy connection and
you will have the right join which is
going to be enabled there for you all so
you can have your custom sequence or the
right join
in that case which gets enabled and you
can use a custom sequel or a right join
right so that was custom sql then uh
joining is where you can as i mentioned
identify and choose between the clauses
and the clause that you want to add in
right now let me show you an example of
blending as well so i'm again going to
open a new instance of tableau
all right and with that i'm going to
show you the example of blending so
let's say you have uh you want to join
in and when it's the best time where is
the best way that you should use now
joining is when you have all your
multiple tables that you want to join
coming in from one data source blending
would be required when you want to join
in
multiple tables coming in from different
data sources
or for that matter you can also blend
even though the tables are coming in
from a single data source there might be
instances that you might want to have
still perform a blend instead of a join
so let me show that option to you
all right so let me connect to the data
let's connect to excel
pull in our sample superstore file that
we have we have the order table all
right and i'm going to go on to the
sheets here all right so we have
one order we have one data which is the
order table now i'm going to again click
on
add a new data source coming in from the
same excel file and this time i'm going
to have the people's table
and
move to the sheet so now if you notice
we can see two
data sets here which is one for the
orders and one for
people here and uh in here now this is
where the blending will will take place
this is where you will have a blend
automatically when you pull in a view if
there is a common view that comes into
picture now let's say i'm going to first
pull in the order date onto the columns
all right
and as soon as i pull in you can see
that my order table has now got a blue
check mark which has become a primary
data force all right and now let me pull
in sales onto my rows
and
from people let me have
from the people's table let's have
region pulled in and added to the colors
so region has become a secondary data
set and now you can see a blend sign
right a linking or data blending that
has automatically been performed on both
these two data sets all right that we
have the order table and the people's
table blue being primary and people uh
which is being or secondary in this case
all right so that's how you can mention
now in terms of blending what happens is
you cannot specify the joint during this
case there is a primary and secondary
data and it is automatically blending in
the data for you it is automatically
pulling in uh the data you will not be
able to your select on the kind of join
you will not be able to manipulate the
join so that's how even though at times
you have the same tables that are coming
in as i mentioned there are times where
you might want to perform and change the
joints so that's when you can use the
joining table option that comes into
picture so that's the difference between
your blending and between joining the
tables
right so uh you can see this available
link and you can see how it was simple
to drag a particular view and uh pull in
data and your as well region has been
added to the color pill because of which
the legends have been created
identifying all four regions present in
the data and it's also letting us know
here in the marks that region is coming
in from the secondary table you can see
the orange amber tick mark here and
that's how you can identify that region
is coming in from the secondary table
that's been created all right
in terms of uh connecting as well
wherein you can combine and uh have the
joint uh enabled now depending on the
kind of data all right going back to the
data source depending on the kind of
tables and the kind of data that we have
that's when we can enable and have the
joints that we can decide on all right
so one is you would require and need to
have
a multiple uh legacy connection with
which you can then define the right
outer joints all right and that's how
you can proceed and have additional
joints that you can work on
we also discussed how we could create
and connect to a custom sql query all
right and uh that is how we could using
the legacy connection uh also enable the
right outer join where we could then
perform or write join on our tables as
well all right and in case if it's a
query then it gives them the name of uh
the query uh as a custom query
which is what we saw on do the preview
and the extract there all right
now in terms of extract all right now
extracts are basically your saved
subsets of the data source which will
help you in improving the performance so
instead of as i mentioned instead of
being connected to a live connection it
is better that we select an extract
which creates a subset and stores it in
the
uh tableau engine wherein it performs
the queries and it takes advantage of
this functionality where it is not
connected to the original data source
and with this it can actually reduce the
total amount of data in terms of
defining and limiting it so that's how
you can create an extract and let's say
uh once you've created an extract you
can then perform like i said you have
the edit option where you can edit the
additional detailing you can allow an
incremental fetch happening where then
you can refresh the data each time or
your data is updated you can provide an
implementation set so this can help you
in improving your performance you can
take advantage of the functionality in
terms of the data source for uh
using the discounts uh the existing
counts as well and moreover it's more
like an offline mode you're actually
accessing your data as an offline access
where it's not directly connected and
you're able to use it like a data local
data
all right so that is the difference
between a live and an extract so that's
how you can make use of the legacy
connections as well so let's go back to
the presentation slides and have a recap
now
[Music]
these are the joining tables that's what
we discussed that in terms of the tables
that we have we can join our table and
we have various joints available where
it makes it easy for us to uh analyze
the data that we want to view we can
join two or multiple tables and based on
that we can customize the inner the left
the right or the full outer join now the
full outer join also depends on the kind
of data source that you're connected to
all right so in case of an excel file we
still do not have the right outer join
option which is enabled so this possible
option again when you open with a legacy
depending on the data type is how you
would have the right outer join that you
can post and have it enabled so this
would be depending on the kind of data
source file also that you have and you
have these four join types that you can
use in terms of joining tables in
tableau
now when would you want to use a join
all right so a scenario is that you have
a sales manager of an online shopping
website and you want to analyze the
customers who have returned
at least half the number of orders that
they have placed now to fulfill this
requirement he will require a worksheet
wherein he can join the orders and the
return table on the particular common
dimension all right so that's how then
he can create a join he can change this
between uh the inner default to a left
join between the order tables and the
return tables and based on that he can
then get to know the customers who have
returned at least half the number of
orders that were placed all right now in
terms of enabling on the right outer
join uh this is taken care of by the
microsoft jet data engine driver so in
case if you all are facing a trouble
where you're not able to connect and see
that particular option it's throwing an
error this legacy connection options
comes in only when you're using a
microsoft
jet data engine driver this is easily
available in case if you do not have it
you can install this driver and with
this it will enable the right outer join
and the custom sequel for us all right
to enable the uh
right outer join here that's how you
open it with a particular
uh legacy connection
now in terms of a right outer join we
saw an example we can force and use the
right outer join we can select on a new
custom sql where we can type in and have
our custom
sql generated
and that's how we can work on with the
sql where we can provide the sql syntax
and based on that the data source will
then be generated
now in terms of blending this is what
happens when you have multiple data
sources in your view or when you want to
establish a link between them or you
want to
blend your data uh it does not create a
row level join so in case uh
like the example that we did also which
is coming in from the same sheet from
the same excel file but we did not want
to create a row level join then that's
when data blending would come in handy
you can use it with a related data
across multiple sources that you want to
analyze in one particular view so that's
how you can blend your data which
creates a primary and a secondary data
so we saw that in this example uh you
can see that it has a customer segment
department and sum of sales wherein the
bars are being created which are coming
in from the time from the primary
connection but in terms of the sales
plan all right these sales plan are
coming in from a secondary data you can
see the amber connection you're the
amber lineur that is allowing you to
understand and segregate and
differentiate that it is a secondary
connection
so in tableau that's how you can
identify as you saw that your primary
source and you have your secondary
source wherein you can identify and
distinguish you can distinguish between
the common fields that are present in
your data and you can establish a
connection in case if it has not
established a link you saw that there
was an automatic link then you can
provide a link
by explicitly defining a link as well
let me take you back to uh the
environment
all right
so this was the custom sql
now in this case in case if there is uh
no link provided then you can provide a
particular link onto your view you can
have the option if it has not enabled
then you can select your particular you
can see that uh it has not uh implicitly
defined but it's giving you an option
that there is possibility of linking so
you can explicitly define you can click
on this link and use person as a linking
field and this was also linked in your
data with the previous data that you
have all right so that's how you can
define and explicitly mention uh the
way that you can blend your data and you
can identify another way can also be
where and you can edit uh the connection
in the mapping and that's where you can
perform so you can go back to your data
sources and you can explicitly define
you can identify uh whether the first
rows are the names whether uh the rows
here are automatically generating a
field or not all right so that's how you
can have these two tables and you can
define the blending whether you want it
or not you can disable the linking as
well in case you don't want to perform a
particular link
so
uh with uh coming to that now let us
understand i've already discussed the
difference between the joints and blends
and where you can use it so let's uh
have a recap again or in terms of
joining uh joining is a sequel term
where it is combining two data sources
coming in from a single data source
while in terms of blending it's more
about combining two different data
sources into one single sheet all right
uh joining is done once at the data
source and this can be used for every
worksheet while blending will be done
individually for every worksheet okay
and both the tables that are joined must
must exist in the sql database while in
blending it helps us combine the
database which is coming in from
different sources different locations
and in case if it's a multi-dimensional
source if it's a cube then you cannot
perform a join and in terms of blending
you have a primary source and uh but in
terms of a primary source it cannot be a
cube but your secondary source can
definitely be a cube that you can use in
terms of performing a blend all right
so that's how you can optimize your
connections you can select whether you
want to have uh perform a blend on your
connections you want to perform a join
depending on the kind of connections
that you have and that's how you can
work with them with the different data
sources that you have available
so at first we will understand what
exactly is an lod expression in w
so l o d
expression stands for level of detail
expressions in w
the l o d expressions will allow you to
compute values at data source level and
visualization level however lod
expressions give you even more control
on the level of granularity that you
want to compute they can be performed at
more granular level that is we use
include lod expression there a less
granular level where they exclude lod
expression will be handy and finally an
entirely independent level that is the
fixed lod expression so in this tutorial
i'll explain you the types of lod
expressions you can use in w as well as
when to use them and how to format them
i will also use an example to
demonstrate how to create simple lod
expressions in table u now in this image
you can understand that
the aggregation and granularity levels
are inversely proportional that means as
the level of aggregation or as the level
of ordering in data increases the
granularity level gradually decreases so
this particular example will help you
understand the inverse proportional
relation between the aggregation and
granularity
now let's move into the next part where
we will understand the two types of lod
expressions in w so basically there are
two types of lod expressions in tableau
the first one is the row level lod
expression and the second one is the
view level lod expression
so in w expressions referring to
unaggregated data source columns and are
computed for each row in the underlying
table are the row level expressions so
in row level expressions the
dimensionality of the expression is
considered to be at the row level only
now the second type of lod expression
that is the view level lod expression so
by contrast which is the opposite to row
level the expressions referring to
aggregated data source columns are
computed in the dimensionality defined
by the dimensions in the view in the
view level lod expressions the
dimensionality of the expressions is
confined to the view level only
now the next part is about the syntax of
lod expressions in w
so as you can see on my screen we have a
sample syntax to be followed for the
level of detail expressions in w so we
will be following the same kind of
syntax in our real-time examples now
moving ahead we have the types of lod
expressions in table u so basically as
discussed in the definition we have
three different types of
lod expressions in w so the first one is
the include level of detail expressions
in w the second one is the exclude level
of detail expressions in tableau and
finally the last one that is the fixed
level of detail expressions and w don't
worry we will understand each one of
them in a bit more detail along with a
practical example for a better
understanding
so the first one the include level of
detail expression
the include level of detail expressions
compute values using the specified
dimensions in the addition to whatever
dimensions are in the view
include level of detail expressions can
be useful when you want to calculate at
a fine level of detail in the database
and then re-aggregate and show at a
coarser level of detail in your view
fields based on include level of detail
expressions will change as you add or
remove dimensions from the view now
let's get back to tab value and try to
execute a simple example for include
level of detail expression
now we are back on tableau and we are
going to use the sample data set in the
table which is the superstore data set
now to create lod expressions in tableau
we have some steps so the first step is
to set up a visualization first so we
need to use the data from the dimensions
and measures and we need to create a
visualization on the sheet and once the
visualization on the sheet is ready then
we are going to create the lod
expression so for that we are going to
use the analysis button on the toolbar
and then we are going to create a
calculated field and inside the
calculated field we are going to create
our expression for lod that is the level
of detail so once the calculated field
is set up or the level of detail
expression is set up the third step is
to use the level of detail expression in
the visualization that is we'll be
getting the newly created level of
detail expression field in this
particular dimensions or measures and
we'll be dragging that into the rows or
columns or we'll be dragging that into
the details tool tips uh text size color
etc etc basically we'll be using that
particular new field which got generated
using the level of detail expression and
we'll be creating the new visualization
using that particular lod
now we have a brief idea how to create
an lod
now let's begin with the first type of
lod expression that is the include type
of lod expression now let's try to
rename this sheet
i'll rename it as include lod
so before getting started i would like
to tell you guys that
we will be using color size label detail
so only these four boxes are only these
four shells will be affecting the level
of detail visualization in real time and
the tool tip and filter pages etc etc
will not be affecting that much
now let's begin with the first one
now as the first step we are going to
create a visualization on the screen
first
so for that let's drag the
region
into columns
now let's drag the sum of sales into
columns
so now we have a bar chart visualization
on my screen which tells about the
number of sales happening in different
different regions so if we have an
example that is central which is near to
500k and east is around
678 k
and similarly south and similarly west
so basically we have created the first
step that is create a visualization on
this sheet
now the second step to create the new
calculated field that is the lod
expression for that will be moving to
the analysis button on the menu bar
click that and
you can see in the drop down menu we
have the create calculated field option
select that
now let's rename this
now let's rename this as sales per
customer
let's select the region where we have to
write our expression so for that we'll
use the include option
next we have the customer
we'll select the customer name or even
we can select the customer id let's go
with the customer id
then
let's select the sum
or
sales
so we have our lod expression ready
okay this shows that the calculation has
some errors
yeah they should be resolved
and let's go with customer name and
let's select ok
yeah i think we forgot to mention the
flower bracket at the end
let's try that yeah now the expression
is proper
so the best part of tableau is if there
is an error in your expression tabular
will not allow you to continue with that
it will show a warning over here that's
the best part so now let's consider the
id back again
yeah they should be fine
now let's select okay so that we have
the new uh field that is sales per
customer in our dimensions part
no no the measures part
yeah we have the new field in the
measures bar that is the sales per
customer now the next step is to use
this particular field
and generate the level of details
now we have the newly created field over
here
so that is basically the third part we
are going to do right now
now we are going to drag this and place
it into the rows
so we have two different bar charts now
the sales per customer and another
bar chart which is of sales now we are
going to select the sales per customer
and right click on it
now we have the drop down menu and
inside that we are going to select the
measure so we have the sum measure right
now as default now we are going to
change that into average
now we have the average sales per
customer according to regions so the
average sales per customer is 796.9
units
and that is in the central region next
we have the east region south and west
so that's how we use the include level
of detail expressions in table now we
are done with one example based on
include level of detail expression let's
try to execute another example
now we have the sheet 2 let's try to
rename it let's rename it include
lod
hyphen 2.
now in this particular second lod
expressions we are going to
calculate the sum of sales on per state
basis
now let's move to the analysis button on
the menu bar
let's try to
select the create calculated field
option
now
let's try to write in the expression
name
average
sales
per
state
now inside the
tray let's try to add the expression
include
state
now sum of sales
now let's try to close the flat bracket
yeah now we have the valid expression
let's just select ok so that we find the
average sales per state option or the
newly created field in the measures
section
now let's drag the category into columns
and
the newly created average sales per
state into rows and we have the level of
detail visualization on the screen right
now
so the furniture is about 742 units
and the next one is the office which is
719 000 units
and the last one is the 8 36 000 units
so this is the average sales happening
in particular categories so remember we
have three different categories in our
sales
superstore data set which is the
furniture office and technologies so
these are the
average sales happening
now with this we have the calculation
placed on rows shelf and it is
aggregated as an average but we still
have to find the sales happening by
state so with that we have the
calculation placed on the row shelf and
it is aggregated as an average so the
resulting visualization averages the sum
of sales by state across categories
now let's drag this segment option into
the columns
so when the segment is added to column
shelf and the calculation is moved to
label the lod expression results update
now you can see how the average sum of
sales first date varies across
categories and segments now we have all
the bus in one particular color let's
try to change it by dragging the
category into color so we have different
colors for different categories
now let's try to drag the average sales
per state into color so that we have
different colors
again
so this is how it works
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now with that let's move into the next
type of lod expressions that is the
exclude lod expressions in w
so the exclude level of detail
expressions declared dimensions to omit
from the view level of detail
exclude level of detail expressions are
useful for percent of total or
difference from overall average
scenarios
they are comparable to such features as
totals and reference lines exclude level
of detail expressions cannot be used in
row level expressions where there are no
dimensions to omit but it can be used to
modify either a view level calculation
or anything between that is you can use
an exclude calculation to remove
dimensions from some other level of
detail expressions so to understand
exclude level of detail expressions in
tableau in a much more detailed way
let's get back to w and try to execute
some examples
now we are back onto tableau let's
create the exclude level of detail
expression example
so i'll be renaming the sheet exclude
lod now we have created a new sheet and
rename that as exclude lod now this
particular sheet will be used to
calculate the level of details
which excludes the region from a
calculation of sum of sales now for that
let's try to create a new
calculated field for that let's select
the analysis select create calculated
field now let's rename this as exclude
region
now let's select okay
okay we didn't write the expression over
there
now
let's edit it and in the tray let's
write the expression
let's select exclude
and in that let's select region
then
let's write in the sum of
sales
let's close the flower bracket
now let's select okay
now we have the new field over here
which is the exclude region now we'll be
using this particular field to create a
new visualization on the screen
now let's drag the region to columns
let's drag the sum of sales
to
columns
now let's track the order
date to
rows
now select select the month
let's kind of change this chart to bar
chart
now this is more likely
good to view
now let's drag the
newly created field that is exclude
region onto color
so that we can have different colors
now this particular step will help us to
view the total sales by month without
the regional component
so this is how the exclude level of
detail expressions will be used in real
time now we can actually make a little
change to this by selecting this one and
right click it or we can go to colors
directly and right click the
colors and select the edit colors and
inside this we're gonna select
kind of
orange to blue
orange to blue diverging
so that we can have a good level of
visualization
now let's move on to the next type of
loading expression syntab which happens
to be the fixed level of detail
expressions
so the fixed level of detail expressions
compute a value using the specified
dimensions without reference to the
dimensions in the view
now let's get back to tableau and try to
execute an example based on fixed level
of detail expressions in w
now we are back on tableau let's create
a new sheet and rename that sheet as
fixed lod
let's type an enter
yeah
now let's get back to the analysis menu
let's create a calculated field
let's rename this as sales by region
so we have the sales by region over here
now let's get back to the tray and try
to add in our
expression
so we should be using a fixed expression
over here
fixed
and
now let's type in region
then sum of sales
let's close the flow bracket now the
expression is valid so we have the sales
by region lod which is the fixed lod
let's select ok and you can see the
newly created field on the measures
section
let's drag the region onto rows and then
let's drag the state into the region of
rows
so now we have a text table
now the view level of the detail is
region plus state but because fixed
level of detail expressions do not
consider view level of detail the
calculation only uses the dimension
reference in the calculation which in
this case is region so because of this
you can see that the values of the
individual states in each region are
identical
if the include keyword has been used in
the level of detail expression instead
of fixed the values would have been a
little different for each state biggest
w would add the dimension in the
expression that is the region with any
additional dimensions in the view state
when determining values for the
expression
now with this let's get back to the
presentation again
so the next segment in this particular
today for our discussion is the tables
versus lod expressions
so now we'll be discussing the
differences between the tables and lod
expressions so the first one is filters
filters involved in table calculate
behave like height and filters involved
in lod calculations behave like exclude
the next difference is
table calculations are generated as
query results whereas the lod
expressions are generated as a part of
query to the underlying data source the
third difference is stable calculations
are capable to generate either equal or
less granule than the set lod or level
of detail but whereas on the lod
expressions case the level of detail
expressions can generate results
independent of the set level of detail
the fourth difference between the both
is
table calculations are used as
aggregated measures whereas the level of
detail expressions can be used in other
constructs the final differences between
the table and lod expressions as the
dimensions that control the operations
of a table are separate from the
calculation syntax whereas in the lod
expressions dimensions that control the
operations of an lod are embedded into
the expression itself
now with that let's continue with the
next part of this particular tutorial
where we will be discussing the
limitations of lod expressions in
tableau
so following are the limitations of lod
expressions in tableau so the first one
is lod expressions behave unreliable
views when floating values are involved
so lod expressions that reference
floating point measures tend to behave
in an unreliable fashion when used in a
view that requires a comparison of the
values in the expression
the next one is lod expressions will not
be shown in the data source
so the lod expressions will not be
available in the data source page when
you are using them in real time followed
by that the next limitation is you
should always keep in mind when
referencing a parameter in a
dimensionality declaration always use
the parameter name and not the parameter
value
followed by that the next limitation of
lod expressions in tableau is with data
blending the linking field from the
primary data source must be in the view
before you can use an lod expression
from the secondary data source
so first up what exactly is data
blending
so data blending is a method for
combining data from multiple sources
data blending brings in additional
information from a secondary data source
and displays it with data from the
primary data source directly in the view
so it might be a little complicated to
understand so let us make it a little
simple
let's imagine that you have data
some of your data is present in your sql
database and some of your data is
present in excel database or excel
worksheet and some data is present in
your cloud say salesforce
so your duty is to combine all your data
from different sources that is sql
worksheet salesforce and work on it so
you might have a question here we
already have joints but joints and
relations have their own limitations or
drawbacks so to cover that up or
overcome those issues tableau has come
up with data blending
now let us take a step further and
understand what exactly i meant by
joining and
relationships and data blending
so as we discussed before the data
blending is a method for combining data
from multiple sources data blending
brings in additional information from a
secondary data source and displays it
with data from the primary data source
directly in the view yeah this was the
definition you can take a screenshot of
this and you can keep it for further
reference
now as we discussed there are some
existing ways to combine your data such
as relationships joints etc etc and then
we have the data blending option
so first relationships so
why exactly we do not prefer
relationships in a few situations
relationships cannot be formed between
tables from data sources published to
tableau server or tably online so
relationships can't be formed based on
calculated fields when you use data
blending you can create calculation
fields those are called as data blending
calculations now next thing is the joins
joins combine tables by adding more
columns of data across similar row
structures and this can cause data loss
or duplication so when you use joins and
create the relationship between multiple
data sources of multiple tables then
there is a chance that the data can be
duplicated so just imagine that you have
two different tables and the two
different tables have one common field
such as id so even a student id has id
and employee id has id if you use a join
then there are chances that you might
get ids of both employee and students so
that's a duplication right so to avoid
that you can go with a data blending
now data blending unlike relationships
or joins never truly combine the data
instead blends query each data source
independently the results are aggregated
to the appropriate level then the
results are presented visually together
in the view that's the reason why we use
data blending
now up next
we have the data blending example now
this is where we get into the practical
mode we'll get back to our data first so
we'll see what kind of data we are going
to use for this particular example and
what are we going to do with that data
in the w
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so this is the excel sheet which has the
car sales data set that we'll be using
today this is the one of the data sets
and we have another data set
let me
yeah so we have another data set which i
personally created so this is a little
similar to the cast data set so i've
created this data set a little bit
similar to the cost sales data set so
that we can use this in the scenarios of
data blending so that you can understand
the concept in a much better way so we
have the following columns the
manufacturer model resale value engine
size horsepower wheelbase fuel capacity
fuel efficiency annual sales and region
and when we come into the bike sales we
have the same kind of columns so we have
the manufacturer model engine size
horsepower fuel capacity fuel efficiency
annual sales and zone so you can see
that this zone and region from the car
sales data set are similar but the name
is different so there's a reason i've
created a different uh name for this
particular column so that while we are
working on tableau data blending we'll
be actually blending these two columns
as a custom blender
so this is why i've named this
particular column as zone
and yeah
so far so good i think we are good with
the data set now we'll get back to
tableau and start working on these data
sets
yeah so now we are on w
let's uh
since we're working on excel let's
create the excel
and yeah here we got our excel files
first let's click in car
yeah there we go we have the car data
set over here
and if you see we have got some
additional columns which we don't need
so the actual column we had was this
when when i downloaded the data set this
was the actual column which has uh sales
in 2000
actually we had the
16.919 which i multiplied here okay so i
had made some changes to the data set in
the excel file and i've hidden the
actual data set so we don't need this
one over here so we'll do the hide
option over here as well so that's gone
over here now let's kind of rename this
as annual sales
enter and we don't need this f column so
this particular f column was created for
a formula on x
into sales in 2000 so we don't need this
one as well we'll remove this height
and the resale value and another f1 here
we'll remove this
now
engine size one
why don't we rename that as engine size
done
and uh do we have any other extra things
no
and
annual sales too yeah that's gone as
well
so the region manufacturer model annual
sales resale value engine size
another engine size okay this was a
problem so
when you look into the engine size over
here
okay and here so when you look at the
engine size here this is the actual
engine size from the data sets the
original one so it is represented in the
form of liters so basically the car
engines are always represented in the
form of liters so 1.8 liter engine 3.5
liter engine
but when you come into bikes they
represent the engine size in the form of
cc's that is cubic centimeters so the
bikes have 650 cc engine 1030 or
yeah 1340 cc engine yeah that's how we
represent the engine size and bikes so
to make things similar i have created
the engine size ncc in the form of cc
over here you can see that over here so
1.8 is equals to 100 or 1800
cubic centimeters so we don't need this
particular column here so we'll
eliminate this or we'll hide this
so far so good we have horsepower engine
size resale value fuel capacity fuel
efficiency region yeah everything is
fine now so now the next step is to add
the
second data set or the second data
source so you can do that by selecting
this particular icon over here and
select a new data source or or there is
another way
you can
enter into your worksheet
and
you don't have to enter into your
worksheet you can do that from here as
well you can select the data and
add new data source so these are the
various options you can select a new
data source from here or you can select
a new data source from here or if you're
on the sheet then you can go again to
the data section and you can select the
data source from here as well or you
also have a short key
so when you see it
so you have a short key here which says
control okay sorry so you can read it
right on the right hand side of this
particular
dialog box ctrl d you can directly press
ctrl d and add your new data source as
well so now we'll add the new data
source so since another data set that
you're working on is also an excel file
we'll select the excel file
so that was bike sales and
yeah there you go we have a bike sales
data set right on my screen right now
so in here as well you can see some
access or unnecessary columns so we'll
remove that as well so
we'll hide this we'll hide
this
we'll hide this as well
now we have engine size horsepower fuel
capacity efficiency okay we have our
annual sales here
so i've changed a few numbers in this
particular annual sales column these are
not accurate so i've created some random
numbers just so that they're different
from the car sales
so yeah so far so good we have this zone
over here the regions column from yeah
let me show you that
let's go to the
sheet yeah so when you see cars we have
region over here
okay
so when you get into cars we have the
region over here which has the north
south east west and similarly when you
get into bikes we have the zone which
has the north south east west et cetera
et cetera so we are
now going to create the
blending between the two data sets
so we have the data set over here which
is the bike and we have another data set
over here which is the car so to create
a blend
let's get into
data and you can see the edit blend
relationships
row in the dialog box or the option in
the dialog box so
remember when you just have one data
source just imagine that you only had a
car's data set only one data set well
let us remove this
how how do you remove this
close
so
we just have one data set over here
which is the buy status set so now when
you click on datum you don't have that
option see it you don't have that option
edit blend relationships but but when
you get a different data source
so we have car sales over here now let's
get back our
okay did we had the cars over there
sales bike we have we have the bike
sales over here now let's get back our
cars data set
yeah
okay sorry sorry we can we can make the
changes again not a problem so we'll
remove this
we'll rename it
on this note
let me tell you guys
if you are getting some errors or if
you're getting some uh you know kind of
troubles while you're learning
it's a sign that you're trying your best
so we have simply learn community which
has
um the solutions to your problems so if
you have any problems while you're
learning then you can
directly you know post your query over
there and our team of experts will be
really happy to help you out with the
solutions
so we have our annual sales over here
and another annual sales which we don't
need so we'll hide that
we have the manufacturer model annual
sales resale value engine size
so i think we don't need this engine
size which isn't the latest
now we'll rename this
as engine size
great
yeah we're done so we'll get back to our
sheet now when you hover over to data
and
you can find the data relationship
option over here so this happens when
you have multiple sources only now let's
click that and you can see we have the
automatic option
and the tableau has automatically you
know found a data blend option for the
columns which have the same names so we
have manufacturer model and
manufacturer and model in both bikes and
cars
so we also have the same names for
annual sales engine fuel fuel efficiency
horsepower also so they are in the
measures section that's the reason the w
has ignored them so
and remember that we have regions in
cars and zone and bikes but we can't
find that relationship over here because
they have different column names to get
a blend between those columns we can
always choose custom so when you choose
custom okay
we don't have zone over here
you need to make some changes i guess
yeah we need to press add icon and from
add you can see the region from
the cars data set and zone from bikes
data set
select ok and then you can find a blend
relationship between the region from
cars and zone from bikes
now we have the blend successfully
applied let's select okay and we are
done
so let's begin with our operations so
currently we are in
bike sales data set
so if we start the operations on buy
sales data set for an example let's
choose
zone into columns and
annual cells into rows
so you can see a little tiny blue tick
over here so this particular little tiny
blue tick represents that this has now
become your primary data set or primary
data source because you're currently
working on that particular data set now
if you remove the zone and annual sales
and again if your shade is completely
empty and if you enter into the car's
data set and again choose regions and
regions on the columns again the same
thing drag the angle sales into rows
like i'm just showing you if there is
some operations happening with the
particular data set then you can find
the blue tick icon which says that
you're working on this particular data
set so that's how we see it
now
so this is how you find the you know
sales happening in that particular
region
and
yeah we can create another sheet
and then we'll see
which model has the
biggest engine
now let's kind of sort it
so viper has the biggest engine dodge
wiper yeah a muscle car of america
now
let's create a different sheet now let's
get back into bikes data set
which is the most fuel efficient bike
uh row and model
so now
according to the data set what i created
multistrada 950 has the biggest mileage
that's great
okay it shouldn't give 50 maybe i think
i entered some wrong value
yeah sv 650
or we can actually take a manufacturer
over here and you know
so sv 650 belongs to
[Music]
let's sort it
where is sv650 yeah sv 650 belongs to
suzuki great
so sv650 has a good mileage
next to multistrada 950.
so this is how you can use sheets and
data from different data sets now moving
forward let's create some data blending
calculations for that let's create a new
sheet
now we have created a new sheet now
let's rename it as data blend
calculations
now we have successfully renamed our
sheet as data blending calculations
now
we are in car sales so
let's drag the manufacturer into columns
and sales annual sales of the
manufacturer into columns
so we have the report of annual sales of
different car manufacturers over here
ford leading and we have porsche
subaru
suzuki hindi etc etc
now let's get back to bike sales and
drag these same annual sales from the
bytes data set into rows
so as you can see on my screen you have
the
annual sales for cars and bikes together
on one single screen so here we have
suzuki as well which is a bike maker and
ford etc etc are the car makers so other
than bikes we have another 28 nulls
which do not belong to the bike section
now our aim is to create a new
calculated wheel which is about the data
blending calculation
so you can see that a little icon over
here which represents the blend icon
and you can always select that to stop
the blending and you can
click on that to use it as a linking
field
so that's how you can use the blend icon
now we are about to create a new
calculated field so you can right click
and create a calculated field or you can
always choose the icon over here and
create a calculated field so now we have
the calculated field over here let's
rename it as data blend calculation
now we have successfully renamed our
calculated field as data blend
calculation now we'll find the sum of uh
sales happening in cars and bikes so for
that we'll be using the summation
of sales
or annual sales
now we have the annual sales sum of
bikes now we'll add the cars one for
that i'll be selecting plus
and sum of
annual sales of cars
so you can see that we have two sums
over here so we don't need that
second sum so we'll eliminate that
so we have another bracket over here
which we don't need so we'll eliminate
that as well so now the calculation
field is valid let's click apply and
okay
so now you can see a newly created
calculation field over here with the
icon equals to hashtag which says that's
a calculated field now let's drag this
calculated field into the rows icon
and you can see the sum of uh
both sales happening in
uh this particular segment here which
shows you the sum of sales of both cars
and bikes now you can see that we have
28 nulls over here right so we should be
having all the you know when you're
calculating the sum of annual sales of
both the data sets and you should be
having something over here
so for that we need to make a little
addition over here that's a function
z and yeah
now after adding said then
okay we lost the sum so we need to add
the sum again
and sum of annual sales
or
we can just add it over here
okay this should be pretty good now we
need to add another zn over here
and another sum over here
close the bracket
yeah this should be good yeah the
calculation is valid now let's add apply
and okay now we have the annual sales
with both cars and bikes and suzuki
combined bmw combined as well
so that's how we do the w data blending
operations so with that let's get back
to the presentation mode again
now the next part in our tutorial today
is
the data blending versus joins so what
are the differences between data
blending and joints so this particular
short data table should explain you the
differences between them so in data
blending the data gets aggregated first
then the data gets combined but where in
joints the data will be
joined first or combined first then the
data is aggregated and the second
difference is when we use data blending
the dataset is from different data
sources but when you use joins you need
to make sure that the data is coming
from a single source now when we come
into the data blending again you can
only use left join so you can consider
data blending as an advanced version of
joins but only the left join can be
applied but when we come into joins we
have the different types of joints like
left joint right joint etc etc right we
have different types of joints so that's
how we have a difference between joints
and data blending the fourth difference
is data can be available in different
level of granularity in data blending so
the level of granularity can be
maintained at a different level when you
have or different levels when you use
their blending but when you use joints
all the granularity of all the data
should be maintained at the same level
and the last difference between the both
is data blending sends separate query to
each data set and aggregates then
performs blending and the last
difference between the both is when you
use data blending the data blending
sends separate query to each data set
then aggregates them and finally
performs data blending operations but
when you use joins the queries will be
sent to the datas at a row level
so with that let's enter into the next
segment where we will discuss about the
limitations of data blending
so the limitations of data blending are
as follows data blending compromises the
query execution speed and high
granularity so when you have the higher
rate of granularity on your data sets
then obviously the execution speed will
be compromised next
while sorting a calculated field that
uses blended data that field is not
listed in the sorted field drop down
dialog box and the last limitation is
cube data sources can be used only as a
primary data source to the blend data in
tableau and cannot be used as a
secondary data source now without
further ado let's directly begin with
the one point agenda that is the charts
in w so for the charts in w i'm using
two different data sets to just make
things look a little bit more
interesting
so the first data set that we will be
dealing with is the amazon prime tv data
set so this particular data set has the
following columns the serial number name
of the serial year of the release
number of seasons language genre imdb
ratings and age of viewers so we will be
using this particular data and will try
to extract some insights from this data
using the charts in w so followed by
amazon prime tv data set we have another
data set called as the w super store
data set so this particular data set is
a sample data set available in tableau
public and it is open for all you can
take this data set and try to extract
some insights from this as well now
without further ado let's try our first
chart that happens to be the bar chart
so what exactly is a bar chart
as you can see on the left side we have
a sample image which explains how a bar
chart typically looks like
so a bar chart basically represents the
data in the form of rectangular bars
with the length of the bar proportional
to the value of the variable
now this might be a little deviated i
can understand that so to understand
this in a much more better way let's get
back to tableau and execute some
practical examples and understand what
exactly is a bar chart in a much more
detailed way so here we are on the table
u
so
you can see i have already executed some
examples on the amazon prime data set
and we have all the charts that we'll be
going to discuss today we have the bar
chart pareto chart side by side bar
chart text tree map etc etc now why am i
showing this so i have actually saved
this data set or what do you call it as
book yeah we call it as a book in w so
i've executed all the charts and i have
seen this in the form of a book in the
tableau public and i'll also give the
link to this particular book so that you
can have a reference to this and you can
try to execute your examples on your own
in your local system
now for our reference let's try to
create a new sheet
so we can name this new sheet
just double click on that
so i'll rename this as bar chart 2 so
that we don't have a confusion between
the existing bar chart and the new bar
chart
just press enter and it's done so to
execute a bar chart let's select general
and drag it down to columns and
the prime tv shows and drag it down to
rows
now you can see that we have a bar chart
here which explains us we have different
genres such as action action comedy
adventure animation etc etc
so now let's uh kind of sort it
so now you can see in the particular
type of china which is drama we have the
most number of prime tv shows so
basically the audience would like to see
the drama based seasons or serials at
the most compared to others
so remember we discussed the length of
the bar which shows the volume of the
variable let's get back to the
definition once more so you can see a
bar chart represents data in the form of
rectangular bus that is we have the data
represented in the form of rectangular
bars and
continued with that with the length of
the bar proportional to the value of the
variable so
we have the drama at the maximum number
of series so 125 number of shows based
on drama so this happens to be the
biggest one and followed by that a
little smaller one which has a little
less number of seasons or shows which is
the type jenna comedy so you can see
that if the value is bigger the volume
of the
length or the length of the bar is
bigger so that's how the bar chart works
in real time so it basically shows the
biggest power for the biggest amount of
data now followed by the bar chart the
next chart we have is
this side by side bar chart now what
exactly is a side by side bar chart
so a side by side bar chart is
completely similar to the bar chart no
rocking signs or no nothing big
difference in between the bar chart and
the
side by side bar chart if we get back to
w you can see that we have different
genres here so we have drama comedy kids
action etc etc so if you wanted to
change this into a side by side bar
chart then we can add a one more data
into the columns which happens to be the
name of the show so what exactly will be
happening here so we will be getting few
more bars over here so those few more
bars will be off the name of the show so
in uh the genre of drama we'll be having
different different shows right for
example the show name a is in the form
of drama show name b is in the form of
drama and followed by that we have a a
in comedy bb in comedy so that's how you
categorize so basically the bars will be
represented that's for sure and the data
is represented in the form of categories
so
we have few serials in the drama
category we have few serials in comedy
category so that's how it happens now
let's see that practically now let's
track the show name to columns and we'll
see that happening
so you can see that happening over here
now let's kind of sort it again
yeah it's sorted so you can see we have
the first category that is the arts
entertainment culture so in that
particular category we have different
different shows tommy little
and the son of abisha
and
paul chaudhary etc etc so basically we
have categorized them and we have the
side by side bar charts comparing each
other now we'll get back to a little
further
and there you can see uh we have the
jenna here and the series happening in
the this particular jenna so this the
drama jenner and inside that we have
various amount of series the good fight
the good doctor etc etc so that's what
the bar chart does in real time so
basically we had the same bar chart but
the only difference is the fields were
divided in different categories
now followed by the side by side bar
chart the third type of chart that we
will be having today is the pareto chart
now what is a pareto chart
so pareto chart has bars and a line
graph so so far we have discussed bar
charts we will also discuss the line
graphs in the further section so line
graph is no different from bar charts
but the only difference is you can see
here right so if we pull out the names
so we have this bar chart so we can
actually change this chart into a line
chart just by clicking on line so you
can see this has converted into line
chart so
we will deal with that in a little more
detail we don't worry about it so this
is our line chart basically looks like
so i have explained you the line chart
just because we have the two different
types of charts in the pareto chart so
there is an inclusion of a bar chart as
well as a line chart or the line graph
so a pareto chart has bars and line
graph the individual values are shown in
descending order by bars and the
ascending cumulative total is
represented by the line
so we will understand the definition in
a bit more detail practically by getting
back onto table u
now let's get back to w1
so now we are back on tab w now let's
create a new chart or new sheet
let's rename the sheet as a pareto chart
don't worry we have already operated
chart over here
i'll just rename it as pareto 2.
don't worry at the end of the video i'm
not going to save anything on to this
particular
book we'll be having the book as it was
when we started the tutorial so that you
don't have to face any duplications in
this particular book
so pareto chart
2
enter
and now we have the pareto chart 2 over
here
so to create a pareto chart let's drag
the jinnah into the columns
yeah now we have the jenna into the
columns
now into the rows we'll drag the number
of prime tv shows based on that
particular genre
so now we are back on the
bar chart now w has automatically
selected the type of chart to be used
for this particular data which is the
bar chart
now let's right click on the channel and
now you can see a sort option
now we have the dialog box over here
let's select the sort by option by field
and
let's select uh
descending order
and aggregation by count
so we'll select this and the aggregation
is count
and it's done let's close it now now the
second step is
we will drag
the amazon prime tv show dataset again
onto the rows
now we have two different bar charts
now everything starts from here we'll
change few things so that we create a
proper pareto chart
now we will select or right click the
second count prime tv shows
and now we will select dual axis
now you can see the chart has changed
itself into the dots type
now you might have a doubt we had two
different bar charts now we just have
one axis that is y-axis and x-axis and
the two charts have gone into one so
what's happening here so what's
basically happened here is we just merge
the x-axis of both the measures so we
have the measures over here right the
count of prime tv shows and the second
count of prime tv shows so we have
basically merged the x-axis of both
these measures
now we'll enter into the step three so
now you can see on the marks card we
have two different count prime tv shows
so we'll now select the first one
and inside that we have the pop-up of
marks card where we have the options of
selecting the kind of charts for our
data and now for the first one we will
select the bar type of chart
now you can see that we have the bar
type of charts over here
now we will select the color for our
bars so to select color you just need to
select the color option and inside that
we have various types of colors
now let's select kind of green
so we have green over here
now let's get back to the second kind of
prime tv shows and inside here let's
select line
so we have a line over here now we can
actually kind of
select the color for that as well now
we'll select some opposite color for
that let's select pink
or you can also go with orange kind of
more visible
yeah we are done with the color
selection
now the next step
now we'll get back to the
second
measure over here now we'll
right click it
and inside that we will select add table
calculation
now we'll select the calculation type
and we needed
the running total of this
and
we we're gonna compute this using table
across
and
the most important step is the last step
to select the add a secondary
calculation by clicking on this we'll
have another dialog box and we need to
add some more details into this one
so here we'll be selecting the
difference from
and we'll change that to
percent of total
and next we'll select the table across
which is
the default one over here and we're done
so as discussed in the definition the
individual values are shown in
descending order by bars and the
ascending cumulative total is
represented by the line so you can see
the individual values of the jenna are
represented in the form of bars and the
ascending cumulative total is in the
form of line so this is how we use the
pareto chart in real time in w now
moving ahead the next type of chart that
we will be discussing today is
the text chart there is nothing much of
a rocket science and text chart it's
just a simple tabular way of expressing
your data text charts are created by
placing one dimension on the row shelf
and another on the column shelf text
tables are also called as crosstabs or
pivot tables
now let's get back to w and try to
execute a simple example as you can see
in this particular book i have already
executed a text chart now
to avoid confusion let's try to recreate
another sheet
and rename it as text chart2
it's done
now let's drag in the jenna and the name
of the show to the rose
so you can see that the tableau has
automatically selected the text chart
for this particular data and we have our
text chart over here which shows us the
jenner which is action the name of the
show's under jenna category and
similarly action comedy adventure
animation etc etc
now with this let's continue with our
next type of chart so the next type of
chart that we will be dealing today is
the waterfall chart
so the waterfall chart displays the
cumulative effect of sequential positive
and negative values it shows where the
value starts ends and how it goes there
incrementally
so the waterfall chart is a little
complicated than the other charts now i
want you guys to follow me up a little
bit more cautiously now let's continue
with the waterfall chart so for that
let's drag the language from dimensions
into columns and
prime tv shows data from measures to
rules
now we have our bar chart over here now
the next step is select the prime tv
shows data which is in the rows
now the same thing is in the
measures as well so keep in mind that
you need to select the prime tv shows
from the measures
let's right click on that and you can
see a create option and inside that
select the calculated field option
now let's rename this
and remember to add a negative symbol
now i'll tell you why we are going to
add the negative symbol
as we progress into the waterfall chart
we convert this particular bar chart
into a gantt chart as a step of the
process so in that particular stage we
might have to make some space between
the bars so that's the reason we have
selected negative of count over here
you'll see that happening in the next
steps
now you can see we have a new measure
which is the negative of count now let's
drag and drop that on to our size option
in the max card
so you can see i've selected the
negative of count which is in this
particular case the complete uppercase
is for the first waterfall chart what we
made
so we have our chart over here
now let's get back to our rows
click on this option
now we have our quick table calculation
option and that will be selecting the
running total
now we are almost done just one step is
remaining to convert this particular
chart into a gantt chart so there you go
we have our waterfall chart over here
now the next one in the list is
the heat maps so you can see how a
typical heat map in real time looks like
so a tabular heat map is used to display
the data along with colors
we can create a heat map using one or
more dimension member and measure value
now let's get back to tableau and try to
create a heat map let's create a new
sheet
rename it as heat map
to
enter
and there we have our heat map now let's
drag in some data to create a heat map
so for that let's select jenna from
dimensions
and drop it down to
no no we're not going to drop it so
we'll be selecting both the data set
once so the jenner one
now let's hold the control button and
select the number of seasons from
measures
now we will go to show me option and you
can see that we have various options
over here so this particular icon is for
heat maps now let's select that
now we have the heat map
now let's drag the imdb rating
from the measures
into
size
and this one imdb ratings into size so
that we have the different sizes for the
boxes over here so the biggest one here
and this next leading one over here now
the problem is we have the same color
for all the boxes
now for that
let's try to
drag
the jenner into color
so that we have different color for
different channel
so that's how the heat maps are done now
the next chart in the list is
the gantt chart
so a gantt chart looks something like
this
now what exactly is a gantt chart gantt
chart shows the progress of the value of
a task or resource over a period it is
used in project management and other
types of variation study over a period
now to create a gantt chart we will be
using the second data set
which is the w superstar data set
so i have already created a gantt chart
over here this is how a sample get chart
looks so we have discussed that a gantt
chart is used to study the variation in
the standards for over a period of time
so here we are selecting the first class
same day second class standard class
deliveries over a period of time so
we have the dates over here or we can
say that the period of time has been
selected in the form of dates or day
now let's recreate a grant chat and see
how it's practically done so for that
let's create a new sheet
g
now we'll follow this in a step-by-step
way
first
let's drag the order date into columns
now
let's select this or right click it
and change the order to day
now we have the days from 1 to 30 in a
month
now let's move on to the menu bar and
let's select the analysis button
and in that let's select create
calculated field
now we have our calculation tab over
here
now let's type in the calculation
now we are going to use this particular
gantt chart to study the shipment
now once the creation of gantt chart is
done we will study how the shipment is
done
based on
what kind of class is selected for
shipment as the days passed
now inside the calculated field we'll
write the formula
date difference so this this is the one
and inside that will be going to select
the day
next order date
next
ship date
so these particular order date and ship
date are from dimensions so just when we
typed them we had them readily available
now our formula is ready let's just
select ok
now in the measures segment you can see
we have a new input or new edition which
is the ship the formula what we just
created now we are going to select this
and drag this onto the marks card and on
the marks card we are going to drop it
on the size
now our gantt chart is almost ready the
only thing remaining is to drag the ship
mode to rows so that we can have the
details of that particular shipment mode
the standard one the first class one
etcetera etcetera
so for that let's drag in the ship mode
from
the dimensions
to
rows so there you go we have a shipment
mode
now the next type of chart that we will
be dealing with today is the pie chart
so pie chart represents data as slices
of a circle with different sizes and
colors the slices are labeled volume and
the volumes are represented in the form
of a chart
now let's continue with the pie chart so
to create a pie chart let's select the
language option from dimensions and hold
control button and select the number of
brand tv shows
and you can see the show me icon over
here let's select that and inside that
you can see a pi icon over here so just
select that and we have a pie chart over
here
now i can see that the pie chart what we
created looks a little bit smaller so
don't worry now let's just select the
standard option here from that
let's select the entire view
and there you go we have a little bit
more bigger pie chart if you're still
not convinced with the size you can just
go to the size option and try to
increase the size and there you go you
have the pie chart
now the next type of chart available in
our list is
the bubble chart
so the bubble chart looks something like
this so bubble charts display data as a
cluster of circles each value in the
dimension field represents a circle
whereas the values of measure represent
the size of those circles pretty simple
now let's get back to tableau and try to
execute a bubble chart
so this is how a standard bubble chart
looks like now let's create a new
sheet rename this as bubble
now let's select jenna's from dimensions
and
number of seasons from measures now the
journal will help us to know a
particular value and that particular
value will be a circle in the bubble
chart and the number of seasons will
provide the size of the bubble that
means the highest number of seasons for
a particular agenda will be having the
biggest circle now let's select the show
me and inside that you can see the
bubble chart let's just select that and
you can see we have different circles
and different sizes of different circles
now we have the same color for all the
circles to change that
let's drag jenna into color and now we
have different color for different
channel
now the next type of chart that we will
be dealing is
the histogram histogram is one of the
simplest charts available and also
easiest to create so histogram is a
chart that displays the shape of a
distribution
histogram looks like a bar chart but
groups values for a continuous measure
into ranges or pins now to understand
this better let's get back to tabling
and try to create a new chart
so we are back on w
let's rename this as histogram
let's just select enter
now let's select the imdb ratings
now we'll be using the mdb ratings
measure to create a histogram and will
be having the biggest bar for the
highest rating of imdb
now we have selected imdb rating just
hover over to show me tab and in that
you can see the histogram tab over here
let's just select that and we have the
histogram chart on our window
so there are many shows and each and
every show has specific number of imdb
ratings so a maximum number of shows are
having 7.2 as the imdb rating
now followed by histogram we have the
next type of chart
that is the highlight table so highlight
table is completely similar to the text
table that we have already dealt with
the only difference is we have various
colors for various data cells inside
that particular table
now interview highlight tables are used
to compare categorical data using color
and represented in the form of tables
that's what we discussed
now
let's get back to tableau and try to
create a highlight table
let's create a new sheet and rename it
as hd
so to continue with the highlight table
let's select jenna from dimensions and
hold control button and select the
number of seasons available
and when you hover over to show me you
can see a table called highlight tables
let's select that option and you can see
we have the highlight option over here
now you can see that we have different
colors for different number of
seasons available
in that particular channel
now you can see that they are not
ordered so let's just select the sort
option and
start from dissenting order
so there you go we have the highest
number of seasons available for drama
that is 339
now the next type of chart that we will
be dealing is
the line chart
so a typical line chart looks something
like this so the line charts connect
individual data points in a view they
provide a simple way to visualize a
sequence of values and are really useful
when you want to see trends
now let's get back to the tableau and
here we are going to use the
superstore dataset so that we can have a
look on the trends
now let's create a new sheet
and rename it as line 2.
now let's drag the profit into rows and
see if the profit is increasing day by
day or not
as you can see the w has automatically
selected the line chart for us and there
you go we can see that the profit is
increasing day by day or
year by year we can just you know kind
of
select the plus icon over here and see
we can have a quarterly update over here
so q1 q2 q4
of the year 2014 and 2015 2016 2017 the
q1 q2 q3 q4 so that's how we use the
line graph
now the next type of graph that we will
be dealing is
the bullet chart
so a normal bullet chart looks something
like this so a bullet graph is a bar
graph that replaces dashboard gauges and
meters it is used to compare performance
of a primary measure to one or more
measures
now let's get back to tableau and see
how a bullet chart is made now let's
create a new sheet
let's rename it as bullet
to
enter
now for a bullet chart we'll start with
the analysis button on the toolbar or
the menu bar
click analysis and now select
create calculated field option
now inside that let's try to you know
kind of set an average for profit
so
we can kind of estimate a profit over
here
so let's rename it profit
estimated
so basically we are going to use the
bullet chart to estimate the profit in
future
now inside that let's have an average
value
so average value of profit must be
something nearly
250 to 300 so just right into 75 000
just select okay
so this is the average what we are
expecting this must be the average
amount of profit that we should be
facing in the near future
now we have a new measure in the
measures section that is the profit
estimated now just select
that
and hold ctrl
and now we're going to select profit
now we are going to hover over the show
me option and there you go we have the
bullet graph option over here we're
going to select that so we have the
bullet chart over here so there you go
we have the bullet chart over here
we can kind of increase the
size of that
as well
so there you go that's how we use the
bullet shot in real time now the next
type of shot that we will be discussing
today is
the scatter plot
so scatter plot shows how points are
scattered in cartesian plane
it is created by plotting values of
numerical variables as x and y
coordinates in the cartesian plane
now let's get back to tableau and see
how scatter plot is used in real time
so we are back on tableau so a scatter
plot should be looking something like
this now let's try to recreate a new
scatter plot sheet
let's rename it as scatter plot two
now to create a scatter plot let's try
to drag the janna from dimensions into
columns
and the sum of seasons from measures
now we have the bar chart by default now
let's just select the marks card and
inside that let's select the shape
option now we have the data scattered
across the different points in the
cartesian plane
now just select
the jenna and drag it into color so we
have different colors for different
genres
so this is how the scatter plot looks
like
now let's continue with the next type of
chart
that is the area chart so an area chart
is a line chart where the area between
the line and the axis is shaded with a
color
now let's get back to tableau and see
how exactly an area chart looks like
so an area chart looks something like
this so let's try to recreate area chart
once again
new sheet a2
now we're going to see how the sales are
happening according to a particular area
for that let's select order date
and hold control
and select quantity so that we can have
a sheet which shows us the sales
happening in quantity on particular
dates
now we have the show me tab and we have
the area chart option over here let's
just select that and we have the area
chart over here now you can see that we
have one single color for all the sales
and quantity now
to have the
details of the
regions like in what region what kind of
sales are happening in what quantity we
want to select the region and
drag that over color so we have four
different colors for four different
regions the central east south and west
so this is how we use the area chart
now followed by area chart
now the next type of chart that we will
be dealing is the dual access chart
so what exactly is a dual access chart
so a typical dual access chart looks
something like this so dual access are
two independent access that are layered
on top of each other according to w dual
access allow you to compare multiple
measures now let's get back to w and try
to create a typical dual axis chart
so a typical dual access chart looks
something like this now let's try to
recreate this one create a new sheet
d2
now the dual access chart is really
simple to create let's select order date
from
dimensions
hold the control key
now you want to select the quantity from
measures
now again hold the control key
and you also have to select the sales
option so we have selected the order
date quantity and sales
now we are going to select the dual axis
chart from show me so we have the dual
axis chart on my screen right now so
what we are going to learn from this is
we are going to learn
the quantity of sales happening
according to the years so we in the year
2014 we have the quantity of sales which
is something around
uh 7.5 k and it has grown
gradually from 2015 16 and 17 and
reached above 12k
so this is what we get to know from dual
axis chart so the number of sales
happening
and the quantity of sales happening so
the line shows us the number of sales
and the bar shows us the quantity of
sales
now with this let's continue with the
next type of chart in our list
so the next type of chart that we will
be dealing is the symbol map
so the symbol maps are simply maps that
have a mark displayed over a given
longitude and a latitude so now we are
back on tableau now let's try to execute
the
symbol map so simple map looks something
like this
so we have the number of sales happening
in a particular
country and particular city now to
create a simple map let's select city
hold control country and again hold
control and select sales
now you can see that we have two
different maps over here the first one
is symbol map and the second one is maps
now let's select the symbol map and
there you go we have the symbol map over
here now we have the same color for all
these sales
now let's kind of select sales and drag
it to color so we have different colors
for different amount of sales happening
so the darkest one shows the highest
number of sales and a lighter one shows
the least number of sales so that's how
we use simple maps in real time let's
get back to the presentation again
now the next type of chart that we will
be dealing with today is the map chart
so a map view is one data point created
since the geographic role is assigned to
a country tableau creates the map view
as shown in the image here
so similar to the symbol maps we can use
the maps which shows the amount of sales
or profits or anything happening in that
particular country or city now let's get
back to tableau and try to create a
map
now a sample map looks something like
this
now let's try to create a new map
m2
now to create a map
let's select country
and hold control
and now let's select kind of profit
yeah so let's select the map icon here
and so now we have different colors for
different profits so this particular
state or country says that we have a
profit of 286
397 numbers or it might be even dollars
or something
we can also select the country and hold
ctrl and
select sales
and now we can also select maps again
so this is how the map chat looks like
now let's get back to the presentation
and the next type of chart that we will
be dealing with today is the tree map
chart
so what exactly is a tree map chart
so the tree maps are used to display
data in nested rectangles you use
dimensions to define the structure of
the tree map and measures to define the
size or color of the rectangles now
let's get back to tableau and try to
create a tree map
so you can see that we already have a
tree map and now we are back onto the
prime tv dataset
so
we have used the
janna and we've used the
sum of imdb ratings to create the dream
up over here now let's create a new
sheet and try to recreate the tree map
so that we can understand how to create
a tree map in real time let's rename it
tree map
so the tree map has been recreated now
just select
the jenna
and from that hold the control key
and select the imdb ratings
and now hold the control key again and
select the number of seasons available
and now when you hover over to the
xiaomi tab you can see the tree maps
icon over here let's just select that so
there you go you can see the tree map on
the screen right now and we have
different colors for different genres so
the darkest color for the drama has the
number of
or the highest number of imdb ratings
and the highest number of seasons
available and similarly so on now the
least one is the comedy as entertainment
culture with the least imdb rating of
6.2 and only the number of seasons
available are one
so this was the last type of chat that
we had to deal with today in this
particular table you chats tutorial
today we will be building dashboards
from start to finish first about world
population then health next we'll build
a dashboard about economy and finally
we'll build a dashboard about business
ease i would recommend getting access to
the data set before you start this
tutorial so you can build along with me
if you would like access to this data
set please comment below and we'll get
you access
so first we're going to build a
dashboard that revolves around
population so we're going to build
a map based on country so i'm going to
double click on country and it's going
to map out all the countries and then on
our marks i'm going to change it to map
so it's a filled in map and we want this
to be colored by population total
and we can see
who contributes the most to population
we're going to label it with population
as well
but you can see that it's labeling it
the total population and what we want to
label it is
how much it contributes to population by
percentage so let's add a table
calculation and we're going to have it
do percent of total
based on country
okay so now we can see which countries
contribute what percent
let's also bring the country name onto
the label
and
let's put it on top so country names on
top now it's getting a little bit of
crowded in here so
we're going to un click show marks label
and we're just going to show the ones
that
we want to see specifically so we can
right click on china here hover on mark
label and click always show
and on india
since these are our two biggest
contributors
we can see that this one's a little bit
darker than the others in that area
and here
here
and that's just a manual way to choose
which ones have indicators and labels
and which ones do not
and we're going to put a note here so
we're going to annotate
an area
that explains that
china and india
contribute the most to world population
just calling out
this section of the visualization
and let's name this sheet
so here we have our visualization and
when you hover you can see both the
total population and its percent
contribution and the country name
our next visualization for this
dashboard is going to be
population over time
so
[Music]
let's bring on our time element but one
trick for bringing on a time element if
we just drag it on so year with the
calendar mark here if we just drag it on
it'll default
to
a discrete version so let's take it back
off
and then we could edit it there but one
thing you could do is if you on
a windows machine you right click on it
and drag it on then it will pop up
with the dialog box that allows you to
select what kind of
date value you want to use in the first
place so we're going to use year here
and now we have instead of discrete we
have a continuous axis
and we're going to bring on
population total
and we can see that over time
one thing you can do when the value is
up so high
in your axis is you can uncheck this box
that says include zero and it will not
always include zero in your axis but
this can be misleading so you can see
that it looks like population growth is
something really dramatic by increasing
that slope of the line
whereas it really wasn't quite as
dramatic as it seems so as long as it's
communicated
well and you're not doing it to
mislead your users
you just need to keep in mind that this
includes zero can change what your graph
is saying so we're going to
not include the zero at this time
just so that we can focus in on our data
a little bit
now we're going to add our forecast so
we're gonna click on forecast and drag
it on
and it adds the forecast to our
visualization right there
and now we can right click here
and see forecast result is
actual and forecast
so you can see that the forecast picks
up here in 2012 and pushes out what it
thinks it'll be in 2013 as well you can
change how far out that forecast goes by
right clicking on the line and clicking
forecast option
and we can change this is automatically
the next two years but we could change
it so that it's the next 10 years and it
will go out into the future
out to 2022.
you can change prediction intervals or
if you don't want to show them you don't
have to show them and this is just kind
of
a visual guide for those prediction
intervals
okay and then you can also
have your trend lines show
where it shows your trend line following
out from where your population growth is
and also the trend line for your
forecast right there
and we'll call this
world population
trend
excellent and we're going to make one
more visualization for this and it's
going to be a pie chart so the pie chart
is also going to be based off of
population
so we're going to click on population
and we're going to control click on
country and come over to show me
and click your pie chart
great so i'm going to make this
the entire view so we can see the pie
chart better
and this is getting really crazy in here
and so i have changed my mind and
instead of country i'm going to drag
region over top of country and now we
see something a little bit more
manageable so we can see that here's
asia
and it makes up
the biggest piece of the pie and then
here is everybody else so right now
each of these is population total
and we could keep it that way or we
could
do what we did last time
and change it to percent of total
so that on hover we can see
the population and
the percentage of population that it
contributes
so for this pie chart we're just going
to
show asia versus everybody else so we
need to make a group and what we'll do
is
select all of these
and we're going to right click and click
group
so now we have
all those things we selected and we have
other let's edit our group right click
edit group
we're going to
rename this group
asia because
that's all that's in there and we're
going to rename this group
the rest of the world
okay
so now we have our group we can drag it
onto label
and we can see asia and rest of the
world and now see how it's breaking it
up into those different sections that's
because we still have region on
our
detail right here so we pull region off
now it's just split asia rest of the
world
we can change our colors
make it a little bit more
visually interesting
now we can still see our percentages
and now let's rename it and then we'll
put it all together on a
dashboard great
so let's make our dashboard we have this
new dashboard button down here and you
can choose what sizes you want so we
have a fixed size where you just select
the width and height we have
automatic which will just fill your
screen
and
we have a range which has a minimum size
and a maximum size
some of the
good things about fixed is that once you
have it you can have it always look that
way so no matter where they're looking
at it you know that it's going to be
laid out the way that you expected
however if somebody's looking out on a
screen that is bigger or smaller than
yours then it doesn't fill up the screen
or it will fill the screen too much and
they'll have to scroll up and down and
left and right
if you have automatic then it will fit
the screen that it's displayed on
however the things that you've placed
might get squished too close together
and then the range gives you a minimum
size and a maximum size meaning if the
screen is too big
it still won't fill up the screen but it
can get closer and then as they get
smaller and smaller screens
you at least know that it will never
make it get smaller than this particular
size so there's some benefits to that as
well where you still have a little bit
of control of what it will look like in
the end
great let's bring on our worksheets
and you can see that where you hover
it fills up that space
and that's where it's going to show up
you can also adjust the lines in between
different visualizations for things that
need more space or less space
another important thing to recognize is
that when you click on a visualization
like this one up here it will tell you
how it's viewing that visualization
within that space so if you click
standard then it will do a standard fit
versus if you have entire view where it
will
make it fit into inside the box over
here we could have fit width
fit height
on some of the visualizations it doesn't
make as much of a difference however
when you have a visualization that maybe
has a lot of text in it and they need to
be able to scroll you'll want to have it
fit width but you don't want it to fit
height
because then it will shove all of that
information
into the box and not allow you to scroll
up and down
so as you saw as we dragged these on it
took
these
legends and added it to the left here
we can modify that
and make them floating
and drag them next to the visualizations
that they
are relevant to
and
this particular one
has a couple of things wrong with it we
might not want the title of this to be
region group
so we could come in and we could edit
the title and then
maybe just call it region
however i don't think we need this
legend at all because it's very clearly
marked on the visualization there so you
could also just remove it from the
dashboard
and this one
is telling you how big of a circle
it would need to be before it gets to
that population number so
it belongs to this circle as well but
again
is unnecessary potentially because we
have our two population numbers
showing up right as we hover
so we remove that as well so at this
point we have a visualization or three
visualizations all on the same page
which is the basics of a dashboard
however we might want to be able to
interact with them a little bit more
than just hovering
and so this is where we should look into
adding filters so we have information
over time we have information by country
and we have some information by region
here
one of the quickest things you can do to
add functionality to the dashboard is by
clicking this uses filter button so if
we click this that means whatever
country we click on here
will filter the other visualization
and then you can unselect it
to go back
now
that
uses filter button
actually creates an action here
filter one generated that it's made on
its own now you can see that when we
click on china
it doesn't make a lot of sense to have
this pie chart update based on that
china click because it's just going to
show
duplicated information so it shows the
20
or the 20 here and the 17
billion
and then here it does the same thing
except for it shows 100 because it's
filtered everything else out of the
chart so it now makes up 100 of the
circle so that doesn't make a lot of
sense
so there are ways to
format your visualization or your
actions
modify your actions so that they only
affect the things that make sense so we
can come here and click edit we're going
to call this country
action
and we want it to
use the population by country sheet and
then modify
only the trend
so now when we click on
china we see china's trend over time and
it doesn't affect our pi
because that doesn't make sense for it
to affect our pie
we might want to select on our pie
asia or rest of the world and have that
affect the other visualization so we can
click use this filter here and click
asia
and now it zooms into asia on our map
and shows us just the asia world
population trend and here's rest of the
world and we can see that asia is grayed
out
and there's the rest of the world and
here's the rest of the world population
trend
we might also want to be able to use
this to filter to a certain year
so if we click use filter
then we click on
2011
you can see these numbers are slightly
updating so this is 19
and we come here 19.5 percent
come down here and we can see that the
pi updates a little bit
although it hasn't been anything
dramatic
you can kind of see it over time
so that's one way
to add filters to your visualization
another way
is to use actual filtering instead of
just actions so if we come back here to
our trend
we could take the year we're going to
control click and drag it onto filters
and now we have a year filter so we
could have it the actual year number so
just look at one year at a time
or a range of dates
so if we click range of dates that makes
this slider
from 2000 to 2012. so if we hit ok
we'll right click and we'll click show
filter we can see it here and as we drag
this
it updates
but kind of messes with our forecast
so let's not do a year filter
in this case
so we click remove filter there
but maybe we want a filter just on this
for the different years
so let's drag year on to the filters
we're just going to do the year number
next and here's all the years we're
gonna let all of them be selected for
now
and then we're going to show the filter
and here's all of our years
and we can change the way that our quick
filter shows up
and we can make it like a drop down so
they can still select multiples but it's
a drop down or maybe we want this
visualization to be just one year at a
time so we can choose single value in a
list and it lists out all the years or
in a drop down
and we want it to be 2012
and
then we want this to show up on our
dashboard so we come to the dashboard
and we click more options here hover
over filters and we can see the filters
available and we can click year of year
and now our formatting hasn't passed on
so that's one thing to remember that
formatting it just on the workbook
doesn't necessarily mean that the
formatting will pass over to the
dashboard so i tend to not do any
formatting on the workbooks and just
format it on the dashboards because the
dashboards are what i publish
so we're in a single value drop down
we're going to
add it we're going to move it to the top
so now how we do that
let's talk a little bit about what each
of these sections are
come here to layout
and you can see we have this layout here
item hierarchy so tiled is the whole
screen and inside of that we have a
horizontal
[Music]
container
and inside this horizontal container
we have another horizontal container and
when you click on something in this view
it shows you where it exists
so we can see this horizontal container
is outlined now and then we change it to
vertical and it outlines this now a
horizontal container allows things to be
side by side
and a vertical container allows things
to be a one on top of the other and so
in our vertical container we see all
this extra space for extra things to be
on top of each other but if we wanted to
have it at the top
we would maybe want things to be able to
be side by side so if we go back to the
dashboard and we grab horizontal and
drag it to the top
it adds a horizontal container up here
and now you can see everything that's
floating kind of stays in the place that
it was
even though all the other things shifted
so that's one of the disadvantages of
floating is that you're kind of just
manually choosing
where it will stand
using your x and y position
and it's not dynamic
so let's give us a little bit less space
up here
we can add a text box into
our horizontal container and we will say
population dashboard
[Music]
we can format it
now we have our title up here and then
we can add our filter
we're going to drag it to be on
inside of our horizontal container but
on the
side here
you can give it more or less space
let's bring
our legends down to places where they
make sense again
perfect
and so now
we have this that will affect this
only and show you just 2012
2011 2010. so we don't want it to affect
the trend because we want the trend to
show
all of time and just looking at one year
for this trend that is only at a yearly
part and forecasts into the future
doesn't make any sense but we maybe
wanted to also affect this worksheet so
that these two are in sync
and so the dashboard is basically for
2012 except for the trend which shows
you the past in the future so one way
that you can do that is clicking apply
to worksheets here
and you can choose selected worksheets
and it will show you all the worksheets
in this visualization or in this
dashboard and you can click show all
worksheets in workbook and then if there
were other worksheets that we showed
them
so we wanted to do asia versus rest of
the world and population contribution by
country
okay and that's another way we can
change what year they show so it's only
going to show one year at a time
unless we select all
and then this visualization isn't
affected by it
if we don't want
to click on a country and have it
make the change if we instead want to
have a filter for country we can do that
by taking country and dragging it onto
filters
we'll have it show all for now and then
when we go back to our dashboard and we
come to this visualization we can go
filters and add country
and it's just added it side by side
where we had our other filter so that's
a nice
feature of tableau where it can kind of
guess where you might want things we're
going to do multiple value drop down
and right now
it only affects that visualization and
we can just look at one country at a
time
and we might not want it to affect this
visualization because it doesn't do us
any good to just look at one region in a
pie chart
but maybe we wanted to affect the world
population trend so we can do the same
thing we did before
and we wanted to affect these two
we'll click ok
and so now
we could look at
all these countries
and that would update both these
visualizations
another thing i like to do
on a filter
is customize and click show apply button
and this means we can make all these
changes in here
see i've selected none however these
visualizations aren't updating and then
i wanted to look at turkey so i found
turkey and then i hit apply and that's
when they update
perfect so now we have a dashboard
complete with filters and
actions
we also have a title on our dashboard we
can give it a little bit less space and
some legends
we have titles on each of these pieces
however if we didn't want a title here
we can click hide title and it will just
show our visualization there
and this is dashboard number one
here's what it looks like in full screen
mode full screen mode is a good
opportunity for you to test it to see
what it will look like to the end user i
press escape and get back out
and it doesn't give you these highlights
when you hover over things that are
dashboard formatting related
you can see that all those extra lines
went away
and it just gives you the opportunity to
test out your dashboard in a more real
way
and see how they will use it
instead of giving you the dashboard
editing options
next we're going to make a dashboard
revolving around health information
so first we're going to make
a map
about birth rates so we're going to call
it
birth rate
rank
and to make a map we're going to double
click on country
and
we're going to change it to a map type
so we have a filled map here and then
we're going to bring birth rate on to
color
so let's define our colors a little bit
by clicking on this color part of the
marks card we'll click edit colors and
we're going to change it
to
red and gold
and the idea here is that the red is for
a higher birth rate which is
more associated with countries that have
poor health so we'll hit apply
and now we have our
higher birth rate countries highlighted
in red next we're going to create
a class so we're going to duplicate
birth rate
and let's edit that field
we're going to call it birth rate class
and so we're going to say that anything
that is in the top 50 countries
with the highest birth rate is
categorized as having
an alarming birth rate so we will
first do the average
birth rate
and then we're going to
do a rank
on that
do you see sometimes
when you're auto completing your
statements
it will replace
one of these functions that you have
with the one that you pressed tab for so
if i type if or i start to type if and
then i come here and click on if it
replaced my rank with if so keep an eye
out for that if you're like where did my
thing go it's because i was typing it
right next to it so if i put a space and
then i start to type if and i click if
it will not delete rank so we're going
to say if
the rank of average is
less than or equal to
50 so if it's in the top 50
then
alarming
birth rate
else if
and we could take this again
is greater than 50. then
normal over 3.
always make sure you put on the end also
we didn't necessarily have to have this
else if statement
so if we had just done else normal birth
rate that would have covered all of our
bases
so with these if statements just make
sure that you're always getting all the
different options
that you want but in this case
we defined both however we didn't have
to define the second calculation because
if it is not
in the top 50 then it's obviously in the
bottom the rest
so we're going to hit ok
and then we're going to put birth rate
class onto label and it's gone around
and labeled everything
and i am seeing alarming birth rate on
everything
so let's see what the problem is
so if we open this back up by right
clicking and clicking edit you can see
it says results are computed a long
table across
so we're going to click default table
calculation here and instead of compute
using automatic we're going to change it
to compute using
country we'll hit ok and hit apply
and that didn't seem to fix it so this
is the first place i would look if it's
not doing what you would expect
so
we'll put it back to automatic okay
the second place i would look is inside
of the table calculation that is created
so when we defined rank here we put a
table calculation on it so when we right
click here we get edit table calculation
and we're going to choose that we want
to do the rate based on
the specific dimension of country
so now we can see
using the logic
the calculation assistance that
we no longer have just alarming birth
rate we have normal birth rate and
alarming birth rate on our screen so we
can close this
and we are done here one thing you could
do
is
when we have allow labels to overlap
other marks selected then it will make
sure that
every label shows up but it gets super
crazy in there so there are some times
where the labels may overlap a little
bit and so you'll want to select this
option in our case we don't want that
and now we have a visualization
showing
birth rate map
based on rank our next visualization
is going to be about
average life expectancy
male versus female
so we're going to do
a chart across time so we're going to
click year and bring it on to columns
and we're going to change it to this
year
in the continuous section so now we have
an axis
and
we're going to
double click on female life expectancy
up there we go double click on female
expectancy and then double click on male
life expectancy so what that did was
made us two charts one on top of the
other but we don't want that so we'll
take this off and we're going to drag
male life expectancy right onto this
axis for the female life expectancy
and what this has done is made what's
called a blended axis chart so it's not
a dual axis chart where we have another
axis over here
for the second visualization this one is
a blended access chart so they
necessarily use the same axis and they
necessarily have the same kinds of marks
so we'll take a look and see what the
difference is there so if i were to
change this to a bar chart we would have
a bar chart for both of them and i can't
define one separately from the other
change it back to a line chart
and they're both a line chart
now if we go back to
when we just had female life expectancy
and we drag
male on next to it and we have two
charts
now we can change it to a dual axis and
we have one on top of the other however
our axes don't line up we can see at the
top here is 15k and over here it's 14k
so we're going to synchronize the axis
and you can see
one on top of the other
and
we have two marks cards so we could have
this one be a bar chart and that would
be a line chart
so that's some of the differences of
those two we're going to do a blended
access chart so i'm going to take male
and drag it here
and we have our blended access chart and
now you can see the our scale here is
really strange so what it's doing is
it's adding up all of the life
expectancies for all the different
countries instead of averaging it so
we're going to change that by right
clicking on the measure down in this
measure values card hovering over
measure sum and we're going to change it
to average
since i only changed one of them and
they share the same axes it's really
spread out now and it almost looks like
a straight line down there and then
let's change the other
and it should get everything a little
bit more
in sync there we go so now we can see
the average life expectancy over time
which for both of them seems to be going
up
however
it seems to be higher
for females
now let's take a look at our analytics
and let's
drag on forecast
so it's forecasted out the next two
years for both line
and we'll bring on trend
onto linear
and let's change it
to a square so now we see
each individual point for the life
expectancy for females and males and we
can see what they're expected to be in
the future
and our trends
and our next visualization
is going to be a heat map
about
multiple different
measures so we'll just call it a heat
map for now
and for our heat map we're going to look
at the different countries so we'll
bring country onto rows and we're going
to look at
their birth rate
so i just double clicked on birth rate
and brought it on
we're going to look at
their health expenditure percentage on
gdp so how much they spend on
gdp so when i double clicked on it it
did what we did before where we have a
measures value card and so now whenever
we put measures on here that determines
what goes here because we have our
measure names on columns so every
measure in here their name is going to
define the name of the column and the
values
define
what's in the text right here
great we're also going to bring on
infant mortality rate
and
the life expectancy for females
okay
so now it has
changed these to not have decimal points
after them which is not as helpful so
we're going to format those
and you can format it field by field so
for birth rate
we definitely want to have
decimals afterwards as a matter of fact
the birth rate is a percentage so
instead of doing a number standard we'll
just go to percentage
and now we don't need to have those
decimals afterwards we can just look at
the birth rate as a rate
and
4
percent of gdp for health expenditures
we can come click there and do the same
thing
and for infant mortality rate
okay
and to make this make a little bit more
sense we again need to change it from a
sum
to an average
and for some of these
we could
change it from a sum to an average right
inside of
the
for all of these we could change it from
a sum to an average in the default
properties under aggregation
so it will automatically average it
whenever we bring it out
default is sum
but if we make it automatically average
then we won't have to do that again for
any other visualizations
i won't do that at this time because i
get a little bit confused sometimes when
i don't have my sum on there
by default because that's what i'm so
used to seeing by default great so we
now have
a matrix
by country and by our different metrics
here and so we can
take our measure values
and drag it onto
color and we'll make our marks from
automatic to square
and it will make our heat map
now what happens with a heat map
is it colors darkly
the higher the number it is in this case
and
right now it's doing it for the whole
area so one percent is obviously much
much smaller than 82 but if we wanted to
be able to look at birth rate
independently from life expectancy we
can right click on the measure values on
the color and click use separate legends
and so now we have a legend
for each one of these let's change the
colors on those legends so that we can
see them separately a little bit more
clearly
so we'll change the colors by coming
over here to each of the legends
and we'll leave one the same
but we'll change this one
and if we click edit colors you can see
our different palettes
you can see some of them just have one
color others have one color to another
color we used the
red gold before
so now you can see that one is changed
we could use
another one that goes from
green to blue
you can also define your own
so you can make a custom one that could
go from
light to dark and then you can choose
what color you want as your dark color
so we could pick
a lighter blue
and then we see that last one
and now with these separate color
palettes you can quickly see the
difference with birth rate and
spending on health
and that is our heat map
with
separate legends
so let's build this all into a dashboard
now
we're going to call it our health
dashboard
and for simplicity we're going to make
it automatic so it fills our screen
and then we're going to first bring on
our map
we're going to bring on our health
related map with birth rates
then we're going to bring on our
heat map
and we'll bring on our life expectancy
lines
now as we brought on all of our charts
it brought in our legends here
and we're going to move our legends up
to the top so let's add a horizontal
container
and then let's put
our legends
into the horizontal container
and let's put these ones in order so
life expectancy
oh so birth rate is going to be over
here
great now
one thing we can do is make these
smaller
well that's actually just making that
one bigger huh okay
so it would make them smaller
by making something else bigger or by
adding in a blank space
which would then
help you adjust the size
by taking up the space that you're not
using
another thing to pay attention to is
this fixed width so once you start to
drag the size on something it no longer
is dynamic
so if we unfix that width
so that it's only taking up whatever
space is left oh and that one's not
fixed with
and then we can edit the width on this
to be
even bigger
then it will squish things over to where
we would like them to be so
that's one of the ways you can add space
or make things the size you would like
them to be
now let's take a look at filters oh
before we take a look at filters i want
to look at this map one more time
because i think that it would be useful
for our colors to be
a little bit more
distinct
so
one quick way to navigate to your
worksheet from your dashboard is to
click this go to sheet button
and while we're here i'm going to click
on color
edit colors and we did red and gold and
we're going to change it from
this sequence to a stepped color
and we're going to change it to three
colors so it's going to either be
this color this color this color i want
i hit ok
you can kind of see it's a little bit
more dramatic
in our differences and it's put
everything into the three categories we
defined so let's go back to our
dashboard
and we can see the difference there
and now we're going to take a look at
our filters so we want to be able to
filter by country
so let's bring country onto filters
now we're going to allow it to use all
and we're going to
here you can click apply to worksheets
and you can click selected worksheets
and it's going to pop up with all the
worksheets
in the whole workbook
and so one disadvantage of doing it on
the worksheet is that you can see all of
the worksheets in the workbook and you
have to differentiate between which ones
are on the dashboard which ones aren't
and these are the three on this
dashboard so we're going to hit ok
and we're also going to do it by year so
when we drag the year onto filters
we're going to
[Music]
allow them to
choose years so we're going to
do the distinct number of years we'll
click use all
okay
and we're going to apply to the
worksheets
this one with the birth rate and the
average life expectancy male versus
female we're not going to filter down
our line chart by year
because we want to be able to see it
over time and if we filter down the time
then we don't get as much context so
we'll hit ok
let's go back to our dashboard
if i click on more options here and
hover over filters you can see that year
filter and that country filter
you should also be able to see both of
those filters on the heat map
because i told it to apply to that one
as well so here's the country oh
i made a mistake let's go back to this
visualization
and
apply to worksheets selected worksheets
see i wanted it to be on the birth rate
and the heat map not the line chart and
i clicked the wrong one
so that was a good test
so when we go here to the heat map
and click down
you can see now
we get the year of year as well so we'll
click year of year let's put it over
here
and we're going to make it
a multiple values drop down and we'll
bring it over to the middle
and let's also
get the countries filter
great so now that we have these in here
we don't need this to be so big so let's
edit the width
and make it
300
even smaller
200
great and let's change our country
to be
a single value drop down so you can pick
one at a time and let's also change it
or this year of year since we can select
multiples let's change it so that
on customize that you show the apply
button
so here since they can only select one
don't have the apply button because it
will just automatically apply
and here since they can select multiples
we'll let them unselect all and pick
their years
and then hit apply and then you'll see
the changes
and you can see that even though i've
selected only 2011 and 2012 you still
see all the years on this line chart as
expected
and there
is our health dashboard
our next dashboard is going to have to
do with economy
our first sheet is going to be
another map that is going to have to do
with
overall gdp
and
as we usually begin with maps by double
clicking on country
and changing it to a map mark type
and this time we're going to bring on
gdp onto color
and change it to average
and we can edit the colors
let's this time do
a custom diverging so you get to pick
both colors
and let's pick
a little bit lighter
hmm
okay
red for there and then we want to do
maybe like a deeper
green
and that way
you can see
who has the highest gdp which is green
we hit apply
okay
and then it will
eventually get lighter and lighter until
it goes to gray which then it will lead
to green
okay
and next we're going to make
scatter plot
which we will call
gdp versus gdp per capita
so
gdp or gross domestic product versus
gross domestic product per capita or per
person
and to make a scatter plot
you have one
measure on one axis
and then another measure which is going
to be
gdp per capita which we will now create
on the other axis
so let's start with gdp and we'll hit
duplicate
and let's edit that
and we're going to call it
gdp
per capita
and we're going to take
some
of gdp
and divided by the sum
of the total
population
population total
what is my error
opening parenthesis
there we go
and then we have gdp per capita so let's
what this will do is sum up the gdp
across whatever measures we have in
place go across whatever dimensions we
have in place and then sum up the
population for those same dimensions and
then divide it instead of dividing it
per row and then
doing an aggregation on it
okay
so now we're going to bring on gdp per
capita on the rows
and we have the sum of gdp and the gdp
per capita and to make it more than just
one
little mark on our scatter plot we will
drag on country to detail and now we
have one mark per country
and you can see some countries have
a high gdp per capita
and some countries have a high gdp
overall but not as high of a gdp per
capita
and so on we have some middle of the
road people here so we can change this
from automatic
to circles and now they're dots like you
might see on scatter plot
and
you can
drag region
onto
color
and now we can see our different regions
and see we see a lot of reds here and
it's quick to see
what region things belong in also you
can click to highlight and you can see
all of the americas highlighted in
context
the next visualization we're going to
make
is going to be
showing
how much country spend on health care
as a part of their gdp so
we're going to rename it
to be gdp on healthcare
and we're going to look at each of our
countries
and we're going to make a bar chart
that shows
the health expense gdp
and we're going to change this to
average
and we're also going to show
the health expense per capita
over here it shows how much is spent per
person on health
and this
is showing how much
is spent on health
based on gdp
click at the top and click sort and it's
sorting by this first one
and you can see which countries spend
the most of their gdp on health
we can again bring region under color
so we can see the different
regions
highlighted
and
let's bring on labels so
for our different marks cards
we're going to want to control click
this
and drag it onto the labels
and we can see that it's a percentage
but it's coming up as a number so
we can right click and click
format right there
and
we're going to change the number to
percentage
maybe just do one decimal place
and then for this one
we're going to control
and drag
that onto labels
and maybe we'll change this one to
currency
however if you don't want to change it
to currency
since we aren't sure necessarily what
currency this data set is in um it's
worth checking out
what currency it is in
so for now we'll just have it as a
number
and now we're going to
customize our tool tip
so we're going to go to the overall
marks card
and we'll click on tool tip and we want
it to tell us the country in the top so
erase region
and we're going to
[Music]
erase country label and center country
and then we're going to
put
this country
spends
this percentage
on
healthcare
and if you want to preview it you can
hover or click here on preview and it
will show you an example marshall island
spends 2.1 on healthcare we'll hit enter
and then when we hover
it tells you the country and it has our
custom tooltip on both visualizations or
on both
of the different axes
so
let's build our dashboard
we'll bring on our map
we'll bring on our
healthcare
visualization
and our gdp versus gdp per capita
and we'll move our legends to the top
again by adding a horizontal container
to the top
and bringing them up here
one thing we can do also
is to give this more space
we can have it go all the way to the top
and these legends are just side by side
just above the map
and uh jbp per capita
scatter type plot
an interesting thing you can do in
tableau is you can see this outlier of
the united states is making it difficult
to see the rest of the information or to
visualize if there's any trend there so
you could right click on it and click
exclude
and then it will exclude it from your
data set very quickly
and then you'll just click this back
button to get it back
great now let's take a look at filters
we are going to do a single filter
so let's go to this visualization and
we'll bring on country
we'll click use all
okay
and we're going to apply it to
worksheets so i showed you how we can
apply it to worksheets here
you can also apply to worksheets once
it's on the dashboard so if we come here
and look at filters we can see the
countries on the filters for this
visualization but if we come down here
and look at filters
we still see country because it's in the
details of the information so
either way when we add country
since i added it from this visualization
it only affects this visualization
okay
but we want it to affect all on the
worksheet
so we're going to apply to worksheets
and we can click selected worksheets and
we can click all on dashboard
okay
let's bring this over here we're going
to allow them to see all at once and be
able to scroll and select the ones they
want and now
when we select different ones it affects
all three worksheets
we're also going to add an action
for a url action add action go to url
and when we click on a country on the
overall gdp map we want it to take us to
the wikipedia page that talks about the
economy for that country so that is
this url and it's going to say wikipedia
for economy of
and we're going to add our country to
the end
so we hit okay
we have it running on menu so let's
change it to run on select and as soon
as you click it it will take you there
okay so now let's try it
and we can click on canada
and it will take us to the wikipedia
page for the economy of canada
great we click on brazil
same thing
so if we unselect on brazil then it will
make our map highlighted normally again
we can also use this one to filter the
other visualizations
and so we could click use this filter
here and then when we click on france
it will filter these two other
visualizations to france
you can see that when we filter this
visualization
to a particular country
so if we look at
germany
germany wasn't green before on our map
but now it is that happens because our
scale has changed just for the ones
selected
so if we control click france and
germany and switzerland
and austria we now have a scale that
reflects only these countries and the
biggest is going to be the darkest green
or the highest gdp is the darkest green
and the lowest is the
lightest pink
and there is our economy dashboard you
can see that we have some nulls on these
visualizations that occurs when we don't
have all of the data
for every point
you can ignore those and they won't show
up on the final visualization when you
publish it to server or you can deal
with those by clicking on them and
filtering that data out or showing that
data at the default position which is
showing the null values at zero our
final dashboard is going to be about the
ease of doing business in a country so
our first visualization is going to be a
bar chart which we will call days to
start
business
so how many days it takes to start a
business is important to know when
you're trying to start a business in a
country and also can be an indicator of
how easy it will be to do business in
that country so
let's make a bar chart that includes
every country and then we're going to
bring on days to start a business
and we will sort it smallest to biggest
and we have some days
or some countries that don't have
any days so let's filter out those
countries
and we're going to
filter it to only those that have a good
market
we're going to make a calculated field
we're going to define business friendly
market
well
we're going to define our market based
on how easy it is to start a business
and how many days it takes so if it
takes less than 25 days to start a
business we'll consider that a good
market and so we're going to do
if
the days to start a business is less
than or equal to 25
then
elsif
space to start a business is
greater than
25 then
business
might or might not
work
doing less than or equal to 25 or
greater than 25
allows us to be able to define these two
different markets so we'll hit
apply there
and we're going to filter it
just to a good market
and we're going to look at
just one year
look at 2012
our most recent year
and we're going to color it based on
region
and we can see
which regions tend to have
the shorter days to start a business
and we're going to
move on and build our next visualization
which is also a bar chart
which we will call ease of business
so we have this ease of business field
and we can bring on the country and we
can bring on ease of business
and we want to
make it
a measure so ease of business is at this
point looking at it like it's
a string
and we can change that in our default
properties and convert it to a measure
or use it up here and change it to a
measure
when we try to change it to a measure
here it wants to treat it like a string
so it wants to take the minimum or the
maximum
but if we here convert it to a measure
then it also automatically made it a
count
so the first thing to do
would be to change the data type to a
number
and now
we can change it to a measure and
aggregate it so we could do
like the sum of ease of business
in our use case we're actually going to
do the
average of ease of business
and then we want to have the smallest on
the top we do have some that don't have
ease of business ratings
so we're going to filter that data out
and again we want the year to be 2012
but how we're going to do that is by
coming to this visualization
and by applying
this particular year
of 2012 so we'll do on select workbooks
and select ease of business okay
and now this one also has
the year of 2012 there
and
we're going to
segment
this by creating another header
we're going to call that
business friendly
and we're going to say
that if the ease of business
is
so i guess this is a nice thing to know
so if if we start typing in what we want
to see then we can select it from a list
here but you can also interact outside
of this box so you could just grab ease
of business and drag it into the dialog
box here and that's really nice so we're
going to say if it is greater than or
equal to 1
and less than or equal to
3
then we're going to say it has the most
business
friendly
regulations
give us a little more room to look at
okay and this statement won't work
because it's saying and what is less
than or equal to three so you have to
have ease of business in both places
and then this should say then and not
the
great so now we're just getting an error
because we don't have an end
so if that's all we wanted to do then
that's what we would do but then we'll
just do another else if
and it's already taken this
if statement goes through
one condition at a time so it's already
classified everything that's between
these two numbers and so
now we can just say
if ease of business
is
less than or equal to 10
then
we'll call it very
very business friendly regulations
now we'll keep going
else if ease of business is
less than or equal to 50
then
we're going to call it
moderate
and we're just going to say moderate
business
regulations
copy that for later use
less than equal to 150
then
strict
so
the reason that this doesn't grab
everything that is less than or equal to
150 is because
these sections one to three and then
three or well four to ten
and then eleven to fifty have all been
classified up to this point so it's just
getting everything else
and we're going to
finally
say else everything else
is going to be called
not preferred
for
business
and see if we get any errors calculation
is valid let's see if this works as we
expect so we'll hit apply
and we'll bring business friendly onto
our rows
and now it categorizes everything
based on what we said so
we want to define what order these go in
so we're going to click sort
and we want the
most business friendly at the top
then we want moderate then strict then
not preferred okay
so we have our top three that are the
most business friendly and then we've
got four through ten which are very then
we've got our moderate
are strict
and are
not preferred
so let's bring region again onto color
and we can see which regions are the
most business friendly
and we have our year of 2012 there and
now we're going to make this even more
useful by adding the business tax rate
onto the label
so that you can see that business
friendly
is like singapore but they have a pretty
high tax rate of 27
whereas if you get down to some of these
that are not preferred
some of them have really low tax rates
so let's make sure that we're getting
okay the right tax rate
so
you can see that
27 is definitely not the highest tax
rate that we have for business
but you can also see that there are
places that have
even lower tax rates
like saudi arabia
and
we have
eight percent here
it looks like we don't ever go to
that second decimal place so let's
quickly
format this
oh
business tax rate is also text
so if we could convert
our data type to
decimal
and then we will
format it
to be
a percentage
and we just need the one decimal place
okay
now let's make
some annotations so we could come and
click here on this mark
and then we can annotate that mark which
will make this dialog box and it's
already filled in here
and so we could
use some of this information
so i'm going to copy that
and i'll put some hard returns there
so we're going to say
that
this country
is the most
business friendly
but has a
business tax rate
of and let's grab the tax rate
and then we'll erase this
i will hit okay
and i've made a typo
so singapore is the most business friend
is not what i meant to say
so i can click edit
business friendly
but has a tax rate of and you can move
this around
draws the line to singapore which is the
mark
that we wanted to annotate so that is an
annotation on a mark if we wanted to
just make an annotation
for the area
then we could
point out that
more business friendly
countries
often have
high
business taxes
we can change that size make everything
fit
now we have this
second note
where our user can come in and see some
more information about what's being
presented here
great and now we're going to make one
more visualization
and it's going to be
about phone and internet usage
because you may want to know about the
phone and internet trends
when you're looking to start a business
so we're going to do this one over time
so it does not need to have that year
filter on it
and we're doing our continuous our axis
and we're going to
look at mobile phone usage so i double
clicked it shows mobile phone usage over
time
and we're going to change it to average
so that it's averaging it across the
countries
and then we're going to bring on
internet usage so we'll bring it on side
by side so we have two visualizations
and we're going to
also make that average
now we might not want these to share an
axis because they are measured a little
bit differently
and so we can make it a dual axis
but allow them to keep their independent
axes
or you can synchronize the axes
and see them at their
rates however
the uses is just a little bit
of a different measurement we can have
one of them be
a bar chart and the other one be a line
let's have this one be the bar chart
okay and then the line is in the front
you can also change which one's in the
front by
coming and clicking
on the axis itself
and you can click move marks to front
and then move that onto the front okay
and now it's made each of these wide and
there's like a star point and end point
on the axis for the bar and that comes
here under size
where they're all fixed
or you could have it be manual where we
can define the size of the bar so we're
gonna make those bars like this
now we can see them going up over time
we can also change the width of the line
itself
make it thicker or thinner
and
we can change the colors here
so let's change it to
orange
since red might apply that it's bad
in some cultures
and now we can see our internet usage
and our phone usage over time and how
it's trending
and so this will all come together on
our new dashboard
which is about
ease of business
you can see that i have a sheet called
these as a business and a dashboard that
i've called ease of business but it
won't let you
create a dashboard with the same name
as your worksheet so
ease of business dashboard
let's have it fit the screen
and
we're going to bring on our
days to start business visual
our ease of business visual
and our
phone and internet visual
let's
put our legends at the top again
so we'll make our horizontal
container
and we'll bring our region legend into
there and then our
measure names for internet versus
mobile phone
and we have a filter that already is
pre-applied to two of the visualizations
called year of year
and it's selected 2012 and if we select
2011
it's only changing this one it's
filtering out all the information for
this visualization and changing this one
to
2011.
so let's see why that's happening if we
go to this visualization
and click the go to sheet
we can see year of 2012 is here let's
click show filter
and if we change the filter
to 2011 okay it's not showing up here
and the only filter i can see that could
be removing it is this averages of
business
that is removing anything that is null
so if i pull that off you can see that
we don't seem to have any information
for 2011 for ease of business
and the more years i select
i'm not seeing any
ease of business information
so
we're going to want to set this to
2012 only because that seems to be the
only information that is useful for this
visualization
so
let's go back until we're back to the
state
we were in when we started
okay so here we are
now we're going to want to remove this
filter
and we're going to give it its own
filter
that only selects 2012
that is not connected to the other
filter
so now when we change your view it only
changes this visualization
sometimes that's useful to note
sometimes it's useful to put
let's do a single value
drop down sometimes it's useful to put
this
right next to the visualization it
affects
so if we could change it to floating and
just put it like
here
that makes it clear that
it's just changing this chart
so that people don't get confused
another thing that we can do that we
should do on all of our visualizations
is
change the titles so that they're more
business or user friendly
great
and
so we have our filter
and let's use this as a filter
and that way we can click on new zealand
and we can see it's the most business
friendly regulations and we can see its
internet
and phone usage over time
we can click on
a lot of different countries to see
those changes
you can see that
some countries have a steeper
change so some of them have
adopted phone and internet usage and
have stayed pretty similar whereas other
ones have only
really adopted it in the last couple of
years
also if we wanted to filter to just one
country we could do what we did before
and create a country filter
here's another way to go to the sheet
you can click this down arrow and click
go to sheet or you can come over here
you can see that it's highlighting a
visualization over here or a sheet and
whatever sheet i click on is highlighted
over here
and there's this little pop out arrow
here that also takes you to the sheet
and we can bring country
on
use them all
go back to our dashboard
we'll go to filters and select country
we'll make it a multiple value drop down
we're going to add the apply button and
now we're going to make it apply to all
the visualizations by
clicking apply to workbooks selected
worksheets all on dashboard okay
now we can see that if we just want to
look at afghanistan
okay
we can see
how many days it takes to start a
business there it's not preferred for
business and it's internet and phone
usage over time
and those are our
four dashboards so as a review we have
made
a dashboard on population
we made one about health we made one
that had to do with our economy
and one that had to do with our ease of
doing business
so today we'll be dealing with the
tableau project so the first data set
that we will be using for the tableau
project is based on covet 19 data
followed by that we'll have another
project based on the airline data and
finally the third project will be based
on space missions data
now let's begin with our first project
so in this first project we'll be
dealing with the covert 19 data set and
using that data set will be getting some
insights so what are those insights
those are what are the total number of
confirmed cases in different nations
what are the total number of recovered
cases in different nations so we'll be
using the map chart for these and we'll
be finding out the insights about how
are the cases going on in the current
situation or in the current date or year
followed by that we'll also look into
the insights of the confirmed and
recovered cases in india as well
followed by that we'll enter into the
next query where we'll find out the
trend line of code 19 in the
international level like how it started
how is it going on
and moving forward we'll create a group
of indian states and we'll find out the
covert heads there and then we will
discuss about the death rates so highest
death rates at international level and
the least death rates in the
international level then we'll enter
into the next segment where we'll find
out the variation in covert 19 cases
around the world and then finally we'll
discuss the future of covert 19 in the
international level basically we'll
create a trend line which will give us
the forecast levels of the covert 19
like is it going to increase or is it
going to decrease or what's going to
happen in the near future
so i hope i made myself clear with the
queries or the insights that we're going
to take from the cover 19 data set using
table u so without further ado let's get
started with the w
so we are on table u right now so we'll
be using an excel data file
so we'll be using the code 19 data file
so this particular data set is available
on kaggle and if you don't find it there
don't worry we'll be attaching that
particular data set in the description
box below you can use that as well now
let's just select open to get connected
with that particular data
so you can see that we just got
connected with that data and
there will be some
minute errors in the data or there will
be some problem with the data which the
table you might identify and when it
identifies something
messy with the data it will show you an
option
maybe you might want to use the data
interpreter so i prefer using that
so whenever i see that particular option
on the left hand side i better use it
for
the safer side for being for being on
safer side with the data and let's also
select these
not a problem
yeah
so the data got clean now you can see
that over here so to do that you can
also check the
review results so when you click that
review results option then you'll get
into this particular excel document
which will help you with the changes
made to that data set so you can see
that the orange color one says the data
is interpreted as column headers or
field name and
the green box suggests you that data is
interpreted as values in your data
source
and now you can see that
there you go
so now we'll get back to w now you can
see that the data has been interpreted
successfully by the w and everything is
uh as expected by the table every every
data element in the data set is as
expected by the table and it's really
fine now now we'll check the uh columns
what we have in our data set right over
here
so we have the serial numbers
observation dates province state and the
country or region last update and
confirmed that recovered so basically
these three columns will be telling us
the confirmed cases in that particular
region country or state and the debts
happened in that region country of state
and recovered rate and the last update
when was the last test done the latest
tested done and in which region and
what's the observation date what's the
observation results on that particular
date and the serial numbers etc etc
so we have the clear understanding of
our data set now let's get started with
the first sheet what we have over here
so according to our first query we had
to find out the total number of
confirmed cases in different nations
so for that we might want to select the
country or region and then
the confirmed from measures so for that
we'll be selecting the map chart for
this so that we have the data shown in a
more appealing format
so now we have the blue color of map on
a screen right now where the darkest
color shows the maximum number of
cases confirmed and the lighter ones
represent the lower number of cases
confirmed
now let's let's make this look a little
more interesting so for that we can
select the edit color options and inside
that let's select the
red to green
divergent
yeah this is it red to green white
divergent and
as you can see the colors are a little
opposite right now so we want the
greener one in the lower side
and
the red colored one on the higher side
this should be good so let's select okay
and
apply
and okay
so you can see that the red color now
represents the highest number of cases
and a lighter red one here you can see
the a little touch of red which shows
that the india's got some good amount of
cases as well and in the brazil and etc
etc so even russia
has a little light green so this shows
it also has some good amount of cases
not not completely green though
yeah so this is how it looks now let's
rename the sheet as
confirmed cases
at the international level
now according to our second query
we are supposed to find the total number
of recovered cases in different nations
so now let's create a new sheet for that
now for that we'll be selecting the
country or region
and then we'll be selecting the
recovered and hover over to the show me
icon
and let's select the map for that
now you can see that we have
a lot of recovery happening in india so
according to the stats we get to hear
that the virus which we have in india is
a little you know kind of harmful than
comparatively what we had in china and
other states of the world
or the other nations of the world
so yeah we have a good recovery rate in
india
now let's rename the sheet as recovery
recovered cases
international level
yeah so i'm naming these sheets
separately because we'll be using these
sheets to create a dashboard at the end
now let's get into the third query what
we have right now is find the total
number of confirmed cases in india and
what are the total number of recovered
cases in india
so for that
let's create a new sheet and
let's select country or region and
confirmed
now we'll be selecting the
text table
and we have the complete data set right
now we have all the nations over here so
what we are looking for is just india
so for that now we'll drag the country
or region into filters
and inside this you can see we have an
option of selecting india
now let's search for india
g h i
so we have india over here let's select
apply and okay so we have the total
number of cases in india now
we can drag the state of province into
rose
at all members
so in india we have old states and
so all the states have their own
confirmed cases so this is the total
confirm state or confirm count in india
let's rename the sheet
confirmed
cases
in india
similarly let's find the recovery cases
in india
let's create a new sheet for that
rename it as recovery
cases in india
so now let's select the country region
recovery
and then
let's close the show me icon and
now let's drag the configuration to
filters then
none select india
apply okay and
let's drag this data province here
add all numbers
yeah so you have the
text chart here which represents the
total number of recovered cases in india
according to the state wise
now yeah this looks okay but we can make
it look a little more appealing so that
it's it's more um you know visible and
understandable readable so we can make
that happen so let's make a duplicate of
this
and recovery cases as well
now i would like to change the confirm
cases in india into a pie chart
which looks a little bit more readable
and understandable let's select the
entire view so that we have
a bigger pie chart and a little bit
understandable or readable let's
increase the
size a little bit and let's select the
label and select the show mark label so
that we have all the
numbers over here we can even select the
uh
province of state and drag it into
detail so we have the state's name as
well or
should we tag it into
label
yeah now the recovered into label again
yeah there you go we have this state and
we have the confirmed number over here
so this is how we can make the data look
a bit more appealing and understandable
so we can see that maharashtra has a
larger number of confirmed cases
it's the biggest state of india
so maybe yeah that's true and
now we'll get back to the duplicate
sheet of recovery cases in india and now
let's make it look a bit more appealing
by changing the way the data looks so
for this we can select the packed bubble
option
now we can see the
bubbles which show the
recovery states happening in the indian
states or the recovery cases
so
you can see that everything is looking
in uh blue color
but difficult to understand so for that
let's drag the province or state into
color so that we can have different
colors for different states
yeah now this is good we have the
country name and state name this is fine
now we can make it a bit more readable
by dragging the recovered icon into
or the recovered
bill into the label
so we have the count of recoveries
happening in that particular state and
that particular country now it's a bit
more readable now we have
maharashtra at the leading place we have
a good recovery in maharashtra
yeah that's fine now let's get back to
the presentation mode and see our
next
query so can we forecast the trend line
of covert 19 here
so how it started how is it going on so
we can do that let's get back to w again
so let's create a new sheet we have the
new sheet over here let's rename that as
trend line
yeah the sheet got renamed now let's
select the observation data from the
dimensions since you're making a
trendline so let's keep it observation
date or you can even select the
last update let's go with the last
update now let's select the confirmed
pill from
measures
let's select a line chart
or
we can do that from here as well
okay so we're not getting the line chart
so there might be some problem
with the date format over here
so
we
have to change the data type of
so i think this might be something with
the
date
yeah let's select the date pill and
change the data type to
date or date and time from string so you
can see we had a string first
so now it's changed to
date and time now we'll be getting a
proper trendline so now we have it
according to the year so we can make it
according to quarter
and
even even even in the form of months and
so if you see this a little bit readable
you can keep it that way or you can even
change to days
so
yeah i think there is some problem with
dating time value
so let's keep it in the form of months
it's it's more readable in one screen so
yeah it's good
let's remove this so we have the month
update
now let's go to analytics to create a
trend line and you can select the trend
line and drag it over here and select
the linear option so you can see here we
have the trend line over here which
reach the r squared and p values and
confirm and we have a formula for that
so basically tabula creates a formula to
create a trend line so which is 5.280
exponent to the power of 8 and 2 month
of last update so very pretty pretty
complex formula yet understandable
so this is how you create a trendline
so according to the trends we have
january february the quartus q1q to q3
q4 and this is the first month of
january so here it is
so in in january we find
one
okay this is in billions maybe yeah
maybe even trillions who knows but but
based on the data we have in the last
year we have a decrement of the
confirmed cases in january so it's
basically indicating that
corona yes basically or slowly
decreasing that's a good sign
now
now let's try to find out the trend line
for india
let's duplicate this
so for that let's drag the country into
filters
we have the filter option
and
let's select all
no no not all
we might want to select the indian
icon
yeah
let's select apply
okay
so now we have the trend line for india
let's kind of rename it
yeah
even even you can see a gradual drop of
corona in india as well so the number
has decreased in india as well
in the earlier year we had a lot of
cases
above
30 crores now we have nearly 20 crores
that's a good sign in india as well
now let's get back to the presentation
mode and try to select the next query
so according to the next query uh can we
group indian states and find covert 19
hits yeah we can do that
now let's get back to tableau for that
let's create a new sheet and uh
let's rename it as grouped
so the sheet got renamed now we're going
to select the country or region
or province
now for that
you can see the create option over here
now inside that let's select the group
now
we have to create a group of
indian nations
so select
andaman and ecobar hold control select
andhra pradesh
now let's select a couple of
states we know which are in india
arunachal pradesh
assam
don't forget to hold the control key for
this
or else the options might vanish
we have bihar
we have chandigarh
we have chapters girl
we have dadar and nagar haveli daiyou
diamond
we have delhi
yeah we are going to just select a
couple of uh
states
uh just to show how um group can be none
so fetching all the states in this
particular
column would be a little difficult or we
might even miss a few
we have gujarat
we have haryana
we have islamabad
jammu and kashmir
jharkhand
we have karnataka
we have caroline
we have madhya pradesh maharashtra
nagaland
we have been job
we have rajasthan
we have tamil nadu
we have telangana
we have the pradesh
we have west bengal
and
let's rename the group as
indian
states group
let's select apply and okay
so after selecting the apply option and
clicking ok so we can have a new pill in
the dimensions section that happens to
be indian states group
so what we're going to do is drag that
pill into detail option so that we can
have the results on our screen
so there you go the states what we
selected are right over here all the
jammu kashmir
and punjab maharashtra gujarat etc etc
and our lakshadweep and the andaman and
nicobar islands
right so we have all the states of india
right on our screen
okay um
let's expand it a little bit
scrolling on tableau is a little bit
difficult
i don't know how to select the default
option for the screen
yes um
we can see
these states
i don't know where this crawler is at
yeah we can always undo what we did in w
so that's the best part
now let's drag the state spell again so
that we can have a perfect map in the
screen right now
yeah
i would like to not to mess with it
again it's it's pretty good right now
let's keep it as it is now let's quickly
get back to our presentation and check
out our next query so find the highest
death rates at international level so we
we are basically going to find which
nation or the country has the highest
death rates and which is the country
with the least amount of death rates so
which is the safest country
now let's get back to tabalee now we're
not going to mess with this particular
sheet let's create a new sheet
let's rename the sheet as highest death
rates
international
i n t l
let's enter
so the shade got renamed successfully
let's drag in country
and let's drag and confirm cases
so
we have a map over here so w basically
uh kind of selected the
map as default
we can drag the depths and
now we can actually change this to
a text chart
now let's drag the measure names into
rows
so we have a little bit more you know
sorted kind of data so you can see we
have the confirm cases over here and
that trades here now if we kind of sort
it
in the descending order
yeah so the
order is being changed now so we have
so we have our charts processed by
tableau for a better visual so our chart
got rearranged or
ordered in the descending order so with
that we have the highest
you know
uh debts and confirmed cases in u.s so
we can even do that using a parameter
where you can create
the
top 10 or top five nations with highest
confident debt values
so for that you can
drag
both
or no you need to create a parameter
i think it's not required over here
let's continue with
the
next
sheet or you can just simply duplicate
this
since the data set is a little huge it
takes a little bit of time
now let's rename this
yeah
now let's rename this sheet
it's still taking a little bit of time
yeah now i think we can rename it
least
death rates so now for that we're gonna
rearrange it in the descending order
i'm an ascending order
so yeah after sorting and changing some
layouts we have the
least number of
cases or death rates in
the country called makkah where we have
least number of deaths and least number
of confident cases
so with that let's move into the
presentation mode again
and in the presentation mode we have our
next query that says can we find the
variation in covered 19 cases around the
world
so for that let's create a new sheet
again
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so after changing some
arrangements or by making an ascending
arrangement and changing the layout
or the orientation and everything we
have our final result which states that
we have the least number of debts and
confirmations of covert 19 in the
country of afghanistan
so yeah so we have the pretty well
sorted arranged data over here on the
screen now let's get back to the
presentation mode and in the
presentation mode the next query that we
have to deal with is can we find the
variation in copy 19 cases around the
world yeah we can do that so let's get
back to w and create a new sheet
let's rename the sheet as a variation
of
c one nine
yeah it's done
so to find out the variation of covert
19 we might want to use the boxes and
viscous chart let's select the country
region pill from dimensions and
confirm from measures let's arrow to the
show me tab and select the box and
whisker plot
yeah so you can see that we just have
one box of whisker over here when you
see something like this happening on
your sheet then directly head over to
analytics and
uncheck the aggregate measures so
we have this kind of visualization
maybe we forgot something so we've got
the country or region to be placed in
columns
so when you place it in the columns
section then you find out all the
countries and the variation of kobe 19
in their region
now let's um
sort it in the descending order so that
we can find out
the maximum variation which is happening
in france
so of course there are less number of
confirmed cases but there is a lot of
variation which states that
they have something wrong
with the climatic conditions or the
weather conditions there
yeah we have a larger
confirmations and or larger cases in u.s
but there is
some
[Music]
some data which shows that france is
leading
in some variation yeah
so um
since we're calculating the variation of
the confirmation of covered 19 presents
we have france in the first place where
it shows that there is a lot of
variation in the confirmed cases in
france rather than u.s
yeah
that's how we can find the variation of
presence of covert 19 in a particular
country
so with that let's move into the next
query so the next query is can we
forecast the sheet of future and
reference of code 19 presence
yes we can do that let's get back to w
for that let's create a new sheet and
rename it as
forecast
of
coal with 19
presents
so the sheet got renamed successfully
now we'll select the observation date
from the
dimensions and confirm fill from
measures
so we'll use them drag it to columns
and the confirm from
yeah
now we're going to change this okay
there is something wrong with the
observation date so for that
let's select the observation fill and
change the data type to date
yeah
so far so good
now let's select this to
day
we can change that to
here
now let's select four cat option yeah
so
this is how it's gonna be
so in the year of 2020 we had the
confirmed cases around this number which
is seven sixty seven zero five three
four six four so which is nearly
seventy six thousand three hundred and
seventy lack
and in the 2021 the number got a little
decreased
which is 17 130 lakh cases and in the
end of 2022 which is the forecast we can
see there is a little more drop so it's
a good sign that the covert 19 is
getting decreased so this is the
forecast of the covet 19 presence in
india
so we can change the path
to
a stepped one
the line is okay the line is pretty good
no worries on that so basically we
finished uh the queries on our
presentation mode
so yeah if we get back to the
presentation mode so all the queries on
the covet 19 data are finished
now let's create a dashboard
yeah we have the dashboard right now so
we can change the layout of dashboard
let me increase the width
to
1320 and decrease the height to 70
or 760. so we have the entire screen
right now
now let's drag in the confirmed cases of
international level and
the recovery cases of the international
level
yeah now we have it
okay or
let's keep it in the top and that in the
bottom
the trend line of code in the
international level
and the highest death rates
in the international level
it takes a little time
it's still taking a little bit more time
i don't know what's wrong
okay
it should be done in some time
let's wait
it's basically taking a lot of time
because we have a lot of data in that
particular sheet
let's kind of change that a little
now
let's change the sheet to
we can just remove this from the
dashboard and
select the least depth rate or the top
10 least death threats so we have sheet
right over here we have the top 10 ones
only here
yeah this is good
so this is how we can have the dashboard
and now let's create another dashboard
for indian results
so again let's uh change the
dimensions of the screen
yeah it's pretty good now let's take the
confirm cases in india
and drop it over here and recovery cases
in india and drop it over there
and
trend lines in india over here
and
indian states
in the forecast
somewhere over here
and if we get back to the dashboard one
we can even add the forecast data or the
variation data
somewhere over here
and we can always change the height
so that it's a bit more visible
so we can rename the dashboard
c
1 9
international
dashboard
and this one has
c
one nine
indian
dashboard
yeah so with that we have finished the
first project based on the covert 19
data set now we'll continue with the
next data set that is the airline data
set
so now we are in the second project and
the second project is about the airline
data set and in this particular data set
we're going to take the insights which
are as follows
what are the total number of flights
which are taking off in a day from the
san francisco airport and followed by
that we have the next query which reads
out find the busiest day of san
francisco airport
we'll be finding out the top five
busiest days in the san francisco
airport and followed by that we'll also
find what are the total number of
flights per day in a month
then we'll find out what are the top 10
busiest flight routes then we'll find
out what are the top 10 longest flight
routes from san francisco airport then
we have to represent the flights flying
outside the san francisco
towards different parts of the world
using a map chart
so these are the queries that we'll be
executing in our second project without
further ado let's get back to the w so
now we are back on the w dashboard so
let's select our data set for today
so our data set is somewhere here
yeah this is the air travel data set we
were looking for
now we got our air travel data set
loaded onto w so remember i said about
the
interpreter i'll select that and
show early
okay let's let the query execute
yeah so the interpreter query got
executed now the data has been cleaned
you can review the results by clicking
on review results option over here
we have another query executed now
basically this query will take us to the
microsoft excel sheet
where our cleaned data is ready
available for us
there you go you can see that the red
colored data is the
data that is interpreted as column
headers or field names the green color
one is the data interpreted as values in
your data source
so it looks something like this so we
have our data fine over here just
looking fine
now when you come into the root column
you have san francisco to
the other parts of the world for example
we have los angeles here etc etc but we
don't have a separate field for origin
and a destination so what we'll be doing
is we'll be splitting this particular
column
uh right over here
so let's navigate to the last column
which will show us the root
so you can right click this
and select the option of slit which will
basically split it into two halves which
will give us the
from destination or
the origin of the
airplane and
to
or the destination of the plane so from
two or the origin destination fields we
have right now over here you can see
that
um so far so good so let's quickly begin
with our worksheet
now we are on the worksheet right now so
what was our first query so our first
query was to find the total number of
flights in a day
so for that
we have a simple step so basically we'll
have
a particular number of rows right for
the data set what we've selected we will
have some thousands of data sets so each
and every row is actually a flight
so what we will do is just create a
calculated field and
just name it as number
of rows
okay since we are trying to calculate
the total number of flights let's um you
know kind of
uh not name it as rows instead we'll
name it as flights
and inside the calculated field just
write one and it should be done
so you can see the number of lights just
over here just hover down to the text
and we'll have the number over here so
this is the total number of flights per
day which takes off from the san
francisco airport
let's kind of increase the text size so
that it's a bit more visible
yeah that should be it
uh let's rename the sheet
from here i would i i would do the
renaming from here because it's a little
simple
total number of lights
yeah that should be it now let's get on
to the presentation mode again now let's
uh you know execute the second query
find the busiest day at the san
francisco airport
so to execute the second query let's
just simply duplicate the sheet and
rename the sheet as um
busiest
okay
we can actually schedules of
flights
or no not schedules of flights
number of lights
or
we can rename this as
flights taking off
so when we get the count of flights
taking off then we can actually find the
date which was really busy like
the date with the maximum amount of uh
you know
flights taking off that would be the
busiest day so the data type is date by
default that's great now let's drag it
to columns
now the sum
of numbers at this place
analysis let's uncheck this to get a map
let's make it by month
or
okay
we don't need this
we don't need this
we all need this as well
now we have a chart over here let's
change it
to
scatter plot maybe
yeah so we have the chart no worries on
the scatter plot thing it's it's really
a scatter plot and don't know what is on
that so right now we need to find out
the busiest days so for that we might
want to drag the date into filter and
let's select the individual dates select
next and inside the top we have the
oh yeah we need to select by field and
now we have the top 10
number of lights on yeah we need we need
the top 10 flies
so
let's select apply we needed top one but
uh why not top ten you will select top
10 for that now we have the scatter plot
on my sheet right now
so let's kind of
arrange it in the descending order this
shows the
highest number of lights are
okay
we need
to change this value to some
yeah it is some
so uh yeah i got to know where we made a
mistake so inside analysis we were
supposed to aggregate the measures so
that we can get the sum of
number of lights now we have the total
number of flights
now let's quickly uh arrange this
now we have the
3166 3200
season 295
yeah so
3295 happens to be our
you know busiest day in the year 2020
that is the sixth march which had the
maximum number of flights taking off
so
we can actually make a set of these
the set of these which happens to be in
the march so much happens to be the
busiest month for san francisco airport
so with that we have finished the second
query now let's create a new sheet for
our third query let's get back to the
presentation
and the third query reads that what are
the total number of flights per day in a
month so for that let's get back to w
let's try to
rename it
total
flights
in a month
done
so for that let's select date and drag
it to columns and
let's make it to
month
let's remove this
let's remove this
let's remove this as well now let's
check it to
d
and now
number of flights
so automatically we have a line chart
and we have the flights taking off from
march 1st to march 31st which happens to
be the busiest
month for san francisco airport now
let's just take the show mark label so
that we have the number of flights
taking off every day
so as we got the result in the previous
sheet 290 or 300
3295 flights on the date of sixth march
or is it third march maybe yeah that
happened sixth march that happened to be
the busiest day of uh san francisco
airport
now
let's get back to the presentation and
check the
fourth query so the fourth query reads
what are the top 10 busiest flight
routes
for that let's get back to w again
let's rename the newly created sheet
busiest
routes
now the uh sheet has been replaced or
renamed
now to find out the top busiest routes
we need a calculated field to remove the
effects of san francisco airport first
so clinton create a calculated field and
we can name it as
uh
busiest route busy
and now inside the calculated field we
need an if condition
then
if
route 1 split 1
is equals to
sfo
then
route
2
split 2.
else route one
and
yeah the cancellation is valid let's
apply and okay
now we have the newly created calculated
we feel somewhere here and we'll drag
that into rows and now we'll drag the
number of flights to columns
so there we go we have the
bar chart over here let's um you know
rearrange it in descending order so that
we get the you know descending order
now we needed the top 10 or top busiest
routes for that let's drag busy into
filters
select top and by field we have top 10
let's just select apply and okay and we
have the top busiest routes from san
francisco airport or sfo
now let's get back to the presentation
mode and in the presentation mode the
next query is which are the top longest
flight rules from sfo
so to find out the
longest routes we'll create a new sheet
and rename it as
our
busiest no not busiest longest longest
routes
yeah
the sheet is renamed and you can see
that we have geometry coordinates 0 0 0
1 one zero and one one so these z okay
not zero one one and one zero
coordinates basically provide the origin
information and zero zero and zero one
provide the destination information so
we'll be creating a calculated field for
that now
let's create a calculated field
so let's rename the calculated field as
origin
and inside the origin we'll make use of
make point
and inside make point we'll write
geometry
coordinates one one and
geometry coordinates
we'll need the geometric coordinates 1 1
and geometric coordinates 1 zero
separated by comma
and done so we have the origin now let's
create another for destination
we are creating a calculated field
destination
and inside destination we are going to
use the same
mate point and
geo
metric coordinates
0 0 comma geometric coordinates 0 one
and select apply okay
now the origin and destination are
created now we need to create another
calculated field for distance
so we'll write it as distance and inside
that we'll use the distance function
and we'll write origin
comma
destination and will represent
the distance who using kilometers
and select apply
okay
now we have the newly created distance
measure in the measure section now we'll
drag the busy into columns and
distance into
rows
okay uh we made something
oh there's no problem we can actually
change the orientation
and now let's rearrange it in the form
of descending order now we have the
distance sorted in the descending order
but there is a small change we have to
change the sum
to
average
so once you change that you want to
arrange it again now we have the vlr
bangalore as the farthest airport from
sfo yeah now we might want to drag the
busy into fill this again
now we have the top ten
apply
okay so we have the top ten longest
routes from sfo
so with that we have uh finished our
fifth query let's get back to
presentation mode and the sixth query
represent the flights flying outside sfo
towards different parts of the world
yeah that can be done let's get back to
w again
now for the six query let's create a new
sheet let's name it as
map
flights from sfo
okay so for that let's select the
latitude and longitude and select a map
[Music]
so we have the map right here
now let's change that to map
yeah it's in the map section by default
let's create a calculated field
called
lines so we are basically using lines to
represent the flights taking off from
sfo so i'll name it as line
or we can
name it as flights line
okay and inside the calculated field
let's type in
make line and
so inside the field let's make use of
make line function and inside that let's
write an origin
and separated by comma destination
and the calculation is valid apply okay
now we have the newly created flight
line over here
now we'll drag that flat line to detail
now once we drag that
flight line to the detail we have the
lines or flights taking off from sfo to
different parts of the world now we can
make it look a bit more appealing or
more informative by
dragging
the roads are
yeah
into detail
so we have the details of roots and
we can even drag the distance into
detail so when we
hover over to the line we'll have the
root and the distance as well
yeah so that's how it is done now we're
basically done with all the queries now
let's create a
dashboard so now let's um you know kind
of arrange the dashboard size convenient
to our monitor so i'll increase it to
1320 width and decrease the height to
760. so that's the proper size what i
was looking for
now
we'll drag the
details
into the sheet
longest routes
we have the flights taking off busiest
routes longest routes
and
total flights
into here
now it looks more readable
fine so we have the busiest routes we
have the longest route we have the
flights taking off and the month of
march the busiest month was the march
and the busiest day was 6th of march i
don't know what was so special on that
day if you know it please let me know in
the comment section below
and yeah so totally we created a
dashboard now let's rename the dashboard
as
sfo flight data dashboard
and we are done so we're done with the
second project now let's get back to our
presentation and let's check the last
project that happens to be the space
missions data set
so now we are in the third project which
is based on space missions data set so
using this particular data set we're
going to get some insights which are
based on the queries on my screen right
now so we're going to find out what are
the average temperature details of the
launch sites
what are the average wind speed details
of the launch sites what are the average
humidity details of the launch sites so
we need all these to uh you know before
launching a satellite or a rocket into
space everything needs to be in ideal
condition
so followed by that we have what are the
different varieties of launch vehicles
used by different companies so there are
a lot many companies if you are from
government sector where you're from
private sector for example uh usa
military satellites belong to government
and uh private satellites like um spacex
yeah and few others
next we have what is the mission status
of the company so we have a list of
satellites launched already right so we
need the mission status of that
particular
satellite is it a successful launch or
was there some failure record or
something like that next at the last
query we have the track records of
launch sites
so what are the track records so what
are the successful launches what are the
failure launches what are the satellites
launched by different companies etc etc
we'll have a complete track record of
that of all the launch sites which are
available in our data set
now without further ado let's get back
to tableau and start the project
so we are on tableau now we're going to
extract the data set so the data set we
need is the space missions data set you
can get this in the kaggle or you can
even have the access to this data set
from the description box below select
open to open the data
so yeah the data got successfully loaded
again use the interpreter and it's a
good habit of using the interpreters to
clean your data and make everything
understandable or look understandable
show all the assets everything is fine
so we're good to go with the data set
what we have in our
tableau right now
now with that let's get back to the
first sheet
now let's check the first query that we
have in our presentation what are the
average temperature details of launch
sites so for that let's
create a new sheet yeah it's created
rename it as avg
temperatures
or
launch site
temperatures
so now we need the
launch site and select the temperature
and hover over to the show me tab and
let's select the bubbles chart
so now you can see the temperature is in
the sum but we don't need the sum here
we need to change that to average now we
have the average temperatures of the
launch sites now let's kind of select
label show marks here
so we can
do one more thing we can drag the
temperature onto the
label now
we have the temperature here now let's
again change the measure to average now
we have the average temperatures of the
launch sites in fahrenheit
yeah that's pretty well
now
let's get back to the presentation and
the next query is what are the average
wind speed details of the launch sites
let's get back to tableau again
let's create a new sheet
launch
site
wind speeds
now let's drag the launch site into
columns and wind speed from measures
into rows
and
you can see automatically we have a bar
chart
but to make it a little bit more
readable let's select the
boxes and viscous chart yeah you know
what to do now go to analysis uncheck
the aggregate measures options
and let's drag the
launch site again onto columns now we
have the different
box and whiskers for different sites
so
let's kind of arrange it
yeah so the wind speeds at
kennedy space center are here 20 miles
and 23 at vandenberg
and marshall at nine
yeah so this is the wind speeds at
different launch sites now let's get
back to the
presentation mode and now we have to
find the humidity details of launch
sites
so let's get back to table we are back
on w let's rename it um
launch site
now let's select the repeat now let's
select the launch site and humidity
then
a pie chart
the pie chart is really small so we can
select the entire view
now we have the sum of humidity but we
need the average humidity
and now let's
drag humidity onto label
and launch site to label
now we have the detail humidity
now we need to select the
measure to average again
and here to average again
yeah so we have the humidity percentage
of launch sites
on the pie chart over here so with that
we are done now let's get back to
presentation again now our fourth query
which states that what are the different
varieties of launch vehicles used by
different companies for that let's get
back to tableau
now let's create a new sheet
launch vehicle
details
yeah
now this query is pretty straightforward
select company and uh
vehicle type and we should be done
so there we go we have the company name
and vehicles used for the launching of
satellites process now let's get back to
the presentation mode let's select the
next query
what is the mission status of companies
now let's get back to tableau
let's create a new sheet and rename it
as
mission status
now we are back on tableau now let's
select the company
drag that to columns and
mission status to columns and
we'll select one
[Music]
parameter from
measures so that we can get a
good
bar chart side-by-side bar chart
and now we can
drag the company to color so that we can
have different colors for different
companies so
we have the mission details so
spacex found a maximum success in the
recent days and little failures and
yeah
boeing found good success as well and
some failures so these are the mission
status of different companies and
different satellites as well
so we have even u.s air force here faced
some satellites here
some failures and some satellites it's
okay
so now let's get back to presentation
mode
now the sixth query is track records of
lunch sites
okay we had the payload as some so we
changed it to count distinct count
so now we have a better observation of
failures and successes over here so as
we discussed in the sixth query now we
need to find the track records of launch
sites
now let's create a new sheet rename it
as track records
and
now let's drag the company to columns
and
mission status to columns again and now
let's drag the
launch site yeah
i think we might want to drag the
mission status to rose
yeah
let's create click on
text
now let's drag the space mission scan to
color
and space mission counter labels
let's use this one yeah
now we have the
stay stats or the track records of
different space centers or launch sites
and we have the failures and success
rates over here
yeah so basically we have done the last
sheet or last query executed now let's
create a new dashboard
as we always do change the resolution
according to the
monitor we have so i'm gonna use
1030p
and height as 760.
now let's drag the
sheets
so we have the launch temperatures
launch wind speeds and launch site
humidity
at one place
now the launch vehicles used
mission status
and
the track records
so we'll kind of
drag it here
and this one over here
this little bit over here
and this one over here
so now we can actually you know
select
the track records of cape carnival we
have the site temperature we have the
site humidity we have the site wind
speed and the track records of that
particular site and launch vehicles
launched mission status everything on
one single
dashboard
so that's how you make use of dashboards
in real time today we'll be going over
answers to common interview questions
for tableau positions first question is
what are the data types supported in
tableau we have string date date and
time numerical boolean so true or false
and geographical in tableau you can tell
what kind of data type you have so when
you're on the data source tab you can
see that this is numerical and this is
string here we have a date we don't have
any date times here that would have the
little clock icon and we also have
geographical these are set by default
and you can change them by clicking on
the icon
and say we wanted row id to allow text
so we'll change it to string and you can
see the icon changes there the next
question has to do with how will you
understand dimensions and measures so a
key thing to remember is that dimensions
are qualitative and measures are
quantitative and if you can remember
those particular words it helps convey
what the interviewer is looking for so
dimensions are qualitative and you can
use them to categorize your data so for
example you can categorize your data by
what country it comes from and measures
are quantitative and can be aggregated
so you can do a sum of sales or you can
do the average profit did you know that
tableau automatically assigns each field
a data type and a role and that
automatically aggregates your measures
using sum but you can change what the
default aggregation is question three
what do you understand by discrete and
continuous in tableau so we have
discrete values and continuous values
discrete is represented as blue and
continuous is represented as green so
let's look in tableau when we go to our
worksheet
you can see that all the dimensions are
automatically blue
and all of the measures are green
however you can have a continuous
dimension and you can have a discrete
measure
so we have discrete dimensions which is
a blue dimension but also continuous
dimensions and data is a good example of
that let's take a look so we pull on
order date we right now have year
and it's making categories
instead of a continuous axis so it's
making a finite list there but we can
change it
to be
you can see now it's marked as
continuous here and it's green and we
change it to be an axis
instead of different categories it would
be a continuous axis
so you can also have discrete measures
which are blue measures and continuous
measures in the green so for example
let's say
we had a visualization that had
the region
and
sales
and profit
but instead of having an axis for profit
maybe we just wanted to have
a number for the profit listed right
next to
the region and then we could have the
sales visualization so what we could do
is change it to a discrete
value and put it next to region and now
it's part of the labels and that's an
example of having a discrete
measure
did you know that
continuous is infinite and discrete is
finite those are some key words that you
could use also to describe the
difference between continuous and
discrete and also just remember that
discrete is blue and continuous is green
the next question number four is what
are filters and name the different
filters in tableau so filters are a way
to restrict the data that allows you to
only see the data that you want to see
in your workbook or dashboard and there
are these different types of filters and
they also have a specific order so if
you can remember the different filters
that's helpful but also if you can
remember what order they apply in
that'll get you some definite bonus
points in your interview we have extract
filters that filter the data as it
extracts and it will affect how big your
extract is we also have data source
filters here which will filter the data
out of the data source however the
extract will still be the same size so
let's take a look at this handy
visualization
that tableau has on their website we
have the order of operations and in blue
we have our filters so extracts is first
and it filters down your extract to just
what you've selected and we have data
source filters that will apply to the
entire data source so any visualization
that uses that data source will have
these filters we also have context
filters which are next which come before
some of these level of details that's
the major difference is that it applies
before some of these sets and
conditional values and then you will do
dimensions and then measures so any
filters that happen on dimensions happen
before any measure filters the last type
of filter we have is a table calculation
filter which happens after all of the
rest of them and basically just applies
to
your visualization just the one
visualization question number five there
are three customer segments in the
superstore data set what percent of the
total profits is associated with the
corporate segment perfect so in some
tableau interviews you may be asked to
build a visualization for our examples
here we'll be using the superstore data
set and if you don't have access to the
superstore data set just comment below
and somebody on the simply learn team
will help you get access to that also
this is a fun opportunity to pause the
video and then you can work on this on
your own and then come back and see if
what you did was the right thing or how
we did it differently also you can
comment below on what your answer is and
we'll see if we can all get the right
thing
so let's build this
three customer segments in the
superstore data set what percent of the
total profits total profits is
associated with corporate segment great
so we're going to bring on our segments
and we have consumer corporate and home
office and let's bring on our
total profit so i just did that by
double clicking and now it's just
bringing on the sum for each of those by
default but we want to figure out what
percent of the total each of these are
so we can change this to be
a table calculation we can click add
table calculation or we can do a quick
table calculation
and find percent of total so let's go
back to our question we wanted to know
the percent of total profits associated
with the corporate segment and the
corporate segment has 32.12
of the total profits
and here's our solution with
32.12
so did you get it right comment below if
you got that what are the different
joins in tableau give an example so in
tableau
you can join your data so if we wanted
to look at orders and tie it to
people we could pull on people and it
will give you this visualization and you
can see all the different joins here and
we'll discuss those in just a second you
also have the opportunity to union
information which would be if we had
maybe two excel sheets that had orders
information perhaps one of them had 2012
and one of them had 2013 then you could
take your orders and pull it so you see
that pop-up drag table to union and
that's another way to add more data and
so those are all worth mentioning let's
take a look at the different kinds of
joins
we have our inner join which will only
give you the values
that have matches in both tables
our left join that will give you all the
values in the left table and its matches
in the right table
and then the right join which will give
you all the values in the right table
and its matches in the left table
the outer join also known as a full
outer join will give you all the values
in the left and the right table
and then as we discuss the union you can
see it's represented by a more vertical
join and what it does is it adds more
rows all the rest of these are about
adding more columns but this will add
more rows
in the same columns that you had before
if you have the opportunity to draw out
the answer to this question and make
these venn diagrams it's a really
helpful way for you to explain your
point and it really portrays that you
know what you're talking about what is
the difference between a join and
blending in tableau so i just showed you
how to make a join here and we are
joining an excel sheet
to another excel sheet all within the
same connection to that excel file so
when you're joining data we'll look over
here at the joining side that's when
you're bringing two or more tables
within the same data source and that's
how you join it and so
we're all inside of a data source here
which when i go to sheet1 just has one
data source here called orders whatever
we wanted to call it and that is all
within one data source however let's say
we already had two different data
sources in tableau and we wanted to
bring together two of them so in this
case it's an oracle table and we brought
in an oracle table and we made a data
source and then also an excel table that
had a second data source and you can
blend it together to get your combined
data set so the major difference what
you're going to really want to take away
from this is that blending is from two
separate tableau data sources and that
joining is all within one data source
and it ends up just being one data
source in the end in blending each data
source contains its own set of
dimensions and measures and when you
join it will combine it into one set of
dimensions and measures so let's go back
to our example here let's bring on
people it is automatically said we're
going to join it on region and we're
going to do an inner join that's fine by
me
and so we come here
and now we have just one
set of dimension and measures under
orders however if we were to add a
second data source which we will it'll
be an excel file and it will be based
off of this rank example
we'll open that up and now when we go to
sheet 1
we have two data sources
and if we were to blend this data
together we would still see two separate
sets of data only we would be able to
pull in from this set some information
and we'd pull in from this set some
other information so that's a visual
difference between blending and joining
question number eight is what is the
difference between a live and an extract
so first we'll talk about live and we'll
say that your dashboard is connected
live to a database and so a live
connection will query that database
every time you open up the dashboard or
visualization so that you're getting the
most recent information each time and
it's useful for if you need information
that's a little bit more real time
however it can be slower especially if
your queries are complicated with an
extract it will run the query beforehand
i'd store the information on tableau
server or on your local machine and so
that it's faster to get to however it is
not real-time information so if you had
a refresh of your extract that runs
every day in the morning and then during
the day somebody has made a change to
your database they won't see that change
on your dashboard until the next time
the refresh runs for your extract in
tableau
you can set
if you want the connection to be live or
extract when you first are making your
data source and this is a tableau
desktop in tableau
public you don't have that option did
you know that
the reason that extracts are faster is
because tableau doesn't need to access
the database each time it builds the
visualization and did you know that you
can set up a refresh schedule on tableau
server in order to be able to see your
extracted data update
question nine what is a calculated field
and how will you create one so if we
look at our data set here
we have the opportunity to see the
difference between order date and ship
date so to create a calculated field
you click create calculated field with
this drop down arrow at the top or you
can right click in white space
create calculated field
then you give it a name and we're going
to call it
shipping delay
and we are going to do
a date diff
so if you don't see this dialog box here
you can click this arrow
to see that
our date part is day the start date is
order date and the end date is ship date
so to remember how to create a
calculated field it's by clicking this
down arrow and clicking create
calculated field and then writing your
query here
and a calculated field is an additional
field made up using the data that you
already have so
we've made a new field here and it has
the equal sign at the beginning that
might be worth mentioning how to tell if
it's a calculated field or if it was an
original field and then we can bring a
shipping delay
here and we can see the number of days
that it took between the order date and
the ship date we could also
duplicate a calculated field so now we
have shipping delay copy
and we're going to call this average
shipping delay
and we're going to encapsulate it
inside an average function
and now if we take off the order id the
order date and the ship date
it's automatically summing up those days
but we can bring on our average shipping
delay
and you can see on average how many days
it took
and let's change
our number here to
include decimal places
so a calculated field is a new field
made from existing data
it can be used to create more robust
visualizations and it does not affect
the original data set for example we
made our average delay function here
using data from our original data set
question 10 how can you display top five
and last five sales in the same view
you can show top five and last five
sales for a same dimension by creating a
set
so let's take a look at doing that here
we have
our customers so let's bring on customer
name
and we're going to do it based on profit
so now that we've done it on profit we
can see these are our top five profit
and i've sorted it by profit
and
here's our bottom five
and we can create a set by coming and
clicking on the dimension that we want
the set to be based on we'll right click
there
and we will
[Music]
come to create and click set
we're going to call this top customers
top buy field top 5
buy sum of profit and now we have a set
it makes a set section here
now we're going to make a second set
off of customer name
create set
bottom customers
bottom
5 by sum of profit we'll hit okay and
now we're going to combine these two
sets so i'm going to control click and
then we have both of them selected and
we're going to click create combined set
top and bottom
customers
and we're going to have it include all
members of both sets
and now we can pull top and bottom
customers onto filters
and you can see our top five and our
bottom five so if we
control drag profit onto color
then it's colored by that as well so key
thing to remember is that you can use it
sets to create to show both the top and
the bottom in the same visualization and
that you can combine those sets
is there a difference between sets and
groups in tableau the answer to this is
yes
you can describe a group as being
simpler and using only one dimension to
determine the group whereas a set can be
more complex so you could say sets are
more complex and you can use conditions
to create the sets and you can also use
multiple dimensions and measures to
create the sets
for example here we create a group of
subcategory so we grab all of these
things together and can group it and
that will be
we'll have copiers and envelopes and
then we'll have one group of all of
these together
over here you could create a set
that looks at sales and profits to
create its set so the best way i can
describe this is by looking at what we
did here and so we were able to use
dynamic
filtering here to create our sets
and where we'll look at the top five or
the bottom five and let's do the same
thing we did there but use a group so
for a group we could see that these
we've sorted it and we can say
one two three four five this is the top
five so we could create
a group that's this paper clip here and
now we have a group of the top five and
it's added that group it makes a new
group customer name group and it put it
on the color for us now let's go to the
bottom
and we're gonna go one two three four
five and we'll create
our group
so now we have a top five group at
bottom five group so let's name them
that and we'll do that by clicking edit
alias
top customers
okay and we'll come here and we'll
rename that
bottom
customers
okay we'll put our top customers on top
and then let's hide all the others so
we'll click exclude there and now we
have a similar visualization as we had
before for our sets
top bottom however a key difference here
is that we had to go through and select
the top five and the bottom five so
let's say that
maybe cindy or let's say henry goldwyn
has suddenly
had much more positive profit associated
with them if that changes he's gonna
still stay in our group this group is
just using these customer names to
determine who's in the group so the
group is henry sherrell luke grant and
cindy no matter
if their data changes so say tomorrow
all this data is different it's still
going to put these people into the group
however the sets as you saw before is
based off of the profit the sum of
profit and who has the top five and who
has the bottom five if raymond suddenly
has a lot less profit and falls out of
the group then
the groups won't pick it up but the sets
will so that's one thing to remember is
that it could be based on conditions and
then you saw how we took two sets and
put them together into our combined
group you could also have a set
that is based off of two different
dimensions or two different measures and
that's how you could put those two sets
together and get dynamic sets
so the major differences
as we saw is that a group is just based
off of one dimension
and a set can have conditions and be
based on off of other dimensions
also you need to know that groups cannot
be used in calculated fields but sets
can
question 12 what is a parameter in
tableau and give an example
a parameter is a dynamic value that a
customer could select
and you can use it to replace constant
values in calculations filters and
reference lines so for example here we
determined we wanted bottom five and top
five customers but let's give them some
options so we'll create a parameter
and we'll call it select
number of
top
bottom
customers
and we're going to
let it be a range
with a minimum of five and a maximum of
20
and a step size of five so we'll let
them go five at a time
okay
now if we click show parameter control
we can see our parameter control and you
can do 5 10 15 or 20. but since it's not
in any of our calculated fields or sets
or filters
then it's not making any difference so
let's put it inside of these
we'll edit our set and instead of top or
bottom five
we'll click bottom select number of top
bottom customers so now it's taking our
parameter and inserting it in
to our set there we'll do the same thing
with top customers
okay and now right now we see top five
bottom five if we change it now we see
top ten bottom ten fifteen and there's
our twenty
so it replaces a constant value and
allows the end user to select the value
question 13 what is the difference
between tree maps and heat maps
so let's first talk about what each of
these are
heat maps compare categories using size
and color i think the biggest thing
about heat maps is the color size is
somewhat optional so let's build this
visualization quickly
so
we have
region category
and subcategory
and we're making a heat map so
we want to bring profit onto color
and you can see we've got hotter and
colder in this case
for a heat map we might want to change
so in this case what it's doing is
hotter is negative but we could reverse
that and then hotter is positive and so
hotter maybe means this is where more
activity is
we can also double click on profit
we can also bring profit onto label
and we'll change this to
square and now it's marked at what
everything is so a heat map will use
color to draw your eye to the places
where there's heat or maybe activity we
could also use size in this case so it's
not just defined by color necessarily
maybe we want the size to be defined by
sales so we get things that are bigger
but they're blue which means that they
are bigger in sales but their profit is
negative and it draws your eyes to
technology so machines in the south are
doing a lot of sales but they're not
having positive profit necessarily
also you can see some things that have
darker colors
but are smaller so high profit but not a
lot of sales so that is a heat map a
tree map is used to represent
hierarchical data now hierarchy is the
term you need to remember when you're
talking about the difference between a
tree map and a heat map
in the heat map
none of these boxes have to do with the
hierarchy with each other whereas with a
tree map you can see that this box has a
thick white line between it and the
other ones and that means that that
section are all connected so these are
all technology and the bigger this
section is that means the bigger the
let's see size is based off of profit so
this bigger section means that
technology has more profit than
furniture so let's build this one when i
build tree maps i like to use our show
me tool so here's tree map and it says
one or more dimensions or one and one to
two measures so we're gonna grab
category and we're going to control
click sub category and we're going to
control click profit and
sales and we'll click on our tree map
perfect and so the darker the color
that means the more sales there is and
that's pretty similar to our
heat map over here so the color
indicated
in this case it was profit so the color
indicates the difference and the size
indicates the difference and that's true
over here the color indicates a
difference and the size indicates a
difference however there is a hierarchy
to it over here you can see
that there is um hierarchies because we
have furniture and then that puts that
all together under furniture
and then here's the subcategories
however if you were trying to compare
furniture to office supplies it's really
difficult to tell which one has more
sales but if we go over to sheet 7 that
has our tree map on it you can see
really quickly that office supplies has
much more
sales
than furniture in this case office
supplies has much more profit than
furniture biggest difference is that
tree maps have the hierarchy question
number 14 what is the difference between
twbx
and twb so these are all
tableau file formats and the twbx
contains all of the unnecessary
information to build the visualization
so it's called a packaged workbook
and it compresses it all together
however the twb just contains
instructions about how to interact with
the data source so when it's building a
visualization tableau will look at the
data source and then build the
visualization with an extract it
contains all of the information that you
need so all the data is wrapped up
inside of there and there's no
connection that has to be made between
tableau and the data source because it's
all right inside whereas with the twb it
has to connect to the data service or
else it doesn't have the data to build
the visualizations it just knows it has
the instructions of what to do with that
data so the biggest difference is twb
twbx has the data inside of it whereas
the twp only has the instructions
question 15 explain the difference
between tableau worksheet dashboard
story and workbook perfect here's a
breakdown and explanation of each of
those and in tableau this entire thing
that we've been looking at all these
sheets
is a workbook
however this sheet 7 is just one
worksheet all of them together is a
workbook and sheet 7 is a worksheet the
big difference between a worksheet and a
dashboard is that the worksheet is just
one
visualization and so it is only one set
of columns and rows here and a dashboard
could contain multiple visualizations so
if we wanted to see our heat map and our
tree map on the same page that would be
a dashboard and then a story
is somewhat similar
to a presentation mode and so you can
have different pages and so we could say
here is our
heat map and then we could make another
page
and look at our
tree map
and then look at our heat map
and then we could duplicate that page
and we could
say let's focus on
furniture so we're going to highlight
furniture
and then so if we were to go through
these one at a time
we would say here's our tree map and
then we would look at information there
and we would say here's our heat map and
then the next screen will say let's
focus on furniture and you can see that
it highlighted furniture for me when i
went to the next scene so a story
can show you things one at a time it's
like a presentation mode so the
differences are the workbook contains
the sheets and the dashboards of the
stories the worksheet is a single view
dashboard is multiple views and a story
is a sequence a sequence is a good
keyword to remember when you're
describing a story and did you know
that the only place that you can access
the dimensions and the measures and
custom fields we've made is on a
worksheet so when you're looking at a
dashboard
so on a worksheet we see dimensions and
measures when you're looking at a
dashboard you no longer see dimensions
and measures what you do see are all of
the worksheets similarly when you look
at a story you no longer see
any dimensions and measures but you do
see all the worksheets and the
dashboards
question 16 what do you understand by
blended axis with a blended axis you can
use two measures that share an axis and
that means they necessarily have the
same scale so let's build something with
a blended axis
so we could make a visualization that
looks at
sales
over time
we'll bring on order date
and
let's just
do order date by
month there we go
so we can see sales over time and say we
wanted to
also see profit
this is two visualizations that have two
different axes but if we wanted them to
have the same axes
and just the same marks card you see how
i made two different marks cards we
could bring on
measure values
and take off all the measures that we
don't want
we just want
when we take them off here it's creating
this filter here for measure names
and let's take off these two extra
visualizations and now we have a
visualization that has a blended axes
for sales over time and profit over time
and you can see that they necessarily
have the same axes there is no second
axes
what is the use of a dual axis and how
do you create one perfect so dual axis
allows you to compare measures and you
can have two different scales so if we
had this same visualization that same
information that we wanted to see with
again profit and sales
over time
we'll do
okay great and we wanted them to have
the same axes we could right click on
the second pill
of the measures
and click dual axis and now you can see
that they do not
share the same axis and you can see
profit is much higher here right there
and so the use of this would be
sometimes you need things to have
different axes if you come here and you
click synchronize axes you end up
getting a pretty similar visualization
but you do get two separate marks cards
so a key thing to bring up if you are
asked the difference between a blended
axis and a dual axis chart
is
one that the blended axis uses the same
scale and a dual axis could have two
different scales and two a dual axis has
two marks cards so let's say we wanted
our profit
to not be a line chart but to be a bar
chart that gives you that option when
you go to
the blended axis we only have one mark's
card so we change it to bar everything
is bar
but back over here we change it to
circles and we see the circles
so if we wanted to show sales by year
and profit ratio by year in the same
view that's where two different scales
could be handy let's build that
visualization
so we'll make a new chart
and we'll bring on
sales
and
profit ratio
over time
that is profit i still did profit so
i'll drag profit ratio right over top of
profit there we go and you can see that
they can't use the same scale because
this is a percentage and so
uh if we had them on a blended axis 20
is really 0.2 and it would just be so
tiny
but if we wanted them on the same area
to act to apply to the same space here
we could dual access it that you can
still see useful information there but
otherwise this would just be in such a
tiny tiny space so our profit ratio
would just show up right here almost
like a straight line
question 18 what will the following
function return
left three comma tableau here's the
question again and here are the
potential answers tab
or eau error or none of the above so
just take a moment and see if you can
answer this question correctly go ahead
and pause the video and if you get the
answer you can comment below and then we
will discuss
we've taken some time to
answer this question
and let's go ahead and see what the
answer is the answer is it will return
an error that's because the syntax for
our left is that the string must go
first first you say left then you put
the string and then you put the number
so let's talk about what left does it
returns a specific number of characters
from the left and if you had done it
correctly the left is this side so if
you had done the string first and you
said you want three the result would be
t a b
there's also one called right
and that would come from the other end
and go eau so that's where these answers
came from question 19 how do you handle
null and other special values tableau is
unable to plot null values or zeros or
negative values on a logarithmic axis
and so it will display an indicator in
the lower right corner which looks like
this
telling you that is unable to draw those
two points
so when you click on the indicator you
can choose from the following first you
can choose to filter the data which will
exclude the null values from the
visualization or you can click show data
at the default position so we'll look at
both of these
so you click on your indicator and it
will say what do you want to do with
these two values if we click filter the
data then you can see that it has
filtered those that blank space and
drawn a line connecting
those dates in between
even though there is no point for the
29th or the 30th
it goes straight from the 28th to the
31st so what's happening on our
visualization is it's adding this filter
if we press the back button we see that
filter disappears if we come down and
select filter the data it adds a filter
here
that then
only includes non-null values
so those are all removed from our
visualization and up to this point you
can see that we have one point per day
the 21st the 22nd the 23rd 24th but then
when we get to the 28th we don't have a
29th or 30th and it just draws that line
to the 31st assuming
that during that time period
what we want is a straight line now the
other option would be
we could also make the assumption that
whenever there is a null value that
actually means zero sales have happened
during that time so that's when you
would click show data at default
position
and now it draws those two points
at the zero line
and when you hover it still shows sales
null
so then when you hover here you can see
the actual amount for sales during that
time
so if a null in your data means zero
then show a default position is good for
you and if it doesn't necessarily mean
zero
then you can
filter the data or you can leave it
disconnected like this
question 20 find the top product
subcategories by sales within each
delivery method which subcategory is
ranked number two for first class ship
mode if you'd like to pause the video
and work on this on your own and then
see if
what you did matches what we did then
you're welcome to now at this time and
comment below what your answer is
okay
so we want to know by subcategory
and by ship mode
which
subcategory ranks the highest for each
ship mode so in sales so if we take
sales
onto the visualization we can see that
by the ship mode
it's already split up and we could see
that
maybe this one for standard class it
would be chairs you can kind of look
through and kind of oh it's not chairs
chairs isn't number one because we have
this one it's phones so to make it
easier we're going to
change sum of sales to a rank table
calculation so we're going to come here
and click add table calculation
and we're going to change the
calculation type to rank and it's going
to rank them
in order
of sales
so but we right now we can see that it's
highlighting that's called calculation
assistance helping us understand
how it's ranking us so if i and select
calculation assistance then it gets rid
of it but you can see right now it's
ranking it
across the table so it says accessories
has most sales in standard class then
second class then first class then same
day
and that's not what we want to see we
want to see it up and down
we want to see for first class which
subcategory has the highest sales and
second highest sales so let's turn back
on our calculation assistance and we're
going to click table down
and you can see now it's going up and
down within first class what are all the
subcategories ranked so that's what we
want now as soon as you click things in
the table calculation it applies it over
here so you don't have an ok button
so you can just close that out
and you can see now we have a rank up
and down
for the subcategory so back to the
question was which subcategory is ranked
second for first class ship mode here's
first class let's find number two it's
chairs
question number 21
find the customer with the lowest
overall profit what is his slash her
profit ratio let's go ahead and build
this visualization
customer profit
and we're going to
bring all of our customers on
and then we're going to bring on profit
let's do it as a visualization so i'll
bring it on to columns
and then let's sort smallest to biggest
so cindy stewart
is the one who has our lowest profit
and now to figure out her profit ratio
we need to make a calculated field which
i've already made here
so in this calculated field we take the
sum of profit and divided by the sum of
sales we do this
so that it will sum up all of the profit
per row
so for cindy we want to take all of her
profit
over all of her transactions and divide
it by all of her sales instead of doing
it row by row profit divided by sales
profit divided by sales and then summing
that up at the end so
we'll take our profit ratio and put it
onto label
and we can see
what her profit ratio is and since it's
a ratio here i have it in a percent
if you don't have your profit ratio set
up as a percent it will look like this
negative 1.65 question number 22 what is
the rank function in tableau we got a
look at the rank function earlier when
we figured out our top product
subcategories by sales and what was
ranked number two so
i'm sure you're familiar with what
ranking is which is assigning something
a position like first place or second
place usually within a category and
usually based on a measure so
tableau
is able to rank in several different
ways where you can do
rank or rank dense rake modified or rank
unique and we'll take a look at these
individualization here and talk about
the difference but if you are asked
about
the rank function in tableau it's worth
bringing up that there are several
different ways to rank and going into a
little bit of detail on those different
ways will be helpful for you so
let's build off of this rank example
instead so we're going to bring on our
store and we've got store a b c d and e
and then we'll bring on our sales
and store a had ten dollars and e had
forty dollars
so
now let's create a calculated field
we're going to call it rank
we're going to do a rank calculated
field
based on
sales we're going to do a rank
calculated field based on sum of sales
perfect
okay
we'll double click on rank and we can
see first place is the one who had the
most sales and fifth place is the one
with the least sales now we had a tie
here at 20 and it gave them both third
place and then it skipped fourth place
and went to fifth place and that's how
the basic rank function works so if we
duplicate it
and we edit our copy
and we're going to make this one
rank dense
you know what let's do rank modified
second
okay
and we bring on rank modified
let's have this happen in order so sum
of sales then rank then rank modified
now you can see
it's similar to rank first second but
then it skips third and goes to fourth
and then fifth so over here it gave a
buyer number when there was a tie
and over here it gave them the lower
number when there was a tie
so if you could remember that
rank gives them the higher number and
rank modified gives them the lower
number that will be helpful
for your interview
now we're going to take a look at rank
dense
rank dense apply
and rank dense doesn't skip a number so
it goes one two three four and it
condenses
the ranking
without any skipping any numbers
and now let's
do our last one
which is going to be
rank unique
okay
and with rank unique it refuses to give
to
the same rank
and how it determines when there is a
tie is it will look at the dimension
that's in the visualization and do
whichever one comes first in ascii so it
goes 1 2 and these are a tie and since
capital b comes before
lowercase c
then it's doing b first then c
then a
so in your interview it would be really
impressive to talk about the different
versions of ranks
and how they all work
question 23 how can you embed a web page
in a dashboard so we're just going to
build this and then explain it so i have
here my map by sales and we're going to
build a dashboard
we'll bring on first we'll change our
layout so i can fill up the screen
then let's bring on my map
and i've added the state name and the
sales on the map here
for
an embedded web page you can grab it
from the objects section the web page
and then you could put a url right
inside of here
and then that will embed that page
underneath
so if we wanted to do wikipedia or
something we can hit ok and it will take
you to wikipedia
but what we're going to do is make this
page dynamic based on what state you
select it'll look up that wikipedia page
for that state so you could maybe look
at some population data
we'll close that and we'll try again
we're going to bring on our web page
it's going to ask for a url but we're
just going to hit ok and not provide it
with a url
and then we'll use this dashboard action
and create a url action
that then contains our url
with our state
appended at the end which is how
wikipedia formats their url so we'll hit
okay
oh i forgot one more thing let's do it
on select instead of on menu so whenever
we select something it will run this
okay okay and now when we select texas
it brings up the texas wikipedia page
when we select nebraska
it'll change
so the major points to know on how to
embed a web page is you bring it in from
the objects section and then if they ask
how to make a dynamic you use dashboard
actions
and a url action
question 24 design a view to show region
wide profit and sales
so one way you could do this is by
bringing on region and then bringing on
profit
and
sales
and that's a pretty simple view of
profit and sales by region however
one thing that interviewers may be
looking for when asking a question about
region
is your mapping capabilities in tableau
so
what we could do
is
region is not a geographic location so
it takes a little bit of creativity but
if you bring on state by double clicking
it and it maps out the states
you can
make it a map here and it fills it in
and then you can bring region onto color
and that splits it up by region
and then if you bring on profit
and sales on the labels
and let's also bring on the state onto
labels
and then you can look at your profit and
sales inside of their regions inside of
their states
and so um
that is another view where you could
look at
profit and sales by region and it's a
little bit more
takes advantage of some of the mapping
capabilities in tableau it may be what
your interviewer is looking for so you
could discuss multiple ways to look at
it but here is one way that we could
recommend it question 25 how can you
optimize the performance of a dashboard
there are multiple ways to optimize the
performance of the dashboard some of the
things that you might mention is that
you could exclude any fields you're not
using from your visualization just keep
them off or you can use extract filters
and if you recall extract filters will
remove out rows of data from the extract
and so only focus on the data that you
need another thing you can do is try and
limit the amount of filters that you use
and when you do use filters avoid using
quick filters and you can use action
filters and parameter filters instead
filters cause your queries in the
database to be a little bit more complex
and can keep them from running as
efficiently as they could use min and
max instead of average because average
functions require more processing time
than min max also you can try to use
boolean and numerical calculations
because computers do better with
integers and booleans than they do with
strings
so quick things to remember is keep your
data simple
use fewer filters and when you do use
filters use parameters or actions avoid
using average use min and max and avoid
using strings by using booleans and
numerical calculations
question 26 which visualization will be
used in the given scenarios here we have
three scenarios of opportunities that
you might want to visualize and there is
no perfectly exact answer for these but
there are some visualizations that tend
better for certain types of data however
there sometimes could be
different ways to visualize it and it
doesn't mean that these are the very
best ways however if you want to take a
moment go ahead and pause the video and
go through
and figure out what your three answers
are and comment below and we can discuss
what we think the best ways are so first
we want to show aggregated sales totals
across a range of product categories and
subcategories we want to show the
duration of events or activities and we
want to show quarter wise profit growth
so to show aggregated sales totals
across a range of products subcategories
and categories you could use a tree map
the reason we bring up a tree map here
is that they are known for allowing you
to show a visualization
using hierarchies so let's take a look
at that we're going to show aggregated
sales totals across a range of product
categories and subcategories so if we
come here and make a sheet
and we want to see sales across control
click
category and subcategory and then we
click a tree map
what happens
it's showing
it based on size and color and so it
shows the size the bigger the size the
more sales and the darker the color the
more sales and the reason we choose a
tree map over just a normal heat map is
that
it makes a category here so we can
compare this box that has all the
technology in it see how all of these
are technology to this box that has all
of the office supplies and you can
quickly see the technology
has more than office supplies but you
can also see that phones has more than
art and it breaks it up as a hierarchy
and breaks it up based on your sum of
sales and question two is show duration
or events a duration of events or
activities and you would use a gantt
chart gun charts are used to show
duration
and each of these lines
is a duration so it's like it's got a
start date and end date basically and it
shows you how long everything takes
and the last one is to show
profit growth and you can use a
waterfall chart and that looks like
this where you can see how the profit
changes across every period and if it's
going up or down and each one of these
show you how much up or how much down
they go but as we said there are
potentially other answers to this
question so
if you have any questions about why we
didn't say this chart or that chart go
ahead and comment below and we can start
a discussion question 27 what would you
do if some countries or provinces or any
geographical entity is missing and
displaying a null when you use map view
so when you start to map the
geographical fields that you have
sometimes tableau is unable to map them
because their locations are unknown or
ambiguous meaning a lot of states have a
city called springfield and it won't
know where to draw that city so for
example
let's look at
here so we've taken city as our detail
and it's drawn a lot of cities however
it's got a lot of unknown values here so
if this question comes up you've got to
remember these three things
you can edit locations filter the data
or show data at default position
edit locations allows you to correct the
locations
by putting in their unique names i'll
show you an example of this filter the
data means just keep them off of the
view and show day that default position
means show it at zero zero on the map
so edit locations
here we can say here's all of these
cities that seem to exist
in multiple locations and we could say
well we know what state they're in as
well and that should help you answer the
question so you could choose a field
that will define the state so here we're
saying the state is from the state field
and we hit okay
and then it can draw the rest of those
cities sometimes you want to keep them
off perhaps maybe they spelled city
names wrong and you just want to exclude
those
and the last one is show data default
position
which is 0 0
28 what is a level of detail expression
a level of detail expression or an lod
expression is maybe the way they will
present it to you and lod stands for
level of detail so obviously it helps
you get to the level of detail that you
want in your visualization but it also
is used to run complex queries at the
data source level instead of all in the
tableau interface
so we're going to take a look at an
example here which is adding a dimension
to an already
calculated aggregate field
in our case we're going to exclude a
dimension from a calculated field so
here we have
a visualization that i built and right
now it's just looking at sales by
category and subcategory but say we
wanted to look at the total sales for
furniture
and not break it up by the subcategory
so if we take off subcategory
then we get the total sales for
furniture
but if we want a side by side and so
that you could see the total sales for
furniture and you can see
it broken up by subcategory you can use
a level of detail calculation
this i already made the field for it
i've called it exclude subcategory so
that's right here
right now it just contains sales
but we're going to use the level of
detail calculation exclude
and we're going to tell it what to
exclude which is
subcategory and then we're going to do
some
of sales so that it will sum it up for
us
and once i apply these changes it should
change it here
and our labels
perfect so now we can see that it's
ignoring the fact that this is chairs
and this is tables this is bookcases
it's just doing the total for furniture
and just ignoring these because we told
it to exclude so level of detail helps
you to be able to define the level that
you want to in your visualization
regardless of what else exists on your
visualization
it also moves some of the logic from
inside of tableau to the actual database
and there are three level of detail
calculations this will be an important
thing to bring up in interviews they
might give you brownie points when you
can remember all three of the level of
detail calculations which are
we looked at exclude
but we have
exclude
include
and
fixed
so include exclude are pretty easy to
remember and just always remember fixed
as well question 29 how do you calculate
daily profit measure using level of
detail here's another opportunity for
you to pause the video and take a look
at calculating a daily profit measure
using level of detail we are going to
get started
profitable level of detail so we want to
have a daily profit measure
and i already made a place for it profit
per day
and we want to look at the profit for a
day regardless of what else is on the
visualization so we're going to use a
fixed
instead of an include or an exclude
which will only take into account
whatever you put in for include or
exclude fixed will take into account
everything it will ignore everything
else on the visualization and only look
at what's in your list here so we're
going to fix it by day
and you have to put a colon
and we're going to do a sum of profit
for each of those days
and close it off so now we have our
profit per day
we'll hit ok and now we're going to make
a kpi
which for our purposes if profit for a
day is greater than 2000 then that day
is highly profitable if it's less than
zero then it's unprofitable otherwise it
is profitable so we're going to go if
our profit per
day is greater than two thousand
then
we're going to call it highly profitable
elsift
we're going to do less than or equal to
zero
then
profitable
else
otherwise it is profitable
you always have to end with an end
great
okay
so now we're going to make
visualizations and it's going to look at
it by year
now it all fits in one view
we
can rotate these labels to make it
easier to see and we're going to bring
on
order id
but now it's showing like a lot of
orders and so we actually want it to be
used as a measure and we're going to do
account distinct
great so now we can see how many orders
we're on each day
and so that's helpful for us to see how
many orders are on this day each day but
we want to see
the orders on each day that are highly
profitable versus unprofitable versus
just profitable so we're going to use
our level of detail
and break it up in a different section
so we have highly profitable profitable
and unprofitable let's also bring this
on to our color
highly profitable profitable and
profitable and now we can see
that the profitable ones are going up
unprofitable ones seem to be going down
in 2015 and that's nice but they are
going up and highly profitable is not
very many
oh in this case we did area charts
instead of just line charts to make that
change you change it from automatic to
area and that helps you see some of that
spatially as well comment below if you
were able to make this visualization on
your own
question 30. how can you schedule a
workbook in tableau after publishing it
so when you publish a workbook in
tableau if you've used an extract you're
going to need to refresh that extract so
in tableau when you create a tableau
data source and it's an extract version
of the data source it will no longer
update if the data from your database
updates so somebody's made some changes
to your database or your excel file and
you want to see that in your tableau
visualization well you're not going to
see it but you can see it if you make a
refresh so you do that on tableau server
and you can remember that you have to
get all the way to your data source so
you can go to your data sources or to
your workbooks
and then you look at the data source on
your workbook and you go actions extract
refresh and then you select schedule a
refresh so that looks like this you can
press these three dots next to it and
click refresh extracts or you can go to
actions and then here you click schedule
a refresh instead of refresh now and
then oftentimes in tableau you'll have
several different options you can choose
daily at seven a.m or every four hours
if an interviewer is asking you
about how to schedule a refresh it might
be worthwhile bringing up the fact that
you only need to schedule a refresh
if you are
using an extract on your data source and
then that will help them know that you
know the difference between live and
extracts if they didn't ever ask that
question with that we have come to the
end of this session on tableau full
course
if you have any queries related to the
topics covered in this full course then
please feel free to let us know in the
comment section below our team of
experts will be happy to resolve your
queries
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you